[Music]
what's good everybody it's Gary ve uh
but you know that uh in New York City
what you're about to watch is a five
five
hour 5 Hour Mega Vlog uh from me in
Dubai a ton of content uh we did this
the last time I was there I think that
was eight hours uh but we packed it it's
tight tons of insight uh a perfect thing
to binge watch or play in the background
as you listen I hope you enjoy it have
the best holiday
ever you about your
perspective I just want to be happy
don't you want to be
[Music]
happy YouTube what's up so so grateful
that you clicked and you're about to
watch a new YouTube video but before you
do
2129315731
that is my texting Community platform
I'm doing a lot of one-on-one engagement
in there and also access opportunity
first looks in that environment 212
93157 31 join it now and now to the
video you've been wanting to watch okay
so first question would you please
describe your life in three words in
three words um
conviction
empathy and work ethic loveely okay uh
is there any excuse that makes it okay
to stay in a job that you
hate this is a tough question you know
there's always there's always an EXT ex
circumstance right just so much
adversity that in the short term I think
there are excuses to stay into a job
that you don't love right the the
reality is is that you may have bills to
pay you might have had your spouse may
pass away I mean that's a terrible thing
and you have to you have to keep that
job but in the long term sustained
staying in a job that you don't love is
always the wrong
formula uh what advice would you give to
people that can't find their true
passion finding your passion is a really
interesting game it falls into two
places one people just actually not
trying enough things you know did you
try to code did you try to cook did you
try selling uh something on the Internet
uh and then there's also just the the
level of some people love to use excuses
to not do it's very easy to say I can't
find my passion this way I'm not doing
it so it it's I find that those are two
uh two common moves uh when people
struggle to find their
passion uh so let's talk about your
downtime uh what is it like and how do
you deal with
it I um I love my downtime you know uh
you know when I'm not working my
professional career like spending time
with my family uh I'm an enormous uh
American football fan so the New York
Jets take up a lot of my downtime
um on vacations I get to think you know
I take a step back I get to be
thoughtful so I'm a pretty big fan of
downtime okay if we want to name one
thing that stresses you
out I think the one thing that stresses
me out is when um Executives in my
company are not treating other people
well okay now right now what social
platform are you dedicating most your
time uh for growing
you know it's interesting it's a very
interesting time for this question
because obviously Instagram is still a
very main focus but Tik Tok has taken up
a lot of my time over the last you know
60 days and I I'm seeing extreme growth
on that platform so if you would choose
would you choose Instagram or Tik Tok oh
I love that you followed that up
uh I would choose Tik Tok uh newspapers
versus books what would you read I
struggle reading so I don't read either
well but if I had to choose now that I
know how you like to roll uh I would
choose
newspapers okay name three people you
would like to invite for dinner in a
dream uh dinner table situation dead or
alive uh Randy the Macho Man Savage my
favorite wrestler who I unfortunately
never got to meet
uh and then the real you know it maybe a
copout answer but it's my true answer I
unfortunately really didn't know either
of my grandfathers and so I would would
love to have them there as well okay you
made Millions already what still gives
you the drive to go around FP things
you're sailing for buck
profit two things one I'm very
passionate to bring value to my
community and there are millions of
people that follow me who use the excuse
of having no money and by showing them
that I can buy something for a dollar
and sell it for 29 and do that a
thousand times and you start building a
base has been really rewarding and two I
genuinely like it I genuinely get an
enormous thrill for me the thrill of the
hunt and the Chase and the process have
always been far more interesting to me
than the money that comes along with it
and so making $12 on a stuffed animal
genuinely brings me more joy than making
a million dollars from a client with
Vayner
media okay so how do you manage being so
real so authentic and humble with all
this Fame and money
I think I was parented extremely well
you know I think I got lucky DNA so I
think I have that in me but I'm uh I I
got parented well and I I very I'm very
blessed with good perspective I'm uh I'm
generally the flattered you know I
appreciate even when you said before as
we were sitting down we all are right
fans like feels nice like I don't I
don't know how I I don't it's a very
interesting answer it's a very difficult
question to answer because the
alternative is so foreign the thought
that my success and the level of
attention I have now would
somehow create a scenario where I
thought I was better than somebody is
just not something that I have in my
mind I think Fame and money expose
people's truth I don't think it changes
them and luck luckily for me my truth is
I like people I'm a kind person I have a
lot of conviction and and and passion
and bravado but I but I do have a lot of
humility okay what message then do you
keep reminding yourself every day stay
like
this I really think a lot about the uh
health and well-being of my family and
and the fact that every morning that I
wake up that everybody's still alive and
healthy it gives me gratitude and I
become very grateful and
um gratitude is an
incredible uh intoxicating feeling that
leads to a lot of happiness and
perspective okay um three tips for
entrepreneurs please three tips um
number one self-awareness I think a lot
of entrepreneurs struggle with
understanding what they're good at and
what they're bad at and uh I'm very uh
passionate about that two patience it
just takes a long time to build
something meaningful so many
entrepreneurs raise Capital too fast um
expect things too fast which leads to
depression and insecurity I think
patience is an incredible foundation and
then three blind consumer Centric focus
it has to be about the customer it can't
be about the venture capitalist your
supplier you know you you it has to be
about the customer self-awareness
patience and being about the customer is
a winning formula for entrepreneurs okay
are emotions important in business
emotions are important but making
decisions based on your emotions getting
the best of you is bad so being
passionate being optimistic being
excited having
conviction that's incredible being upset
about something and then letting you
lose control of your discipline and then
firing back which leads to the demise of
your brand is a bad idea this has been
so unactive thank
you thank you thank you so
much yeah great we just do a
quick thank you so much thank you so
much thank you I'm hungry can i h yes of
course thank you so much you're welcome
you want to take a photo or when we
finished um let's take one yeah let's
one we get
her with the be
lovely nice thank you so much you're
welcome whenever you're ready guys Gary
yes sir welcome to to Dubai thank I
should say welcome back to Dubai you're
becoming a fan of the place I sure am so
we're here for the national Achievers
Congress what exactly is that and what
are you what what's happening today you
know I I I think it's a conference that
brings you know speakers into regions I
don't think it's anything too crazy I
think um but uh yeah I mean I'm super
excited to be speaking in the region at
this scale about consumer Trends and
opportunities and Entrepreneurship and
so I'm excited a lot of people who come
to to this event today and who see you
speak uh would you say they're of a
certain mindset uh are they
entrepreneurs and what do you who do you
think you're talking to when you when
you communicate on stage yeah I mean at
this event you know I have I have
several different groups I speak to um
entrepreneurs uh corporate Marketing
Executives uh you know Financial
investors and things of that nature uh
but yeah I think this one's an
entrepreneur based audience
um I think their mindset runs the gamut
I think some of them are looking for a
shortcut and an adren an adrenaline hit
from me and I try to put pressure on
them I'm like look you're going to feel
good for an hour now but that's not
going to solve anything so let's get
into the mindset and the strategies and
the tactics you need uh others are maybe
finally over the hump and are doing and
they're looking for that one Insight you
know I've have such a long track record
of being right about end consumer
Behavior so if you right now if you ride
the wave of Tik Tok and Linkedin like
I'm telling you good things will happen
and I think I'm starting to build that
reputation so I think people are coming
to hear if I've got a current
observation um yeah I I I'm very bullish
on Tik Tok and Linkedin and the organic
reach and uh because for a lot of people
they can't spend the ad
money uh podcasting content at scale
things like this so um yeah there's
always something um it's really fun when
there's a new platform like Tik Tok
because there's a real land grab uh a
lot of people benefit from it um so yeah
I'm excited about it and we all we see
you mentioned creating content and
that's sort of thing and we always see
how you produce your content and the
people you connect with at these events
how important is that to you do you uh
do you follow up with these people do
you invest in these people's companies
and uh are you aware of the impact that
you can have in just a few minutes with
individuals yeah I mean there's a lot of
followup we've hired people I've
invested in things we've I love doing
Karma like I I don't see something I
want to do but I'm like hey you should
meet Rick and you know so that's always
a lot of
fun uh yeah the third part of the
question
is borderline emotional like I can't
believe I was gifted with the ability to
be such a good communicator such an
authentic Communicator that
that I could talk to somebody for 8
minutes and something good can happen
for them it's it's beyond humbling it's
it's
borderline difficult to even fathom when
talking about Dubai in general when Tony
Robbins was here he mentioned about the
region having resources but it's
actually more about being resourceful
we're sitting here with a beautiful
backdrop of B alarab how much do you
think the entrepreneurship mindset and
the kind of spirit in a city like this
is important uh to to progress I think
it's important I think entrepreneurship
and Innovation have always been
important I think taking it to another
place I think it's important for the
people that are meant to do it my great
concern right now is that
entrepreneurship is cool and when
something's cool everybody wants to do
it yeah and uh so you know you have a
lot of fake
entrepreneurship and that fake
entrepreneurship is going to lead to a
lot of failures and a lot of unhappiness
and so even though I love it and even
though I benefit from it I like to speak
about hey just make sure that you are
one like you don't have to be one the
number six at Facebook did really well
uh you don't have to be the number one
okay interesting you grew up in in the
in the US uh you know the the American
dream entrepreneurship is almost part of
the the psyche and not just
entrepreneurship but the the hope and uh
there's many uh people that they can
follow there many heroes yes this region
doesn't have as many there isn't as much
hope there's a lot of people unemployed
a lot of young people who don't believe
it's possible what would you say to
those people I mean you I I would say
you find what you're looking for you
know in life you find what you're
looking for if you've decided that the
government only cares about the top 1%
that you know it's impossible here that
I've got no shot well then that's 100%
going to happen um my favorite thing to
tell people a lot of times is do you
know anybody like you at all that has
succeeded even people that have come
from the ghettos with with parents that
are drug addicts and and sexual abuse
kids know somebody that's gone on to do
something and and I I put pressure on
that I say look if that person could
then at least we have to both agree and
acknowledge that it is possible yeah and
once you create that you don't need a
100 Superstar entrepreneurs if there's a
single entrepreneur from Dubai over the
last 5 years that's built a meaningful
business from scratch without all the
advantages of like family money and
things that nature if one exists one has
to then argue that it's possible I love
it okay amazing touching on that you
know there's a lot of kind of press
coverage for unicorns and big companies
you know does does this region does the
US need that what do you think is a is a
business viable I think that's you're
starting to see that with the Wei work
situation I I think that era is coming
to an end it's because there's so much
money in the system um we've we've
glamorized these companies that are
don't have business
fundamentals um and uh you know it's why
if you go you know it's funny I just put
out a search engine on gary.com search
okay you can search almost every word
I've said On video okay W um I guarantee
you made a new Google for yourself yeah
and I I guarant I'm actually have no
idea but I can't wait to Google or
Google I can't wait to look uh how many
times I've said unicorn I guarantee it's
very few and it's only an answering
questions like this it's uh it's not
something that I've been excited to
glamorize cuz I don't think I think
those are Financial Arbitrage machines
not businesses so when we're looking at
Dubai as a regional and Global business
Capital the by the par measures of
success isn't unicorns it's more
businesses sustainable jobs growth and
things like that that's what we should
be looking us Dubai and every other part
of the world
yeah I mean what are we doing here like
we're we're we're glamorizing people
that are good at raising
Capital yeah exactly that does that's
not the game I want to play yeah you
know like that might make one or two
people some
money but that's not interesting to me I
was luy enough to spend some time in
your offices this summer and I was taken
by the Kare um that there's probably
almost there was 900 people at the time
probably closer to a th000 now uh is
that is that what's important as a
business when you say building a mean of
Miss I'm trying to catch a f good
building a meaningful meaningful
long-term business is that what you mean
is it about uh the economy and jobs for
me I like people I like building
something that has Legacy yeah like for
me and for other people they want to
raise so much Capital that they take 50
to $500 million off the table and
whether the business succeeds in 10
years or not is irrelevant they'll get
theirs and by the way I don't like it
it's not my steas but I'm not interested
in judging other as long as not you know
as long it's not fraud as long it's not
hurting so you know um but yeah I think
we I for me it is I want to build
something sustainable I'm in year 10 of
Vayner media you know what is Vayner
media for people who you know there's
many companies what what are they all
them what's their function I see so
vayer Vayner X is what you're referring
to as the holding company Vayner media
is the kind of classic advertising
agency for the big Fortune 500 companies
there's a company called the Sasha Group
which is built named after my dad built
for small businesses cuz vayer is $2
million in fee these can be you know
150,000 there's Tracer uh data analytics
platform that we used at Boehner that
we're spinning out that's a SAS
business uh there's the gallery Media
Group you know 3 years ago I bought
purewow.com I wanted to get into digital
publishing we launched 1:37 p.m. so
that's exciting Vayner
Productions the production facility we
use uh to produce all of our our stuff
um so you know it it's a it's a holding
company yeah interesting and where do
you there's a lot of Trend in the US at
the moment and that's spinning over
globally with OT streaming platforms
Disney plus yes um many of these Apple
TV plus uh many of these platforms how
do you see all that what age are we in
we're in the uh second quarter of a four
quarter game of Ott taking over Network
and cable totally totally wow yeah once
Sports gives their rights to Ott it will
be over that's why we're in the second
quarter and Ott has and streaming are we
are we heading into kind of are we going
to be watching sports and headsets is it
most is it still on our phone is it
streaming and is it sports that way yeah
I mean I think it's you know look I
think if you're if you have the option
to watch sports on a huge TV or your
phone you're going to watch on T on a
huge TV if you're got to go run out and
go to a wedding and the big game's on
it's nice to be able to stream it it's
more that the networks um are able to
create altern that we're interested in
meaning it's exciting to pay $6 $7 a
month and have the entire Disney Library
that's a good deal compared to what we
used to pay for for Content so we're
going to buy up that we're going to be
able to go to our alak cart bundles
we're going to cancel our cable and be
in the Netflix Disney Plus Peacock and
sports this and you know and I think the
long tale of Ott is very long I mean
I've I consider that I I debate that I'm
going to launch a vayer OT in 5 years
where I just going to ask what that
means for Vayner media yeah I mean I
think I can launch my own Ott and put my
Content Library on there and produce
original content and buy up content so I
I think
Ott is second quarter I think you're
getting the big players right now we're
finding out the who are the global
players the regional players but I think
over time you I I think there's a viable
business if you think about it why can't
somebody who's got 13 great shows part
of their YouTube Network spin that out
making an Ott and and charge $66.99 a
month but would it be the same as cable
you know TVs in the home isn't the same
relationship of streaming OT and the
mobile because there's a lot more noise
no I think both will both will both will
be mobile I mean cable providers are
letting you consume okay I don't think
the mobile home I think cable forces you
to buy a ton of [__] you don't want okay
interesting you're buying cable as a
bundle yeah we don't want that I don't
watch Lifetime or Bravo or
Cinemax why am I paying for it okay when
are we going to see Vayner media in
Dubai in the Middle East I would say
we'll see Vayner media in the Middle
East in the next within the next 36
months for sure okay brilliant on that
note Gary we'll let you do your talk
today and it's been pleasure as always
thanks for having me thanks a lot
cool cool perect awesome thank you
you're welcome yeah photo yeah
thanks awes Brant thanks a lot
appreciate it it's great to see
you and he said I was going this is Al
Ali is in turn for me awesome how are
you he dm'd me because he said he heard
like that's the best way you should DM
people and tell them you'll work for
free so so he dm' me and Andis and a
bunch of famous people and said I want
to do some work for you for free and I'm
the only one that bit and so he's doing
some great work he's working the event
today and tomorrow and he's helping so I
wanted to get a minute to get a picture
with you since we got a few minutes and
then we'll head out but um he did the
right thing and he's volunteering and
working for free and hustling he's a
college student here and I said come um
meet Gary and then he's going to be he's
working no idea like how much youve cuz
thing is like I was 17 I was in high
school I didn't know was I going to go
down the typical route so uni blah blah
blah but then I knew deep down that like
I wanted much more than this but I just
didn't know how to get it and I felt
arrogant for asking more but then like
when I started watching your videos at
first I was like okay so I'm not the
only one that thinks like that there's
so many people and then I started the
only book that I've read so far which is
bad I know but it's CR I I've I don't
read books either brother I get it it's
really nice list to your podcast like
every day driving to like seriously your
words like inspir me so much thank you
so much such Anon thank you my friend
how are you all good I'm so happy to be
here we're happy to have you here thank
you so much want to take it yeah do you
want to take it with the view Dubai
behind
you okay and than you thank
you I got I'll take it yeah I'll share
with
you oh that's so cute yeah thank you so
much man for everything thank you thank
you so much one day I'm going to be able
to like I'm going to be standing there
and say like dare help me get there
thank you brother thank you how's it
been going all is good everything's good
we've been working uh hopefully you like
and the page yes very much actually I
wanted to come personally it's such an
honor to be with you today and we hope
to do a lot of stuff together thank you
we uh we have very big dreams and
Ambitions for the region so I'm sure
there'll be many opportunities in the
future definitely there are a lot of
opportunities here and back in Egypt and
we'll be trying to shoot across the days
a few I really really really am
committed like like I'd like to book
this December maybe when we're in
Minnesota we'll get on with my admins
I'm 100% Going to the Egyptian Film
Festival yeah yeah n is waiting for a do
you have does he have the date next
third week in September firmly firm why
don't you make sure yeah make sure you
get it because I will definitely minimum
be there for that yeah yeah which is
exciting yeah and actually there's a lot
of potential back in Egypt right now
things are progressing quite well and
there's a huge opportunity for even
Sasha company and bner media there's a
lot of potential okay so um Pepsi in
Egypt which I met they they flew in
today I got them a free ticket they're
coming to meet you because they want to
host an event in Egypt around
entrepreneurship so they're going to
you're going to see them today and the
person who's organizing the event
that they want to do for you is also
coming in awesome so they're you'll see
them CU I got them tickets and after you
speak we're going to have a meet and
greet with some of those people I saw
that okay so thank you we just are going
to we have a few minutes we're just
planning what we're going to do tomorrow
okay you take that good to meet you nice
to meet you and uh really cool to have
you in Dubai thank you thank you been uh
enjoyed the morning so far really really
cool good I'm looking forward to seeing
you in a little bit what time I going
I'm four uh I think so I'll see you
there I'll see you soon take
care you thank you for 3 4 hours like
when I get on the ground that's why L
you know what you'll never believe this
I'm completely convinced this is how I'm
going to London from now on from Miami I
loved the nine hours yeah it makes a
difference yeah the six doesn't work for
me we're gonna go to I was able to get
you know Virgin Radio I'll show you
where to go you could wear it coming
here first and then going to London and
then no yeah you can get that long oh
that's a good idea right go to Dubai
first then London that's that's true
that's definitely true I'm very bad I I
actually posted about this on short
flights like 6our flight to La for me
was so painful I'm so comfortable on a
10 12 15 hour flight me too and I was
like that La flight was so I was so um
Restless I was like how much time left
how much time I couldn't it yeah I'm I'm
I'm really I'm fine with six if but not
if that's the amount of sleep I get I
need 6 hours of sleep yeah like I don't
want less I don't think it's
healthy so the event is here so when we
come we can just get dropped off or walk
over I'm finally getting there you want
to move you can take a left
here h no we'll take a left
self good morning Dubai what's good I'm
in the building hope you have a
wonderful wonderful wonderful
day Egypt what's up just want to say
happy happy happy mornings hope
everybody's having a wonderful morning
as we head into the afternoon uh have a
great great great great day perfect
thank you you're
welcome Hi how are you good to see you
again good good to see you hey how are
you pretty are Hi how are you come on in
guys you know what to do right yes okay
thank
you come on in thank you how are you
when did you get in this morning oh jeez
did you get a nap in at meast I did not
oh awesome
and he's here hello sorry about my
shorts how are you don't worry it's good
bro good to see you again so good to see
you thank you for coming in I appreciate
it thank you my fiance Brianna Bri my
manager Karen Hi how are you such a
pleasure oh thank you so much for
coming love to see you good to see you
good to see you so good to see you m how
are you thank you for
good really do you want anything like
water what would be
great it's a weekend we're chilled it's
beautiful the v in the house thanks for
coming in thank you mate thank you I
know this is a rare occasion this is
beautiful thank you um you um you landed
this morning yeah you're gone you're I'm
like I'm like I'm rarely cranky but like
are you a little bit n i red eyes are
just not fun yeah they're just I there's
just no other way to s and I have I've
never done the London to Dubai is always
fun to come to cuz I always get sleep
like wherever I'm coming from but London
Dubai is just only 6 hours so it's it's
not not enough and it's always tricky
right you like try to trick yourself
you're like all right six and a half
hours but then you realize the first 45
minutes are shot the last 45 minutes are
shot you know so it's what we were
saying Maha short flights can't can't we
were just talking about that in the car
too like the short flights
suck I mean I don't mind you mean you
mean short flights period or you mean
when you need sleep no just in general
oh I love short flights I can do a long
haul like from here to New York no
problem but when it's like a 3 to four
hour flight I'm so ansy and I'm ready
yeah I I get so much work done that I
love them I just I like every flight
except the one that I just took which is
like you know like it's just you know
did you you know what's funny because I
go everyone's like hustle and all this
the way way people talk about me it's
crazy I I don't know how many people
believe in sleep more than me I think
sleep is [__] important my function
but what do you get usually cuz you
obious 6 seven eight that's good in one
go or you waking up in one by the way in
one like plop no movement no peeing no
water plop done see you not drink them
before you go to bed on purpose I don't
drink water I'm saying water period this
is very rare I can't believe I asked for
it I'm
like no this is going to be the great
demise of water of my life like I'll
probably Lo I'll probably Die 3 to 7
years early because of my water
consumption and like I'm going to look
super old at 55 because of the my
wrinkled [__] face someone needs to
just freaking do a backpack on you with
straw I've been telling everyone that I
just had I had a
colonoscopy no I'm actually about to
have my first one need to do it I tried
it's very every minut I know
tou I was good when you get it done get
them to do an endo as well they put one
in your mouth they put one up there get
it checked at the same time cuz you're
out rather than having to do it twice
interesting okay I'm literally I'm
literally doing it in a couple weeks
okay my first colopy I'm nice and old
the day before oh man I did over the
summer the day before is like horrible
the day where you have to drink like you
have to drink all it's the prep yeah but
they put me to sleep I did this two days
ago it's being it's being like it's good
you pumped it over and you're happy p
what I mean all it is like you know it's
preventable I was talking to the doctor
and he was saying like you know if you
if you see it early they just get rid of
it but if you don't it just grows and
it'll turn into a cancer that's right
it's crazy um all right well listen man
thank you again you all right great
we're all here yeah all the cameras are
checked and everything so what's going
to happen is when she gets here this
have we told Gary have we told what's
going on like last time you got some
peep coming this this person now that's
coming in does doesn't know that you're
here we've said that you've got to come
in today because we want to just have a
quick intervie we want to hear your
story and then if if so we believe that
your P you'll meet Gary tomorrow on
Sunday she has no idea that you're here
right now she was like freaking out okay
yeah she was freaking out already just
the chance of this happening she's going
to come here the security guard is going
to do a walk by when she's here so when
we see him we know she's here and then
we can go and get okay cool and if we
need be or any come through she'll be in
the main reception okay all right
awesome can I can we just get you guys
to stand here just cuz those that camera
is going to go right over your head if
that's all right um where where's the
best place for this guy to stand I
actually think anywhere fine M if you
want to stand here as well you can get a
shot over the behind just um run where
you need to guard rather your footage
get priority
so okay are we doing this in the like it
happen
so it happened yeah the Gary V fans Gary
V fans will know that he's not here but
I think it's fine so just say it
happened no I think we just roll with it
that he would put him in the studio no
no what I'm saying is to mention the
events oh yeah the event I don't think
not even talk
about if you're cool with that we'll
give it a mention before
after all right you all hear me you all
hear me let's do it let's do it all
right Virgin Radio 104.4 morning the
Chris fade show across the country we're
back man we got him back in the studio
the legend the man Gary V is with us
good morning morning my gosh so we were
just talking about this off the radio
about just flying and taking short trips
and you've been flying all over the
world man you don't stop and it's it's
fantastic to see it from the outside how
is it from the inside Gary ve it's uh
humbling it's um it's it's just a lot of
fun like you know I mean for me the fact
that what I'm putting out to the world
is not necessarily that I'm a great
Sportsman or that I'm a supermodel or
that you know or I'm a educator I'm I'm
a
practitioner who is interested in giving
away every single thing that works for
me and from the other people and
companies that I observe and what then
leads to I'll give you an example it
leads to the DM I just read right before
we went on air it in all caps Lamar
Jackson for everybody who's listening
which is probably quite a bit that don't
follow American football there's a Young
quarterback that's doing extremely well
for people that are following me very
carefully in the last year I've been
talking about sports cards making a
comeback this kid sends me this crazy
email of like he was in depression in a
bad place he saw me talk about sports
cards he decided that he's a Ravens fan
which is the team that Lamar plays for
he believed in him he bought a bunch of
them they've gone up
10x wow 10 times you know and uh and
it's been really meaningful to him and
he's got his self-esteem back and he's
got a couple bucks in his pocket and
like that is just awesome that's
something that you just said that
changed someone's life and got him into
playing cards which is now really
changing and got him out of depression
you're saying that's exactly right and
and and what's amazing for me right now
is at the scale that I'm playing at that
email that DM that text is happening 500
a thousand times a day so what's
happening is the positive reinforcement
of that I'm getting from the good
behavior that I'm putting out it just
becomes a cycle right you become
addicted to the
admiration you know to me there's
nothing that feels better than
admiration of course you know and I've
started really learning about myself I
just had my 44th bir birthday the other
day thank you and I hated it I don't
want gifts I don't want like I it was
crazy I said something I think drock
heard me and I said I don't like
attention and everybody started laughing
and I said I'm serious I don't like
attention unless unless I earned
it then I love it like if I'm doing good
stuff then I then it feels merit-based
but if I'm but I don't like it otherwise
so anyway on the inside it
feels quiet which would confuse people
feels slow which would confuse people it
feels like I feel like I know what I'm
up to I feel like it's early and it
feels um
impactful wow we were talking to uh just
had a moment there we were talking to
Joe Koy the comedian the other day I
don't know if you know Joe Koy an
amazing comedian please watch if you
like Comics um he's coming to do a show
here and I said as as a comedian do
people come up to you and want you to be
funny all the time like they expect you
to make people laugh and do you get that
as soon as people they don't want to
make you you don't want to make them
laugh but they want something from they
want you they just want something from
you you may be on a flight and the lady
I'm a big fan and then they're waiting
for you to say something a couple things
yes next it feels amazing every time
cool I've I've yet to even come close to
being bothered the only thing I feel is
humbled I I'm just so flattered it just
CRA it's crazy so that's cool I'm glad
that hasn't gone away like and now I'm
kind of at the point where like oh right
this is not going to go away this is how
it's going to be forever I will always
have this perspective um
yes and and that's tough right because I
I hate when people think I'm a
motivational speaker I understand I'm
motivational I understand I have that I
understand I understand but if you
understand how I communicate it's a
series of thoughts off of a lot of
listening a lot of watching so so in the
macro I can tell you a ton of themes
parents forcing kids to be doctors
lawyers Engineers I know what that looks
like
uh people raising capital and not
building real businesses I know what
that's like everybody wanting to be an
entrepreneur now cuz it's cool and it's
the current rock store I know what that
is so in the macro I can put out a ton
of stuff but when you roll up to me and
say hey help me I'm like damn I need a
ton of context like this is this is I
what am I going to you know I mean what
I get caught on those on is because I'm
like walking to my cab or whatever you
know is you know I talk about the 4 to
715 things that I know are tried and
true
self-awareness you know uh are you
actually living your life for you or are
you living them based on the fact that
you want your friends to think you're
successful or you want to appease your
mom right like like those are true
things so th the things that I spew out
are are generic truths that may
fortunately hit them because they're
wildly true like 98% of the people
listening right now driving or in their
kitchen are actually living their life
based on their spouse's opinion their
older sister's opinion their parents
opinion or they want to show people that
they're successful people impressing
people but people buying things handbags
cars Apartments trips people spending
money to impress people they don't like
is one of the great cancers in our
society m i I've heard you say something
similar to that but then you said if you
do want to buy it and it gives you self
happiness that's okay if you want that
if you buy a Rolex because your
grandfather had one you look at watches
for an hour and a half and think those
trinkets are cool like you understand
that this one was made for a limited run
like that's amazing if you're buying a
Rolex cuz you're going to the top of the
building of Dubai at one night and you
want girls to see it so that you hook up
you're in
trouble you just said I'm serious
offended so many people in the country
this is what they're doing I put my
watch on especially for
Gary it right off doesn't even work Gary
look at that I see it I see it it's
stuck no but but but taking it off but
but it's it's a very unpopular take this
is not what people are talking about but
I know I know it's true I know that if
you're a 27y old guy and you need money
and things to close the gap of your
insecurity that you're not in a great
place I know it I've seen the road this
is the beauty of living through it
watching your contemporaries and now
sitting at the top of the funnel where
you're getting 10,000 DMS a month from
that 27y old guy who's crying in his
Penthouse that's that he can't afford I
I mean it like people don't get it like
there's a lot going on out here all
right more with Gary v- you're cool to
hang around with us this morning I'm
very cool to do it amazing Virgin Radio
104.4 the Cris fade show pretty mik big
Rossy please welcome Gary
V uh bunch of things here let's read
them out written three best sellers
YouTube Five EXC please update this info
guys uh fors top 40 social selling
Market Masters holds the number one spot
Fortune Magazine 40 under 40 uh he's
here for the second time here in the
Middle East uh the CEO of Vena media
digital agency is there anything that
you don't do and apart from this if you
follow Gary which I do and you see what
you do you go on the uh you go into like
garage sales in the states we call them
garage sales you guys call them uh what
do you call them garage sales you call
them Gage Sal sales you were buying you
were buying toy cars and you were buying
certain items and you're flipping them
to show people that they can make cash
out of this by reading all my DMs you
know I realized how many people all I
want to do all every day is eliminate
excuses mhm that's it yeah there's
nothing more fun for me than eliminating
excuses because once you become
accountable you can become happy like
every second that you blame the boss the
government your parents some random
thing that happened 13 years ago you're
finished every time you say everything
is my fault you're on fire you're going
to win and so I saw so many people
blaming I don't have money and finally I
was like huh you know how you know
you're just always thinking you know and
I'm just like wait a minute
I used to not have any money what did I
do all right I used to garage sale and
flip stuff on eBay and I made a fortune
like tens and tens and tens and tens of
thousands of dollars which was a fortune
at the time so you know you know this is
what is fun rolling with drock I'm like
drock we're going garage selling this
Saturday and we we filmed it and it is
inspired so many so many like the amount
of people that can spend $30 on a
weekend and then work 5 hours posting
and shipping out stuff and make 700
bucks is almost everyone like garage
sales and thrift stores and dollar
stores are loaded loaded with stuff
that's worth a lot more than what you
pay for it just one second just one
second is the girl she she's there she's
just like around here so prettyy can you
walk in and please cuz WHYY BR go out
and get her I'm not sure maybe she got
CAU by some so can you go out there just
push her down the other way just I don't
want anywhere near you right now just
one
second no she went cuz Meg came
okay sorry it's a member of the team oh
J
sorry we thought you were some guest
right now sorry I'll you with a girl
live on Saturday right um pretty back to
you where we were S I wanted to go back
to a point that you made about um doing
it for others and making other people
happy and buy all stuff a lot of that is
about Instagram as well with Instagram
taking away likes yes do you think that
mindset is slowly going to start to
really Hammer home and change like well
people start to change yes I think likes
going away is one of the great moves by
a social platform in a long time people
are wildly insecure and now people are
only posting what they know is going to
get the likes that they're accustomed to
getting what that also means is it makes
people talk about things they're not
passionate about anymore it also it
leads to people still talking about
themes they talked about four years ago
that they don't want to talk about it
leads to people who no longer want to
show themselves in bikinis continue to
show themselves in bikinis because they
want to get the same amount of likes it
just leads to people not saying their
truth they've become creatures of the
algorithm so it's a good thing in your I
think it's a hugely good thing can I can
I say the the the heads of Facebook
Instagram got in contact with me a
couple of days ago CU we were talking
about this on the radio we're getting
people's views on what what you believe
and a lot of people were positive for it
they want me to read this official
statement out by Facebook releas which
is uh on November 14th we're expanded
out my birthday oh happy birthday I'll
start it again on Gary's birthday we our
test of private likes to the rest of the
world Beyond Australia Brazil Canada
Ireland Italy New Zealand if you're in
the test you'll no longer see the total
number of likes and views on photos and
the video posted to the feed unless
they're in their own unless it's your
own uh feed while the feedback from
early testing has been positive this is
a fundamental change to Instagram
Facebook and so we're continuing our
tests to learn more about our Global
Community uh attributed to Tara Hopkins
EMA head of policy for Instagram
Facebook so I I like that I believe it's
posit because what oh it's it's this
is I think I
I'm deeply in this world and I've done
this for a long long time it is a
remarkable change but now
yes there's a much bigger Point here
okay and we've been saying it all
morning this is an algorithm in a
company that is trying to help everybody
with their insecurity
mhm they look at data at scale the fact
that Instagram and Facebook have had to
hide
likes is the great indicator of how
unbelievably insecure our society is and
how we have to start changing the
conversation that is why I go after
watches bottles models private Jets all
of this is doing is make up for deep in
security we must put happiness and
self-esteem
self-awareness patience all these
absolutely tried andr things on a
pedestal Facebook and Instagram can't
help you just cuz they hid the likes
that doesn't change you going out on
Friday night and feeling insecure
MH you know you say that and it's you're
living it Gary you're worth a lot of
money but when we follow you and we see
you on on the ground
you are living a life as just many of us
are we don't see we purposely like I use
private PLS to for efficiency uh and we
rarely show it I don't because you don't
want to show you don't want to be that
person to go like I'm on a private jet I
also don't think it's cool I'm actually
pissed I'm spending that much
money like you know how much how much is
it how much is a I mean some flights are
15,000 for an hour or some are 35,000
for two but like I need it to like bang
out these two meetings I've decided it's
worth that money with the hope that it's
Roi positive with my time I just don't
think it's I don't think it's cool I
also don't show my family for extra
likes you know I'm the I'm the most
public private person on Earth yeah I
really am I nobody's listen nobody's
putting out the level of content I'm
putting out when you take in all the
platforms podcast YouTube LinkedIn
Facebook Instagram snap Tik Tok like
nobody yet I don't show my family at all
I know I don't because because I don't
want to like I like privacy like it's
great but I love people but like there's
certain things that I want to keep for
myself too and people are letting
themselves put their whole life out
there for the likes cuz babies and
relationships and pregnancies get more
likes it's true it is true people are
sucked into one massive game of high
school yeah you right and I'm and I'm
trying to get them out of it because it
gets really the reason I was so happy in
high school school was cuz I was not
stuck in high school I liked everybody
and and I like nobody do you know what I
mean like like it was all just like it
was an experience and that's how it is
now like like for me the reason social
Works here's a good one this might help
a lot of people listening my friends one
of the reasons you're struggling with
social media and the negative comments
you get is because you're overvaluing
the positive
comments if you're going to O this is
where everyone gets caught you love when
they say you're
pretty you love when they say you're
smart you love when they say it's lit
but then the problem is once you hear
that you're also hearing the
negative for me my ab back to what we're
talking about here for me my humility is
my
superpower because it allows me to deal
with the negative feedback do you get a
lot of negative feedback sure because
people you know first of all I curse a
lot people don't like that uh in in you
know depending on what St you know I'm
when I speak on a stage and have 5,000
people there I'm
peacocking you know I'm in I'm doing my
thing and and that comes across with a
lot of bravado and when drock and I clip
it and I'm cursing out the crowd they're
like who the hell is this you know and
if people that give me negative feedback
are the ones that I'm choking out with
the content and they don't like being
called out so when I'm making a piece of
content that says stop taking mommy and
daddy's money and you'll actually find
happiness well the guy in the feed who's
taking mommy and daddy's money isn't
happy that I'm calling out 28 year-old
you know cuz I'm really going there I'm
like here's why you're unhappy you're
taking your parents money you're
spending it on dumb stuff you're
insecure like I'm going right at it he
doesn't like that so then he's leaving a
negative comment when I see negative
comments I know that I'm helping that
person I'm like stay with me yeah that's
where my mind goes I'm like stay with me
hopefully and this is what I do to a lot
of people they don't like it but the
communication style so intriguing they
don't you know when you're actually
giving and you're coming from a warm
pure intent even the person you're
destroying right there they kind of can
tell you know humans are amazing animals
even though I'm yelling at them
suffocating them calling them them out I
think they can sense that I'm coming
from a good place not a bad place and so
they stick around they stick you know
they're mad at me for a while but then
you know then their four best friends
think I'm the coolest H and then 7
months later they call their parents and
they stop taking the money and then 4
months later I get a DM that says thank
you and then and then I'm like that then
that's the oxygen for me to keep going
through it all if you go to Google and
you're typing is Gary V I don't know if
you ever done this nope we're going to
run through him a
scam sure no no uh is Gary ve married
uhhuh makes sense is Gary ve Rich you
going to answer these no no not enough
is Gary ve single no is Gary ve Russian
I
am uh is Gary ve invested into Tik Tok
I'm not which which blows people away
because I'm you've been talking about
lot a lot because because I want to be
historically correct you are the reason
why I got on Tik Tok 6 months ago can I
tell you cuz I was what you would tell
people people are like I don't need to
be on Tik Tok I'm on Instagram Facebook
I don't want to join another one and I
was saying those exact words and then as
soon as you got out on your platforms
and you're like and you were showing
footage from years ago of you going I
don't want to go on Instagram cuz I'm on
Facebook Myspace and I'm like I'm
getting on Tik Tok now we're all I got
and can I tell you I have never had more
numbers and likes and Views than on my
Tik Tok in the last 6 months it's
underpriced attention than I've had on
Instagram that I've been on for 4 and a
half years listen guys there's a reason
I'm Gary B yeah I I tend to be right
here's why I don't guess right you're
based on facts I'm based on I own
everyone's like you know when they're
giving me compliments Gary you're like
no stradamus you know the future what's
next I'm like I don't know anything I'm
like I'm just good at knowing what is
actually happening and I'm not scared to
talk about it hey recently you had
mentioned that you were thinking about
no social media December was are yes
disappearing December yes are you still
going to do that I'm not no but it is
absolutely something I've thought about
and the reason I put it out publicly was
a I was thinking about it and B it might
work for somebody disappearing December
going social media especially at
Christmas time as well on Christmas Day
I actually think it's the hardest month
to go off cuz the holidays the pictures
the trips like I actually think it's
which is why I think it's an interesting
one yeah you know it's very it's a
difficult disappearing yeah if I was
like seea September people like all
right yeah I can do that you know I can
do that but disappearing December is
like um last one here on on the top 10
of Google is is Gary ve vegan I am not
ever thought about it I have it's the
thing now have you watched all those
Doos G changer and all that by the way I
was thinking about it before all the
hype and and the docs now I'm like oh
I'm not following this you know you know
it's funny I'm very into you know what
is interesting actually this is I've
never shared this I have this real
thought in this everything paleo vegan
not vegan I wish people were comfortable
changing their
mind I have a lot of friends who are
vegan right now who don't want to be
anymore and feel like they can't they
can't change they've gone too far
invested in it yeah I can I say I went
vegan for a month right and uh I'm
getting scared because I knew that the
vegans were they were proud they started
inboxing me oh Chris is vegan he's one
of us and so I kept having a say I I I I
kept saying on the radio guys I'm only
doing it for a month because I did start
to get a little I can I tell you yeah
tell me everything uh I felt better I
had more energy I was less bloated going
to the bathroom was a lot easier you
were regular I felt like my like just
Clarity in my in my brain was better
brain so why did you
start cuz I love meat and I was I I feel
like when I'm a training at the gym and
I'm eating my proteins and I'm getting
my you know my chicken on and I'm
getting all that like I felt like with
the vegan side of it I was eating more
of those carbs Bas I probably wasn't
doing it the right way do you do do you
have a sense of why you you value
muscles de so true so true
well you know no really it's like like I
come from a good place on that like it's
super interesting like why can I tell
you I was I was overweight I was 128
kilos at one stage of my life that's
when I was anxious and depressed y um
the only thing that got me out of that
was not the pills and I would see a
psychiatrist and see all those guys and
the only thing that got me out of was
going to the gym every single day right
and awes that transformation in my body
and I was going through a divorce at the
same time so that transformation that I
went through going through the divorce
and the body change where I started to
develop muscles that I never had I had
them I went through it as well it was
crazy to like it's weird to have them
it's right like you later in your life
you're like what a wo yeah you start
like I'm like wait running into things
doesn't hurt anymore this muscle like
that was by the way that is the single
biggest thing that I thought like that
I've observed of actually having muscles
later in my life I'm like weird when you
run into a wall it's not
painful but I guess that's I mean I
right now it's not so much about the
muscles and wanting to look like you
like a a bodybuilder or anything like
that I just enjoy it and you know what
that self- gratify you know and it's
true if I you look at yourself look
myself in the mirror it plays it plays
with my mind it makes me happy you know
what about pooping better um because
that you man I'm telling you yeah we're
talking real right now it totally
changed well that's what I mean maybe
you should value that more than muscles
well I tell you what now I I've reduced
my meat intake I only eat red meat once
a week and I only eat chicken twice a
week and the rest is sort of like a
vegan diet that's you know when I hear
that I'm like this is where I'm trying
to give the reason I'm saying out loud
it's okay to change is because I like
people having the ability to continue to
mix and and listen all of this is about
balance yeah like all of it's about like
life is about balance right like one of
the reasons I'm talking more about how
much I sleep is because I think a lot of
entrepreneurs think staying up all day
is how you hustle and win and I'm like
wait a minute I might be a part of that
movement I need to create Clarity so
over the last three four years I mean we
had Ariana hington on the askary V show
four or five years ago I've been very
thoughtful about clarifying you know
because in the first book I wrote that
broke me out crushed I talked about 7:00
p.m. to 2: in the morning as the time
you do side hustle while you still paid
your bills because I was trying to be
practical you can't quit your job why
don't you work after instead of going
out or playing Xbox or doing things to
escape your real life why don't you work
and then eventually that thing could
become the thing and you can leave which
was great and I still believe in that
but then obviously people the 2 a.m.
thing you know and like and so you know
how things evolve and so balance is
incredibly important the whole part all
of it you and people's own balance I for
example for me I find balance in
extremities like I love going hard you
know Monday through Friday and I love
being completely checked out on the
weekend but do you ever I I I I I go
pretty hard as well as we all do but I
feel guilty sometimes on the weekend or
at moments when I'm not doing anything
and I've got to tell myself
Chris just you're allowed to do nothing
I've never felt guilty you don't feel
guilty again I would argue and my friend
Tom bellu hit this for me my ability to
not judge myself is my greatest strength
and that's hard yeah not to be able to
judge yourself that's hard you know why
I don't judge myself cuz I don't judge
other
people you want to get really happy stop
judging people oh that's good you stop
judging people you stop judging yourself
and by the way for everybody who's
driving and you judge people you don't
know anything about them you don't even
know everything about your sister how
are you judging Strangers Like judgment
is poison and has led to so much
darkness in the LA especially with
social media what what has happened
people blame social media social media
hasn't done anything except expose us
there's no social media we're social
media they're empty platforms we fill it
when you leave that nasty comment
because you're jealous that that girl's
pretty and you're insecure about your
looks that's your Darkness that's not
Instagram making you write
it it's not Instagram's fault it's not
the video game's fault bro these
platforms are
empty this notion that Facebook or
Instagram or the Russians are
controlling us is
laughable we need to change society we
need to put happiness on a pedestal not
money Gary be with us and guess what
there's some happiness happening in the
studio next cuz we got a rise not so
much for Gary ve but for someone who's
waiting outside hang out Virgin Radio
morning okay super cool so prominent man
it's amazing um okay so what we'll she's
in the main Reception Area yeah I'll go
and get her I'll go get her do you want
me to be underneath here and pop
out that be so good T rock you have to
hide too
okay in there get yeah um can
I absolutely wait wa wait wait all you
guys should we to go into that
studio just so it looks like it's a
regular day reg all right so I'm here on
the ground in Dubai uh at Virgin Radio
and uh with my man Chris B and uh we're
surprising somebody who doesn't know I'm
actually here she thinks she's coming in
for a pre- interiew and I'm about to pop
out like I'm a Jack In The Box and she's
going to scream and it's going to be a
great viral clip and we're going to have
a lot of fun with
it this is
great that was a good sash Chris are you
hiding too no no no no I'm just
having
disappear you what's her name Nikita Nik
Nikita so just so you know she's uh
she's 24 years old the reason why we
have a guest coming into the studio he's
a huge fan of Gary ve she doesn't
realize that she's uh just about to meet
him here we go hey hey hey hey hey hey
to see you thanks for coming in take
your seat thank you for coming in on the
weekend we're sorry that we had to do
this but we've got three or four people
who are having the opportunity to meet
Gary so we want to make sure that we're
giving you the chance to uh see how it
goes here let's see how we go what's
your name sorry Nikita Nikita okay good
morning good morning how are you good
thank
you
surprise we're
here in the
studio hi don't cry don't cry this is AB
how are you how are you oh my God it's
so good to see you all about ladies and
gentlemen how are you s don't
cry how are you Makita take a seat you
keep that emotion rolling honey that's
what exactly what I want this is a
beautiful moment whole note section on
my phone planned so I didn't forget
anything so it's gooded right now
because my heart's like racing so you
you were unaware that you were going to
be meeting Gary ve right now now do you
know Gary was actually sitting at the
bottom of the right here on the ground
that intuition but I wasn't sure oh wow
well here is the moment you uh you hit
us up now we got a we got hundreds of
messages in the last 24 hours of people
wanting to have this opportunity to be
next to Gary Vee and just be able to
pick his brain and have a quick little
word to him and congratulations give her
a big round of
applause please I'm you know what I'm
I'm going to stay out of this and pretty
and Rossy will stay out of moment I
really want this moment between you and
Gary to really go the way that you
wanted to go so over to you Gary can you
please pass me my phone yes here we go
thank you so much you're welcome um
where do I start
so uh can you ask me something I sure
can yes no worries so actually here's a
good question how did you first find my
content and like what resonated um
everything so when I I was in school for
fashion design back in 2014
and that's when I found you and you were
just a huge source of motivation for me
um especially when you're super stressed
out about meeting deadlines and whatnot
and then when you're stressed out you
procrastinate so all of that but that
wasn't part of it so basically the big
thing is is
um after school like I just didn't know
so it was a very condensed one-year
course and I wanted to go to either fit
or Parsons in New York afterward now
that's like 30,000 40,000 us a semester
yes two semesters a year four years it's
super expensive and then living in New
York of course so I um I was already in
personal training because I was a figure
skater growing up so I was always like
very active and I just kind of fell into
the role so I was like okay this is a
perfect opportunity for me to make money
to actually focus on another thing that
I'm really passionate about got it um my
voice don't worry don't worry we're here
but um so that's another reason so I was
living in Vancouver I'm from
um and believe it or not Vancouver is
more expensive than Dubai and then
there's income tax and whatnot so I
moved out to Dubai thinking I could save
more money turns out training is very
saturated here and like 90% of personal
trainers struggle okay um so it's just
still a matter of like feeling very
stagnant and like when am I ever going
to reach the school and then comparing
myself
to um like others others and like yeah
like other people that I went to school
with and they have their Bachelors or
they're working on their masters or
they're doing this job and it's like oh
like what am I doing I'm never going to
get to school like couple couple things
are exciting to me about your story two
things stand out quite a bit number
one anytime One Compares themselves to
somebody else they always lose okay when
I was 27 years old I worked in a liquor
store and my and my friends drove to my
liquor store and would buy champagne and
I would carry the box to their BMW I
remember you saying that in a video Yeah
but you had no ego about it right
because they're they're first of all if
your friends have Bachelors or or are
engaged or have moved into a new
apartment I think you should be happy
for them yeah of course but but it
should stop there to your point I and I
can even tell by your energy you are but
then what happens is and then you look
at yourself and you say Where am I yeah
it just doesn't mean anything it like
people have to realize like life is so
long it's like you know just cuz we're
at this point and you're not as in the
same place as somebody else there's
little value to that comparison okay
like there's just little value like I I
think so many people get upset about
comparing themselves to others without
realizing what those others are going
through so it's cool that they have
their Bachelors but they might be in a
super abusive relationship but you don't
know MH for sure you know what I mean
know it's behind the scenes you really
don't and it's super important that you
ground yourself in that and not compare
number two far more interesting to me is
I want to play this game of of like why
those schools are your dream so it's not
necessarily my dream it's like when I
was in school I did really well and I
was like I know that I'm passionate
about it and I'm creative and I have the
talent what would you like to happen
networking like so and that's another
thing with videos I've watched of years
you're like you don't need education so
I was going to ask you like you need
education you don't need to pay for it
in the current package as they are let's
play this game so you want to go to
those fashion schools which I understand
those are legit spots yeah let's say you
go there and Crush what would happen
next I don't know it was just a matter
of who I met within those years of being
there and um like the fashion directors
at those schools are the actual
designers themselves so like Diana Bon
fenberg Calvin Klein Mark Jacobs all of
those people so if I were able to get
face to face with those people but let's
play that out the amount of fit students
and Parson students that have face to
time with those three is zero they'll
come and give a speech you might take a
selfie but you're not getting real
FaceTime you're far more likely to send
a top designer DMS and offer to work for
free for them and they say yes and then
you grab coffee and pick up shata and
actually get close to them and actually
get FaceTime than ever going to one of
those two schools so what like how would
that happen without going to school you
would literally take your phone right
now and message them and DM DF dvf and
say I'm willing to work my face off for
free and you do that to 400 of the top
designers in the world and none of them
answer and then you sit there and say
Gary he told me this was going to work I
hate him and then you do it again and
you do it again and do it again and then
somebody says yes okay until Virgil says
yes and you're in Paris doing an
off-white
show I'm s this is real like like this
is why breaking down this conversation
is so important like this is what's so
fun for me like the fact that you in
your mind truly believe that going to
those two schools is going to let you
interact face to face with those three
is amazing because that's where I get to
say cool but not really and then there's
another part of that question let's say
those schools actually did give you face
to face with those three the next
question is and what then and so what
are you going to do in that hour I mean
getting an hour with Callin Klein's
ludicrous but let's say you get it yeah
from Parsons you know
what good question and it's and it's not
a tough question it doesn't have to be a
scary one like I'm not asking to like ah
I got you it's about
what like do you want to be a designer
of course I do well great then I have
great news for you you're far more
likely to break out as a designer just
designing and putting it out on social
media than you are to go to a school
like like if you have the talent whether
you do go to fit or you go to Instagram
it's all going to end up in the same
place anyway M Talent
wins so if I wanted to go ahead and
within the meantime like if I started
putting everything out there on like all
of my capsule collections yes sketches
everything out on Instagram but I didn't
have that following and I wanted to
start my own business within without an
audience how would I go about actually
starting that without having like
because well first of all the way you
just talked about it that costs nothing
yeah the other way cost you $240,000 in
debt I know well I also know and so
that's why I want to bring that up to me
I'd rather you do that listen your
ability to put out those sketches first
of all you put out those sketches there
is a point0 1% chance of a miracle MH
right the other thing you can do is DM
those sketches to 5,000 top models on
Instagram okay all you need is one
person to think it's
cool I would rather you lay in bed for
11 hours a day and DM people all the
sketches whether they're designers
fashion magazines fashion pages and
models I genuinely believe what I'm
about to say I believe that's a more
likelihood to what you want than going
to fit okay no I definitely think so
because even after school it would just
be kind of I don't want to be in the
exact same position that I'm in now of
like oh I just not necessarily wasted
four years of my life but I just put all
of my eggs in that one basket and spent
like three four years of my life
dwelling on getting to the school to
finally get here and then be in the same
position and now what correct yeah the
reason there's so much unhappiness right
now in the world especially in the
American world is there's a ton of
people that have hundreds of thousands
of dollars in college debt and
everything they thought they were going
to get from it they
didn't basically what happened to me
basically what happened to millions of
people yeah I I genuinely think that you
need to sketch capsule and put it out
for free to the World on all platforms
like this is why I yell about Tik Tock
like if you know if you if you did
figure skating I assume you have
athletic Rhythm capabilities that most
people don't the fact that you like when
I look at you I'm like this girl should
just go on Tik Tock and put this stuff
out so I have a Tik Tok as well and it's
just a matter of like knowing what
content to put out there that would grab
people's attention work it the other way
that's what everybody does which is why
people fail my game is just put out
everything and figure out what people
want okay after the fact and everybody
sits there because this is what gets
into insecurity and judgment that's why
I talk about it so much if you just put
it out you'll find out if you sit in
your head you'll never post yeah that's
basically what's happening I never post
and I think that like I resonated with
one of your posts about never posting
because of insecurity and just like
worrying about what other people think
and whatnot but going to get anywhere
that way that's what everyone's doing
yeah you had fun was that good was that
that was a good like 10 minutes right
now with Gary really did you know I'm
going I'm going to wrap this up but you
guys can have a quick chat afterwards as
well but how did was it was that cool so
unexpected it feels so surreal being
here like I was not expecting that
whatsoever and just like you're so
genuine like the smile on his so
genuine he cares so much about people
you know what you said again what you
just said to Nikita here about you know
putting out content again resonated with
me when we met nearly a year ago where
we we I heard you say that you said you
know well put out 100 videos one of them
may hit yeah so I took that upon myself
now with my own social media where I
used to think oh I'm not going to post
that cuz I think that's right oh I don't
want to put that one out because maybe
it's not going to work so what I
literally after I spoke to you Gary I I
really changed my mindset on on social
media and I just started posting and I
used to only post at this certain time I
used to do it only then and and I'm like
you know what I'm just put it out I the
same way I watched his 64 in a day yes
last night though and it's just like
even a matter of posting like a snippet
from your note section or Twitter like
it doesn't have to look perfect so I
have't sto being so so particular good
on you I'm glad now Gary we're we're
going to let you leave here this for a
while
even though this could go on for the
next 3 and a half hours I believe um
real quickly what's next for Gary ve
that question that everyone must ask you
is there anything do you you got your
future goals short-term goals what's
going on I want to continue put out
information that I know is leading to
more happiness you know like hanging
here in Nikita like it's it's it's just
perspective it's just it's you know I I
was born with it I had Parents around me
that gave it to me and I just want to
pass that on once you look at it a
little bit different it just changes
everything it's literally just looking
at it different like it's so exciting
for me that I know what you actually
want yeah is a lot easier than the way
you're seeing the path it's literally Le
leaving this studio right now sketching
and posting it on Pinterest and
literally that could be the
moment That's so
exciting if you're not following Gary ve
I advise you to uh you're an AB absolute
Legend thank you so much for joining us
once again on Virgin Radio here on the
Chris fade show Gary V thank you thank
you so
much yeah can we do can we do a picture
Nikita with Gary yeah that keep sorry I
fooled
you I appreciate it let's get's phone
yeah it's very I'll take it for
you
okay you ready three two one
go four there good luck with the edit
yeah got it so nice to meet you can I
ask you more questions yeah
okay I hey I'll give you another five
minutes cuz we got to do a bit more
stuff with G's got to leave as well okay
can I yeah take that there you go yeah
okay so pictures I have like eight
things here so daily structure what
should that look like and what should I
be most focused on so basically we
talked about sketching and just posting
it but as a daily structure like how
should I be string stru ing my day and
then even with my personal training
business here and like making both of
those successful businesses at once it's
about ideas and making okay whatever
puts you in a position to make the most
content the content is going to lead to
your opportunities okay it's as simple
as that okay and you can't cop out like
put it just on stories like you have to
put it in your feed okay you have to put
it on Twitter okay Tik Tok is a listen
to me Tik tok's super important here's
why there's so much extra attention on
it mhm you can break out there good to
know yeah one of my friends posted and
he got like over a million like views
and then like the other had like a
hundred so it's crazy how it works it's
crazy this is early it's an early social
network with huge scale it has so much
potential for you okay good to know um
funding a startup when you don't have
the funds so how would you go about that
I wouldn't no like everything I'm
listening to you on like like it's like
meaning raising capital is just a huge
waste of time right I really believe
that like I think that you I think that
one's more of a patience game it's like
saving money as you can like I wouldn't
worry about a startup right now I based
on so what do you want to happen you
want to start a brand fashion breand
eventually but I would like to start
under other people just to kind of learn
the ropes of it first but if I could
have that on the side to still have an
income coming in while I'm doing that
obviously I want to do it I really think
you break it down to huge Simplicity and
I just think you sketch and put out
stuff okay just sketch your [__] face
off okay sounds good um so that's to do
with that I really mean it like a lot no
I will I've been doing that how many
sketches are you like capable of I don't
on a daily basis um I don't know it's
just a matter of like actually taking it
out and doing it for hours and then
however many pages happen I love that do
that as often as you can and get it out
as often as you can okay I have have so
much time to do it right now so it's
like perfect
opportunity one more deal um we'll be I
I love her you were so prepared good on
you um I answered that so making both
businesses work so right now if I have
to focus on like if training is my bread
and butter here in Dubai and I want to
scale that how would I be able to also
scale that while focusing on this free
content did you ever did you see Jordan
s fitness who trained for 3 years yeah I
know the blonde guy no that's Mike okay
but like both did the same thing okay
because they were with me every day I
pounded into their [__] head that it
was content eventually they did it and
then miraculously everything they wanted
to happen happened okay like you need to
post across all the platforms that have
attention in Dubai as many times as you
possibly can okay I will do that awesome
you so
much thank you guys so thank you you go
to photo yeah can I get we took it we
yes of course of course um Gary we want
to get you to have a few photos as well
if you don't mind we going grab one
quickly of us okay cool could you just
po this for um yeah can you is it all
right this way you want to do it here
yeah I think so it looks
nice you should get in one I can do
that oh no we'll get
one
go
got a
few Okay prettyy jump in let's jump in
Gary and then we'll do one with all of
sorry get Prett oh thank
you Karen come here don't be back there
two
three awesome thank you Karen hi
Karen yeah this way oh you got
it thank you awesome yeah yeah look have
you seen it
than
thanks okay so about 18 months ago
launched my kids snack company I
remember okay um it's doing very well
we're in about 500 and uh Rossy just one
sec mate um we're we're in about 550
locations now we just got FDA approval
CU we had some interest in the States
this is the old packaging this is going
to be this is going to go uh these are
the demos of how the new packaging will
look like they start in a month all
right now the reason we got rid of me
because when we went to the states for
FDA approval and they approved it and
people started getting interest they
were wondering who this bided Arab man
was on the package for the kids snacks
cuz they don't know me so now we removed
me from the snacks they're going to look
more like this there's adult snacks
coming out as well because we realized
that the adults were eating it as much
as the kids were um we've moved probably
about a million of these already uh in
the last 18 months which has been great
we're getting into Starbucks now we're
into the big guys Tim hens all the
cinemas and we're getting some major
distri contribution I've had interest
from global companies already we've sat
down and had boardroom meetings where
they were like we like what you're doing
we just want to know what you're doing
and what you're planning and if we can
get involved in somehow we've got the
first sugar-free gummies coming out for
kids in the Middle East these are my
daughters obviously the financial
controller and the general manager nushi
and Kiki they are the main face of the
business alongside me so they're all
about it they help me with all the taste
testing they get me they're involved in
everything that we do I take them to the
boardroom meetings with me they make
decisions with me uh their friends come
over and this it's a it's a Co little
family bus that we've got right fade Fit
Kids obviously with me there's a couple
of questions that I want to ask you just
real quickly um mainly on on on on
social media and and how to own own that
how to be better at it yeah right now
we're sort of just all over the place
and well I'll start off with this we're
a small organization yes my fiance Brian
is the brand manager I pay an agency
they take 8% of 6% of my sales they take
but they run the company for me all
right cuz I'm doing what I of course of
course she's my eyes and ears she's
always there and she leads me the info I
go when I've got to our distribution we
have the second largest Distribution
Company in the Middle East doing our
products they take their percentage as
well so everyone's taking their cut and
I'm left with the profits right now I
don't care about the money that I trying
to build the brand I'm building the
brand right and with with my name and my
expertise in this in this region it's
great it's building very quickly and
it's already now somewhat of a household
name in this region yes my my thing is
do I spend now and go get my fulltime
accountant and go get my full-time
digital person to get my videographer do
I build that now how much how much
revenue is this brand doing uh close to
about close to about 3 400,000 at this
stage you know look I
mean couple
things I don't think you have to go Full
Throttle now you don't have to you can
that's a very simple question it's how
much money do you want to invest in it
there's no right WR wrong answer to this
it's can you afford it I can afford it
and do you want to do it it's as simple
as that okay like you know it's it's you
know there people are always thinking
these things are binary there's no right
time do you feel like it's time like you
know that's the question cuz I feel like
we're we're doing everything literally
be and I are doing so much we're filming
stuff we're getting it out there I'm
going to this shop doing this that's
that's what you're supposed to do yes
but do I have like a you know I always
look at D for example and just see the
the the the this is where I want to be
there was no D for the first eight years
that I was doing it but why did you
choose cuz I finally got to a place
where I could afford it okay and really
afford it and if I make the the first
employ if a couple things are running
through my mind I apologize I can't say
this loud enough I want this brand to
put out 10 pieces of content on Tik Tok
a day okay a day okay here's why here's
why Tik Tock is in a very wild place
right now mhm people don't get it
because that's why I keep showing those
old videos like these things don't come
along that that often mhm it we could be
in you know when's the last time we had
something like Tik Tok Snapchat yeah
that was you know that's like four or
five years ago yeah you know like it t
like these platforms that give like and
for a brand like this like this is crazy
like you have to take advantage to me
almost everything else is secondary can
you instead of the accountant I'd rather
hire a kid in the market that can help
you make 10 a day and we have that but
we got to use them okay that Mak sense
here's why it's it's like buying real
estate right now the beach front is open
to what's destined to be an island that
people are going to visit it's a good
bue buy up some property that's where
your energy needs to go cuz you're in
brand building Y and brand building
requires awareness people need to know
about it here you have a big [__]
microphone yeah the rest of the world
you don't yeah but but 18 Tik Tock Stars
becoming you know infatuated with you
know I don't know if the girls want to
do Tik toks if you and their mom are
willing to let them do it but they
should do a ton of them you know like
all you you know you can't imagine what
can happen when you catch a platform
right okay that's great advice I can
tell you what happened it's called
fashion NOA I can tell you what happened
it's called gym shark I can tell you
what happened it's called you know you
know yeah no no okay that to me is the
real answer yeah cuz the major and and
and sending samples to influencers who
are willing to post it in
feed okay so like for me I mean for you
or again if you hire these people to
help you scale like literally you guys
are laying there at 10:00 at night and
instead of like watching TV just like
dming a thousand influencers and being
like this is our brand so giving out
stock is important like is in the right
people right we were just having that
discussion that I'm a big fan of okay
yes can I ask you one last thing of
course you can giving out stock if I
don't want to give away the whole thing
we're making sample packages is that
okay or does it differentiate between
you want them to have the physical
package I want them to have the physical
package cuz you're building brand and
what you're doing with sampling is
trying to save a couple pennies and the
pennies aren't worth it sure the dollars
are in The Branding okay that's why I
don't want to take any more your time
thank you man appreciate it and by the
way let's not do this every you know six
months or a year that I come here if you
really have a burning question reach out
to Maha I'll get on you'll get done okay
I'll get on the phone your your
production quality is high and so you're
you're valuing the production quality
over you're doing a really good job the
quality is high okay the quality is high
okay I think that's your detriment
okay okay okay you need some real life
[__] photos yeah like you need like
like you're like like if you're like
next week you're like Gary told me if
right Gary told me three a day [__] and
it's like laying there on the table
you're like even and then hash inth wild
done even something that simple yeah
because you never know what the audience
is going to love okay okay super cool
man this is this is too much this is too
this is too good this is this is two
magazines but you know what my thing is
yeah please I'm listen so many it looks
and by the way I think it looks [__] so
now what who's right me you who who it's
all just
subjective okay thanks man what's not
subjective is the amount you post what
is subjective is does this look good
yeah can I one last one I promise I
signed a deal with Amazon right here in
the country so I'm their Ambassador and
within my deal I got some uh barter
what's the best way to utilize that on
Amazon do I want you want to use Amazon
ads to drive the business yeah okay
write that down B just so we
know
okay yeah the UA is such a small Market
we're going to Saudi next so we just
started a break into Saudi saudi's where
the money's at because the population's
so big this is a very small population
in the essence of what we're doing it's
a volume sale so we got to sell a lot to
make to start to make the cash um but
we're really happy where we are and
obviously it's a great product really
it's just the average family size in
Saudi is seven really do you know that's
why bulk win is going there it's like a
Costco seven seven because they have to
buy they could to buy in bulk yeah bulk
gosh man interesting okay is that seven
as in five kids or seven as in ad
children yeah and I was working for
which is a Spotify at leas and I reached
a place where I'm saturated then I moved
to Tik Tok to follow my North Star so
couldn't couldn't be that's awesome
thank
you that's
cool I just want to be like you when I
grow up you do really I want to I want
to be like me when I grow
up and I think what's what's growing Tik
Tok so so so rapidly is the type of
content that's there sure it's because
Tik Tok takes it does have the creative
job for people 100% right so it ends up
breeding creators so the moment we sat
we're like What are we standing for
we're like we're the hub for creators
and all of a sudden everybody who's been
trying to create content but unable to
scale outside started knocking our doors
it's like I do Sports I do Fitness I do
comedy I do food I do fashion and all of
a sudden you've got this Diversified
pool that says well well we're no longer
musically we're no longer lip syncing
and dancing front of the screen that's
right and that's what happens with every
platform exactly you know Facebook is
college stuff Instagram was photography
yes everything evolves yeah if it wins
and and the game play here is how do we
make sure that we keep winning of course
and how do you you know set up the
content criteria which we call now it
has to be real content it can't be broad
content like fast so don't worry about
the quality and the editing like you
always talk about and I think that's
that's the power of what's what's what's
what's growing it so fast um are Brands
hitting you guys up in the region the
brands so one thing that we're seeing is
Brands and people have no idea how it
works yeah there's a big education game
to say one it's simple and two you just
need to spend some time with it and not
get scared of it so three things that
we're currently doing one is a major
creative Workshop I I have a vision to
create a tick creative Academy yep to
breed creatives creatives 100% right so
and in this region there isn't you know
we don't have the Zach Kings of the
world so we want to breed them work with
universities work with schools work with
creators work with musicians who end up
posting pictures on Instagram rather
than bringing their voice to life and
bringing their fan base so um you know
what the number one thing I want Tik Tok
to do hit me pictures really really I
didn't see that I I didn't think you I
didn't think you did that's why I set it
up nicely I think it would be huge huge
move would it yeah why I think it would
it would it would give people more
creativity and it would help the
platform grow more okay I know it's not
a natural I need to syn this in I know I
can't wait to get your DM in a couple
weeks I I really think it's an I think
it's a super interesting play yeah I
really do I've been thinking about it a
lot the only thing is please in in what
form so I so for me I I tell the team
all the time please stop calling our
people influencers people on Tik Tok
don't influence they entertain we have
creators social media has influencers
the context of mindset of how we I think
I think those I think we I I've seen
this Rodeo a lot the conversation I'm
having with you I had with Twitter in
2007 in Facebook right I've been through
this I think I I think and a lot of what
I'm seeing from this conversation and
just some of the others with Tik Tok
reminds me a lot of Snapchat yeah and I
think the reason I'm giving the advice
of pictures has a lot to do with how
Snapchat's evolved wow I think a lot of
times we get into conversations that
have nothing to do with the end consumer
yes the you see what I mean we also with
experence how we can be
different we're you see where I'm going
yeah in the same way that you try to
explain to people it's simple just make
I'm saying a photo is simple it help it
people can make and it it might go
against the philosophy of what we stand
for but what we stand for is something
we're deciding in Ivory Towers in China
and Dubai it has nothing to do with
Muhammad right now sitting in that
building debating what he should do with
it or would he adopt it or he's a guy
that likes to do eight photos and one
video a month and I don't need Tik to
talk because I can't do photos we should
I think creating restrictions for people
is a bad idea yeah I think restrictions
are powerful but I think they drive they
drive they force for cre 100% 100%
however I uh I think that's going to be
the if they do it I think that's going
to be the big
move I I'm going to SN this in and get
you that DM and the one thing I'm going
to start doing and taking this with me
is the how and the purpose and the RO
the role of
Photography um today we tell people that
when you're on Tik Tok and you want to
create content there's so many tools
it's a it's a Content creating Mach and
here's the good news it's not just
filters here's the good news adding a
photo element doesn't eliminate that
yeah there's a photo collage feature now
but that's that's about it I think it's
an interesting concept because I think I
think um I'm very big on offense and I
think that people I think what consumers
want from their social networks is
flexibility it may start as something
but Instagram's already you know trying
to find its competitive feature yeah to
what you guys have created but here's
here's one thing that's that's
interesting to me so one I think one
thing that puts us in a very strong
position versus other social platforms
which gives us a why people should come
to Tik Tok uh and register just another
social account is the ability of
different content Beyond fashion like
sports like music um like food uh like
education learn it can live in video
format more than they live in any other
format and I think that's why but that's
but there's video format on YouTube and
Instagram and Facebook
form is that an opportunity you think
but there's a one minute video you can
do on Instagram about sport I don't
think that's the reason I think the
reason is it I think you nailed it the
first time it helped people create yes
period That's What Snapchat did that's
what what Instagram did I'm a buyer of
that that's the Insight now and then it
won the youth culture huge and now the
question becomes can it do things that
aren't viewed as
features and that's where the upsite is
but I'm I'm I mean as you know I've been
very bullish about it I'm very excited
about it very yeah I really am and I and
I think it's healthy to have you know
competitive products to Facebook and
Instagram yes of course that's Health
but the only thing is it becomes really
tricky is if you're creating the same
experience who's going to want to build
a fan base in two places and here's the
good news uh everybody really mhm but
but that's a different point to your
point they all blend similar yeah um
you're you're not it's already we're
past the part of you doing the same
things everyone comes from a different
angle exactly uh it's all still the same
game yeah you know pictures videos
written words not super complicated
um I I think what's interesting is if
you become too
one-dimensional you'll become vulnerable
yeah that's why yeah you understand easy
to take and not even it's just too
one-dimensional
yeah it does it become a game of
diversity of content and diversity of of
experience or you have so much scale
already that it's you've already kind of
won this is what's so funny about when
people are like Gary you're wrong about
Tik toac I'm like this is not a debate
it's over
already it already happened why are we
debating something that happened it's
you know we're talking about 1.5 billion
like you know it happened um now the
question is how long cuz Vine happened
cuz Snapchat happened cuz Myspace
happened cuz Facebook happened cuz
Twitter happened they all have very
different life cycles yeah one of the
biggest things we struggling with is we
want to create a pool of content that's
qualitative and cool and and when I say
qualitative I'm not saying high
production quality I'm just saying
content that matters and with purpose
versus just fun in City stuff I have
good news real good news it's just going
to happen it will naturally will it 100%
yeah cuz we're like how do we level up
content in Egypt and how do we get more
localized in Saudi it'll happen just get
people on yeah people will take care of
the rest yeah creators that is or
resources to guide humans will do it
humans will do it and I keep telling my
teams we have to be on the street with
the you are you that's right are
you able to put people into the for you
like do you guys have any levers to yes
of course so now it's we have influence
so that's the game brother yeah like if
Maha dm' me and she's like hey they need
more of this kind of content and you'll
get for you in the Middle East I'm like
done done exactly done that's the game
100% that's the game it's accelerated
growth that's what we're putting on the
table get you put put quality content
and will as in quality defined by keep I
know how you and and you're right and
I'm glad you are hedging and we're
accelerate the growth
whatever most interesting thing in the
world yeah I will produce whatever
content any platform wants for me for
Accelerated growth
yeah where we going M we're here we're
going to circal Avenue so this is like a
warehouse District where they have like
funky coffee shops and art and
warehouses and we're going to meet Anis
bash the amirati and uh he has a show
called the here at called AB talks AB
talk um it's a YouTube show and a
podcast take a right we just arrived AAL
is a culture Hub here in Dubai um when I
launched podcast in aami one of the
things we were trying to do is how to
sort of bring the culture here celebrate
all the the storytellers that were
there how did podcast do on the platform
um so I left before we actually
officially launched so I start
structured it and put it together I
think there was uh uh there was rapid
growth because it's growing naturally
and my role was to get more people on
board to create a variety of content uh
to get more entertainment content and
start working I ended up creating two
podcasts myself one about hip-hop and
one about Fitness and is it the biggest
it's the Spotify for the region yeah so
anami is uh anam's got 50 million active
users every single year it's literally
the biggest by far it's been up for 7
years um across the region um and how's
it spelled a n g h Mi i a n g h m i m i
anami in Arabic means my Tunes my Tunes
um not your most creative and
differentiator but words um but what
angami did well that made them win is
they socialized the experience and they
start including stuff like stories and
podcasts and interviews and and all that
stuff Beyond just going there to head
play and find find find the songs and we
worked a lot with the rising community
so I put a lot of eff with team on
content here in Dubai and other markets
how do we start breeding the tier C tier
D artists that are going to become tier
B tier a next year and Mentor them and
try to give them scale and growth I love
that all that stuff um and then same
thing happened with
podcasts it's been it's been a crazy
journey and where were you before then
so before Tik Tok I was in anami and
then before anami I was in a a media
company called ond so I used to consult
for Global Brands McDonald's Visa you
yeah and where were you born I was born
in Lebanon Lebanon yeah but I've been
here for 20 years give and take y that
fantastic fantastic not not only did I
meet you I had amazing
CH thank you Hi how are you good how are
you good good good don't do much often
I'm G he said pictures on Tik
Tok all take care stay well than time
thank you thank you how are you hey hey
H to meet you guys nice to meet you how
are you this his little brother it's
awesome nice to meet you should see
their see you it's been a year Mick's
the Hi how are you nice
me the place is Marvin how are you
Marvin mom's side of the business so she
more woman empowerment that's aing and
all of that still not done very
different really cool Forest modern love
that vayer media office I think yeah
it's cool is it yeah thank you Ron the
family it's nice every oh mine great
thank
you okay boys team is here how are you
meet Hello nice to meet you what's up
bro how are
you smells good in here
all right keep this as efficient as
possible like
yesterday all right in the nutshell yep
the interview will never be posted until
you you guys watch it okay if you're
happy we it's approved I just I'm being
dead serious okay yeah I don't need I
just want you to be completely
yourself that's all I know how to do one
time let's do it try to be efficient
let's have aoup photo first you and got
it okay we're good boys we're good all
right 3 two 1
and Gary V yes sir gady V very good you
got it who the [__] are you wait
before I want you I read a very cool
stat that said that people people who
swear are usually much more honest
people I swear you swear way more than
me but I want you to be as honest as you
feel free so I'll start with who are you
I'm uh
a very grateful human and that gratitude
drives a lot of functions of my life the
way I the way I build businesses the
reason that I'm been doing this
interview um AKA people know who I am um
at its core I'm a deeply grateful
individual who you know for context you
know was an immigrant from the Soviet
Union who went to the US and like many
immigrants in many parts of the world
had the luxury of the adversity of that
situation become
foundational um which also led to a
complete lack of entitlement which which
leads to humility but deep drive and
conviction um well parented very well
parented um and deeply ambitious you
know deeply ambitious for legacy
first um and uh and that's that's who I
think I am you you had so many things I
want to talk about but first one is your
childhood yes how do you I know you left
belus yes I I know at one point you had
eight people in a
studio how did that shape you I think it
shaped me a lot you know I I think that
not having a lot at a young age
is a very big
Advantage you know it's very hard to be
hungry when you've been
fed and
so I think it shaped me in a lot of ways
a I'm extremely close to my mother like
very close um
be you know not only did we not grow up
with a lot but on top of not growing up
with a lot my mom is deeply
cheap so even when we I can relate there
are some things in my life that are the
same it's crazy even when we got to like
middle class we still lived in like I I
you know it's fun to like think about
you know as I've gotten more notoriety
and as I've challenged myself to bring
more value to people I've had to think a
lot more about what's worked and and you
just start thinking and I'm like wait a
minute you know things that I never
thought I'm like wait a minute after a
while we were not that poor but we still
didn't buy anything oh crap my mom's
cheap you know I think it's a mentality
It is Well my mother my mother my
mother's dad my grandfather kind of you
know in communism you're not allowed to
really own anything but it was all black
market and he kind of you know clearly
I've got my both my grandfathers had a
lot of entrepreneurial DNA so it makes a
lot of sense of who I am
she kind of was like pretty well off
which by the way in bellarus in the
1950s and 60s was ghetto but it was the
she was the Ghetto Queen of the ghettos
and then my grandfather went to jail for
10 years in communist and Russia and she
lost everything and I think that has
always stuck with her her having a
little something in context and her
losing that she we talked about it last
week like you know I'm trying to get my
parents I'm encouraging them they're
thinking about buying a home in Miami to
go down you know they're getting older
they're in their you know mid-60s
they're starting to I want them to enjoy
this next decade and she's a cheap girl
from the old country she really is but
it's very interesting because my mom
went through [__] in her life and even
when she became secure she always feels
that it's not secure yet and it's not
stable I need to have this much in my
account to feel like I'm okay and for me
it's a little different but the same I
don't have a number I need to have but I
save money which is like something
nobody talks about
anymore everyone's like how do I raise
money nobody talks about saving money
yeah you know and so so your
relationship with your parents you think
is good yes solid more than solid that's
great I I would argue that I fear the
death of my parents at the same level
that I fear the death of my children
which I think is unnatural which speaks
to the relationship I think I have with
my parents okay um moving I know you're
not a fan of the education assistant I'm
not I'm not too but unfortunately it's
also a very intrinsic part of the
worldwi we we're in right so we can
criticize it so much me and you cuz I'm
the same and I talked about it but what
do you think is really maybe quick
changes that we can do to at least start
being in the right path of Education I
think we have to understand that every
single human is different and if we
don't reverse engineer what they're good
or bad at and they have to go through
One Singular system it's inconceivable
that we're doing anything good for
them miraculously 33% of those kids 18
29 54 71 will get what they want I just
think that it's
unfortunate to force somebody from six
to 18 or 22 to go through a system that
does brings them no value and prepares
them for nothing that happens in real
life how are we still in 2020 in a world
where we do not educate children on how
to manage
money yeah how like it's not even there
not a kid is being taught about how to
manage money every kid is being talked
about outer space
who gives a [__] about outer space I
don't care about Saturn people don't
know how to pay their
taxes we it's a complete a it doesn't
work for everybody and it and everyone
has to do it that's bad
B looking at the room here and
definitely the people behind the camera
anybody who now lives life post School
realizes there's an enormous amount
about life that we were not prepared for
in any shape or form why fits all one
size fits-all can't work for anything
two even what's taught in there is
missing core things why don't we teach
self-esteem why don't we teach money
management why don't we teach mental
health just talk about that any why
don't we teach anything that's valuable
let's everything that's taught is stuff
that people memorize correct why should
I memorize something I'll give you
where's my phone I got the answer to my
phone it's crazy
the whole system is fundamentally broken
I think what what I what I find bizarre
is that when we are born literally what
they talk about is how unique your
fingerprint is how unique is a person
and how special you are right but then
all the big systems are one siiz as Sol
education all of you have to have a
bachelor's degree yeah but I don't want
to study you have to pass biology I
don't like biology no you have to but
you said I'm special you said I'm unique
I don't want to no you have to so
suddenly if you don't even have a CV who
looks at you today very few
corporations who wants to work for a
corporation but you see what I mean but
by the way the best corporations in the
world are not looking at CVS anymore
College Google Facebook these are not
College required companies Vayner media
proudly does not yeah well listen a lot
of things take so long like we it took
us so long to demonize beating your
wife it took us in America in 1975 in
America in 1975 half the States it was
legal to rape your own wife it takes us
so long for
everything it we had concentration
camps that murdered millions of Jews 70
years ago we do a lot of things that are
stupid people are very funny they're the
best but we have tons of stupid things
and the modern education system in an
internet world makes no
sense uh one of the lectures I heard and
uh
uh you said that 99% of the
entrepreneurs that were attending would
fail I'm like [__] that's refreshing
because I hear all the fluff on the
other side all of these life coaches
selling so many words giving that
24-hour boost of morale which then
crashes and I'm like okay at least this
guy is real the question I have which is
also related to what you just said in a
time where we have the internet me and
you when I'm I'm 38 now I don't know how
old
44 we didn't have have the internet in
the beginning today they have every tool
every search to not fail why do you
think so many entrepreneurs didn't fail
cuz it's
hard it's hard this is entrepreneurship
got cool look at you and I look at you
and I right now dressed and acting at 38
and 44 when we were six and S years old
people at 38 did not wear the Travy
Scots n like you know like like it's a
different C culture um and but it's hard
it's hard number two entrepreneurship
got
cool and that's the biggest issue right
now trending it's trending people like
like you know how it's crazy like I'm a
40 I'm the coolest I've ever been at 44
because entrepreneurship got cool and
now everybody wants to be one just like
a rapper just like an athlete it's that
cool correct that's Danger dous it
because first of all every guy wants to
do it cuz it helps him get
girls 90% of them should not be
entrepreneurship entrepreneurship is
super
lonely it's anxiety
filled I was telling drock yesterday I
hate being on this part of the world
because when we go to sleep there's
still action going on in New York and
New York is where most of my headaches
are and I can't attend to them and I
can't attend to it so I go to sleep not
as comfortably
it's lonely right I relate I mean I wake
up at 3:00 a.m. write a note that so I
just don't forget and then it's it's
quite it's not and right now people
raise Capital so they can make pretend
they're
winning when you raise Capital you can
disguise success
correct so I'm talking about it not
because I want to say I'm an
entrepreneur and you're not I'm saying
it because I know what happens next what
happens next is the money stops flowing
cuz there's a global economic slowdown
cor right and I do believe that 90% 95%
of the people that we know that have
startups will fail because they didn't
build a business they were building a
deck to raise more Capital yeah they're
in it for a completely different reason
completely they're not in for the game
they're in it for what how it makes them
look and the potential of money yes and
that's very dangerous like this is what
I tell a lot of the students in in
University because I'm like you don't
see somebody who has a cafeteria making
money you're like ah he's making money I
should open a cafeteria and that's what
you see you see cafeteria cafeteria
cafeteria dry cleaner dry I'm like just
because he made money you shouldn't why
did you why are you doing it so you have
to have passion but you have to have the
skill for it do something you're
passionate at all but you're actually
good at or if you have the passion and
your skill is okay settle into knowing
that you're you're only going to make
130,000 M accept that aim for happiness
be
self-aware I'm not the best fashion
designer but I love it so much that I
know I'm not going to make 5 million a
year but I love it so much right
nobody's talking about that that's
awareness man yeah you I mean like look
this is real for me I want to make the
$130,000 take-home fashion designer Happ
the problem is right now every fashion
designer wants to become off-white
correct they like if it's not a there
are kids running around thinking that if
they don't build a billion dooll company
it's not a big company we've completely
lost sense of reality it's completely
broken one thing to to compliment what
we're saying is um I read I've done a
bit of research thanks to Nikki um that
you at one point were posting I think a
video every day on YouTube for years
correct yes okay and this I think what
people don't realize is the hard work
the focus the consistency and the
quality ncky what you weren't able to
research was from 2007 to 2011 I replied
to every single email and tweet I got
until 4 in the morning nobody knew who I
was so I would go into Twitter search
search wine terms and jump into
conversations that people would tweet
having this P Noir and I would reply
they didn't know me and I would reply
that's a good one did you try the year
before and slowly but surely for hours
and hours and hours for years and years
and years I built a foundation that
years and years and years later started
the creation of what people see now and
meanwhile people start a Tik Tok account
post five times don't go viral and
they're like this sucks
but that's the issue I know what the
issue is we're in a drivethru convenient
no waiting so people are in
relationships which we'll briefly talk
about as soon as they don't like okay by
[__] it yeah they want to order food
they go to over they want to dat they go
on Tinder it's so quick gratification
that I'm not even wired to just [__]
wait or I go to the gym they go three
times they're like I don't have a
sixpack you need to go for 3 months and
you need to eat better but they don't
want they go do dios section and it's
it's scary that nobody's giving that
what I was asking you about the
consistency of effort you know you're
preaching the the Lost Art of
patience and foundational and and this
has a lot to do with
parenting our parents generation around
the world where they could when they
they borrowed money from parents our
parents borrowed money from grandparents
and paid them back if they wanted a
house or start a
business now kids think their parents
should just give them money yeah if
you're 22 years old or older in the
world and your parents are giving you
money you're in deep trouble why because
you have been told by your parents and
you've told yourself that you were un
incapable of standing on your own two
feet
cor which immediately leads to
insecurity which leads to very bad
behavior defend is the
end and then when I say this this maybe
the fifth or sixth time I've said this
publicly I'll get a bunch of emails
saying you don't know me I have two
children from a bad man who left me I'm
like live in a worse
house I'm like why am I looking at your
in if your Situation's so horrible and
and you need to think your parents why
did I just click your Instagram account
and you have a Prada
bag yeah we become so
materialistic that people want all these
things but they want them the question
is why do they want them they want them
because we're communicating to the world
every one of us right now is wearing
what we're wearing our haircuts
everything communication we're
positioning ourselves to the
world I I I really really think there's
a lot of important conversations that
are not being had I'm trying to throw
them out there and I enjoy I remember
you know meeting with you like a year
ago like I like when people see what I
and and my hope is that if I have the
courage to say stuff that people aren't
talking about then others will start
doing it like these are important this
is an important video this what if one
kid or grownup watches this on YouTube
and changes their behavior exactly
that's intense Legacy and it's by the
way it's a passion project there's no
sponsorship I even remove the ads I
believe you I want to do content for the
sake of good content because it's
lacking we need thousands of us
thousands and eventually it becomes the
culture correct this is the first year
that I've seen kids and cool kids post
on their Instagram things like gratitude
and empathy and kindness and I'm like
I'm making an impact you know yeah I'll
switch it to a personal because I think
think it's really important to talk as
human beings please um more than 15
years with all the popularity the um
demand the power it's not easy to
sustain relationships today you can you
were talking about the other people that
quit how do you survive I don't want to
even use the word survive because I
think it has a negative connotation how
do you sustain a healthy relationship
with all that attention every
relationship whether it's your spouse
your boyfriend girlfriend your children
your parents
your business partners your siblings
every relationship is 100% predicated on
communication that's your secret and
that's it and when it works for me it
works as of communication and when it
doesn't work for me it's because of
breakdown of communication and and
that's it that's for me and that's for
every other single person on Earth it's
that it's kind of like everything else
we talk about and I think one of the
things that's been obvious to me in our
limited interactions with each other is
I don't think we overthink
things you made a great point about
plastic surgery I think about that a lot
I really do when I talk about business
or how simple I just answered the
relationship question all of this is
wildly simple people just don't want to
do it you want to you want your body to
look better eat better and go to the gym
that's it very simple that's it every
course every book every every conference
every video is just extra layers of fat
on a very simple thing you want to build
a business here's how you do it make
something that people want make it
always about the customer make it always
about your employees be patient be
disciplined rinse and repeat rinse and
you know these things can be wildly
simple the problem is we complicate them
more importantly the things that are
simple are actually hard it's hard to be
simple yeah yeah it's hard to do hard
work you know people have egos like you
know I tell the kids all the time at 27
years old I was in a liquor store in New
Jersey ringing people up and taking
boxes to the car that's my life that's I
was doing that so of course when you're
24 and you're freaked out that you
haven't made it yet of course I'm going
to laugh at that of course I lived
something else I I want you to see it so
I think it's communication do you think
think uh cuz obviously your page is very
objective about work entrepreneurship
and and if people even keep scrolling
they don't see anything about your being
a father of you or a husband is it
obviously it's by design of course but
do you I think I'm the most public I'm
the most public private person there is
yes you see so there's the others that
will I don't want to say sabotage but
they will put out their family and they
become family easy likes right yeah you
know what gets easy likes girlfriends
and boyfriends food your pet yeah
children layup yes I I am
convinced that there are enormous
amounts of people in the world that have
children just for
Instagram it's like a bag like a
designer
B so
now that doesn't bother me believe it or
not because I believe an enormous amount
of people have children because they
think they're supposed to at a certain
age because their mother's putting
pressure on them like there's a lot of
other reasons people you know especially
in this region of course listen one of
the one of the reasons I think I do
resonate quite a bit in Asia in the
Middle East in other parts of the world
is I deeply understand immigrant culture
I deeply and and I understand old world
culture they connect to you also 100% an
old world culture TR you know like so I
get it I get it I mean the biggest one
in the region for me the single biggest
reason I love coming to this region is
just to go on stage and put pressure on
the parents to stop using their
children as collateral for their own ego
interesting the number one flaw the one
thing that Americans are detached from
their children which I don't think is
great but the one thing that is
Extreme in this part of the world is
parents tell kids to do things that
makes them look good not makes their
it's 100% selfish this this part of the
world Asia India wildly selfish parents
who force their kids cuz it makes you
don't want to embarrass the family you
don't want to you want you you have to
go to that school to make me look good
you have to be an engineer or a banker
you have to go to Harvard in America to
make me look good I haven't even paid
attention to what makes you happy
absolutely you're a product of me
question what makes my kid and you know
what makes me mad and I talk to some of
these 63 year olds 45 year olds I'm
like like this is what hurts me about 20
the cliche 22-year-old kid in this part
of the world they listen to their
parents talk about how their
grandparents made them miserable for
doing what they wanted and they're just
repeating the same behavior human
behavior of course it is but it's but
it's time for it to stop and things stop
when people start talking correct and
the reason I'm saying this right now is
for that reason hopefully the next
person takes it and it didn't start with
me these things were things I heard or
observe who the hell you know you know
sometimes you don't know where you got
it from but it's happening and actually
a lot of what works for me and this
might help others I think so much of who
I've become has to do with my listening
not my talking I
read comments DMS emails that's how I
learned people tell me things how is it
being a father
it's really interesting being a father
I'll explain why
I am so in love with my children yet I
am so passionate to not impose anything
on
them you know Will Smith's book some
literally a law of attraction [__] so
last week recommended video click on it
Will Smith talks about how um Willow his
daughter
was the challenge of his life because he
wants to impose things because we we do
that like you said to feed our ego to
impose things on her and he's like I
realized that our kids are like seeds
the seed will be what it will be
whatever plant they may be us as parents
water give the environment 100% my
daughter is already showing that she is
a remarkable student she might be the
best student in her class in a private
school in New
York my daughter's
much better at school at this a my
daughter is a much better reader right
now than I ever was uh she and like that
makes me
happy like when sometimes my friends
figure this out they're like are you
okay I'm like with what they're like you
hate school I'm like I hate school for
me I love school for her she's learning
her ass
off I I don't have any
absolutes I just want flexibility
I don't have absolutes even though I
speak in absolute terms everybody else
has
absolutes yeah black or white right I'm
only
gray I'm just talking about things that
are the alternative to the accepted
black got it that's what I'm doing I
think I operate in the same I don't
think one size all for anything it can't
it's you know why we're
logical very it's been dangerously
so but by the way that's how you know
that's how we' got to
this it can't one size fits all here's
the
proof here's me not and I can show you a
million people that are happy functional
and wildly successful that crushed
school and loved it and that's
amazing but you know what's interesting
I grew up in the US when
entrepreneurship was nothing and school
was the thing
and so now to see it the reverse that
it's funny that's why I'm pushing
against entrepreneurship for everyone
you want to read them BS I I just want
self- awareness individual individual
him him him him her her individual what
makes you happy what are you good at and
then more you said something very smart
and and I added something but I think we
should go back to it if you love
something and you're good at it it's
going to be a big win correct I think
the Nuance on that is if you love
something and you're not good at it it
might be worth doing cuz being happy is
more important in making money but you
have to be honest with yourself that
you're only going to make a $40,000 a
year being a painter because nobody's
going to buy your painting like if you
learn to live on a $440,000 year budget
this is what you know what's funny I
I've realized something about me I'm
like right I'm cooking an entire meal
with the things I talk about so in
individual ingredients when people look
at it it might be one thing but if you
take all the things I'm saying it's an
entire
meal okay and and I like how you react I
like that I like it too because I think
it can bring a lot of happiness and if
you understand how the internet works
there's a lot of people that can be much
happier if they settle into I'm a
$63,000 a year T-shirt maker you see
where I'm going but it takes another
ingredient and I know this is a good one
cuz I'm really getting them right now
you have to live a life on the means of
63,000 you can't be a $63,000 a year
t-shirt guy but mommy and daddy are
giving you $100,000 a year so that you
can live in a better neighborhood and
drive a BMW cuz that's going to lead to
resentment between Mom and Dad and you
and entitlement from you you have to if
you want to be a big shot I love when
people you know some of my more young
liberal friends are like I just want to
be happy and I'm like no you want to
just do art but you want your parents to
pay for it
yeah we need more real conversations
absolutely we have to put making 63,000
a year because you love t-shirts and
that's all you can do on Shopify and at
the flea market you have to buy a home
that you can afford you have to go to
the holiday in not the Ritz Carlton if
we can get to that it could get big it
could get real big and the way we do
that is by us applauding our friends who
make 63,000 and go holiday in not W look
I went to the Ritz Carlton you know
what's funny I got a
comment uh a guy told me I was an
economy with my kids and I took a
picture and I posted it on story and he
goes anest I don't get you I'm like
excuse me he goes one day you're in a
private jet the other day you're in
first class now you're in economy I'm
like ah so when I'm in economy I'm not
supposed to post that's what you're
telling me I'm like bro it doesn't
matter I'm with my family I'm happy
doesn't change the fact that I have to
oh no I have to run off to first class
think have become come but that's the
world not the world I live in neither me
but I guess we're the strangers at some
point which hopefully becomes the common
it's going to become the common yeah cuz
this is going to break there's so much
unhappiness in the world un sustainable
it's not
sustainable okay I'll go to different
questions you seem um generally people
can say that you're uh loud uh
fast-paced like you're running out of
time maybe some people say you're angry
do you feel these feelings do you feel
you're running out of time that you need
to do so much no I feel like I have so
much time okay I'm definitely not angry
people confuse how one communicates in a
certain environment for their
truth when I'm on stage talking to 5,000
people and I'm hyped and and if I'm
angry I'm I'm angry at the systems that
have created their unhappiness I'm
actually
thrilled that I escaped those
vulnerabilities I'm actually so grateful
it's funny so yeah I see all those
comments and ater all the the the
funniest one is my college friends spent
their entire four years trying to get me
to smoke weed and I promised my mom in
seventh grade that I would never do
drugs so when people leave the comment
like Aderall or cocaine because I'm so
fast and Hyper me my my college friends
get the biggest kick cuz they just think
it's so funny because they're like man
if they just knew
uh I'm fast but that's just cuz I have a
lot of adrenaline and I talk fast like
and my brain works fast uh do you think
you have a big ego no I but I think I
have enormous
confidence I think ego is insecurity big
difference if a big ego is Big
insecurity I think we are all born Egos
and it can be a good tool but if you let
it control you it's very dangerous I I
actually have no connection towards ego
I I don't think I'm special let's just
start there I understand that I was
gifted things but that's not me I think
my parents are special I think my
parents should have an
ego but I'm the bi I'm the byproduct
yeah how the hell that's like I love
people that are gorgeous they're funny
to me you didn't do anything yeah he
were born this way and that's how I feel
just cuz I understand people better than
almost anybody I've ever met I didn't do
that that's my parents had sex at the
right
second it's hard I mean this it's hard
for me
to think I'm special or you know if
somebody says do you like listening to
yourself and the wisdom that comes out
of you I consume nothing that I put out
no I do not like listening to myself at
all I like what I'm
saying what don't you like about G
that I that it took me a very long the
the thing I don't like about me is the
thing I'm most working on which is on a
one toone level I struggle with cander
because I don't like hurting people's
feelings which blows people away when I
answer that CU I haven't shared that a
lot I'm starting to share it because I'm
so raw and real on stage but in real
life for my company and my relationships
I I struggled with cander because I hate
negativity
H have you been depressed
no worst moment in your
life worst moment in my
life probably when I probably when I
realized there was real conflict between
me and my dad when I kind of really knew
there was one day when I left the store
just left it which I never did in
November when I was like 28 29 and I
knew I knew that I wouldn't be there
anymore that was tough for me because I
really enjoyed building that business
for him and I was willing to do it
immigrant style and be there for a very
long time I'm so patient that I thought
I can do this and build this for him
until I'm 50 and then I'll go build my
own thing so that that hurt because I
there was more that I wanted to give him
you cut the umbilical cord then yeah
that's just that's something I've never
really said I've never said this out
loud ever but it's the true answer it
was tough because I felt bad for him
that you let him down no that he let me
get
away best moment in your life when my
daughter was born I I it's a very close
one to it's either the day my my when
the second my daughter was born
I looked at her I was at the side she
came out she was looking straight and
then she turned and looked at
me it's I have never ever cried so on a
second and so hard it was crazy I feel
yeah it was guys it was super crazy I
just am so grateful it's so funny how I
have nothing close to that with my son
sorry Xander but she came out and I was
right here and when she turned I just it
completely destroyed me and that is
either one or it's two or it's tied with
the day that the New York Jets beat the
Patriots in New England in the second
round of the playoffs in
2011 I uh I
uh I'm not kidding the one place that
I'm completely
irrational because I'm not in control
is my deep love for the New York Jets
the amount of pain the Patriots had
brought they had beaten the Jets 45 to
three five weeks earlier it was the
playoffs all my friends that usually
come to jet games with me didn't go just
me and my brother and two other people
cuz they didn't want to go there and get
slaughtered I walked in there like I was
going to get killed like literally like
this is I'm not even going to use the
analogy but I was walking into death I
remember walking into that Stadium
everyone's making fun of us not a word
no face and to watch them be able to
beat them and see that and then watch
all those Patriot fans have to leave and
this one guy was giving me a really hard
time five rows in front of me like he
was drunk he was nasty you're going to
lose like spitting almost fighting and
then when the when it became obvious the
Jets were going to win he tried to leave
I'll never forget this the Jets went up
10 points late the game was over and he
tried to leave and I was like six seats
in off the aisle the most athletic thing
I've done in my life I somehow in one
second went over six people and grabbed
him and said where the [__] do you think
you're going and it was like one of the
Great Moments Of My Life Pure maybe the
best moment of my life I like that um I
love the
journey I love the journey cuz it makes
you cherish the win you know what's
funny I will actually argue that one of
the great vulnerability one of the
things I don't like about Gary is I'm
incapable of smelling the Roses I don't
like the win I didn't like my birthday
the other the team I had a really
interesting moment two weeks ago the
team did something very sweet for me my
team Gary put made content and put up my
face and a big thing for me in Time
Square and they brought me into an
office and they're like we got to show
you something and drock and dkirk were
in Time Square during the hour and were
live to for me to see it and I reacted
as if they like stole my wallet and a
lot of the team doesn't know me that
well and I I I remember thinking this
sucks because this was so sweet and I'm
so grateful but I'm incapable of Faking
my emotions
so I just I don't like I know you
understand it's a vulnerability of mine
I actually I'm ever fully satisfied you
know what's funny I'm satisfied you know
what's funny I'm fully satisfied in the
G I'm fully satisfied right now when I
win I don't like it I know I don't like
it I just like the game it's why I think
I'm such a good
entrepreneur I don't want the money I
don't want the BMW that was actually my
next question but I'm glad you're
telling you continue you don't want the
BMW no I mean I'll drive a BMW it's fine
I don't have one but like no none of
this is for this stuff all of it is for
where where do I rank as the best
entrepreneurs of all time number 37
number four billion number one number 19
like I'm playing the game the real game
and I think actually one of the reasons
that I think I've
become the entrepreneur that is giving
back by far the most in my opinion to
other entrepreneurs with no I think
value for free is because I probably
subconsciously think that's my hack to
being the best entrepreneur because bezo
and some of these other they're putting
up some real numbers and I don't think
I'm going to get there uh but in my own
mind if I'm judging entrepreneurship on
impact I genuinely think I'm having a
huge impact on the next generation of
entrepreneurs and that makes me proud
and whe wherever that means in ranking
it feels very good last few questions
it's very close to what you just said
we're born Gary with a need to feel seen
or valued or relevant it's a need in
child daddy look at me do this or look
at yes what do you think
is what makes you feel SE and value like
you're adding value what is it the
feedback of admiration I'm chasing
admiration everybody out here is chasing
private jets I'm chasing
admiration okay it's one thing to be
seen it's another thing to be seen for
what
are you being seen because you know how
to kick a football past a goalie are you
being seen because you're wildly
attractive are you being seen because
you're funny are you being seen because
you stole money and it looks like you've
made money like what are you being seen
for I want to be seen more than anybody
in the
world why I'm being seen is what I'm
most proud of I like that you to many
you seem Fearless but what are you
afraid of snakes I don't like snakes so
much me too I yeah snakes are [__] up
you know I don't like snakes I I fear
the death of 10 or 11 people a lot I
actually think the first time I truly
disappear for a little while is probably
one of my parents' death I can see
myself really going into a a form of
depression or Funk because I live my
complete life on the gratitude that
those people are healthy and happy I'm
completely po the reason I'm fearless
and happy is because it's about those 12
people so my fear intuition it's really
the one thing left for me at 44 there's
one thing left that I'm curious about
with me which is when I lose one of
them what happens do I do what I
normally do which is default into such
optimism that I say I'm so lucky that I
had all this time with them or have I
put all my chips in there and when one
of them goes I do go into a place where
I can't get my juices going for a month
3 months a
year I don't know that answer but that
is the one thing left that I want to
that I'm excited I mean it I'm even
though I fear it it's the one thing that
I'm
it's the last piece of curiosity I have
about me because everything else is very
obvious any
regrets you know what's funny I'm I'm
really good at not regretting things but
I will say this I do believe that I took
it too far when it comes to work ethic
between 14 and 30 I worked every minute
nobody will ever know my my mom got
emotional about it a couple years ago
she's like they'll never believe you
because she almost feels bad my dad too
I mean I worked every minute all of
them all I mean all of them literally
every weekend every summer vacation of
my entire adolescence I worked and I
don't think that's healthy that's too
much that's I could have used some
balance I'm so I do regret that a little
bit I do um my problem is it's hard for
me to G regret because I think me being
so unique has led to so much happiness
that I I I the reason I the I'm trying
to challenge myself to actually answer
these questions with that but but then I
have to say this for the record and then
even as I just told you that I in my
chemicals I can feel like no I don't
regret it because the
extreme that I went through created a
very unique voice that leads to all my
happiness I I I can't
I
can't it's my journey I can't I'm too
happy I'm just deeply happy and grateful
I can't
critique last one Gary what
word that's really good Gary in one word
kind okay I like that
[Music]
thanks
thank
am I good with that it was amazing
amazing it was really
good get and get a photo of all of you
hi it's great to see you hello how are
you how are you it's great to see you
how are you I wish you so much it's so
good to see you everything's very good
to see you look we're in Dubai I love it
so good you well yeah good
Gary can now I understand why you're so
doled up you knew there'd be a lot of
pictures today I was like I was
literally does my hair look nice guys it
look your hair you always look
good let's fix
it okay we got it thank you that was
unbelievable that's good yesterday and
seeing you now in real life and it's
like such an honor thank you brother
[Music]
you still taking this
picture it's right he's got Good
Vibes it's funny I saw I saw Brady talk
about that game and I could tell he was
still pissed about it and it made me so
worst days I'm not saying because it's
the one day that my kids saw a really
bad side of me that game that game yeah
that was a shocking result and just like
what you said cuz week few weeks before
453 yeah I'm like there's no way we
going to lose this no shot anyway
pleasure know actually while you were
doing his videos I used to follow Ryan
Dice and you know I to see San Diego to
see you speak uh but yeah man I just
love what you're doing thank you so
much
hi
got it awesome thank you yeah everybody
needs to get the crew
[Music]
get thank you so much you're
welcome how are
you
it's wings I love shoes thank you
brother thank you yes the next one how
are
you awesome brother take care nice to
meet you Hi how are you good nice to
meet
youo yeah of course let's do I miss you
I miss you too how have you
been Instagram
story I love this piure can we do an
Instagram story we
can
so guys andab be
Dubai Gary V don't tell them hi
everybody how are you I'm so good it's
so good thank you I miss you too it's so
good to be here thanks for having
me yeah we're going to take a picture uh
sorry one more love
[Music]
you thank you you're welcome thank you
so much you're
welcome ready
ready so good you're welcome thanks for
having me thank you for
coming very interesting like you know
what's funny it's more um I I've got a
good
yeah it's funny I don't know what it is
I I will say this this was a little bit
of what we talked about I'm a so I'm not
only unique in the fact that like how we
ended the interview I'm unique in the
way I grew
up I'm unbelievably unique in my
vocabulary and mannerisms because I
really never consume anybody it's
actually why I think the least unique
thing about me is when I give Keynotes
because I think it is very much Chris
Rock and Eddie Murphy and Richard Pro I
I think basically I'm a black comedian
in the way that I deliver I love us
standups those like they affect like
that was probably the most Chappelle
came after I'm a little bit older
so I actually when I like analyze like
this right or like so many other things
the words I use I'm like wow what a
power not consuming anything does for
you but the one thing that I absolutely
know like between Randy the Machu Man
Savage the way he did promo videos like
it's kind of how I like when I started
doing it like I looked back I found some
of them
online Dubai I'm coming on December you
know like it's wrestling promos yeah
yeah yeah so it's funny how and that's
that's why that I think a lot about this
I think I'm unique and breaking through
in a world think about this I would
argue that accomplishing success of
attention in today's
environment is remarkably difficult
because everyone's producing content
absolutely Instagram will tell you you
need to post two to three times a day
compared to one I mean think about that
we're competing against the whole world
and for me to be winning in that game I
think it has a lot to do with the fact
that I just have a unique style that is
uniquely my own cuz I consumed no movies
very little I consumed such little stuff
and again it all plays out it was
hip-hop that I consumed I skew herban
because of that it was between the The
Comedians and music like so much of what
I consume plus you know it's really
interesting it all makes sense it all
makes sense you know um [__] I was about
to say something pretty interesting uh
uniqueness
growing this oh ready I got a hot take
I'm making a
prediction a fun one within the next 4
years I'm going to get spoofed on SNL
you think I do I I I think I can see
that cuz I think I'm very easy to get to
spoof oh yeah I mean the one video the
other day was outrageous outrageous so
good I'm very easy to get spoofed I
think within the next decade I'm going
to either have one of two things happen
I'll decide to do a big show on an Ott
that will make me Global or I'll have
one
video Hit 100 million views yeah like
it'll very possible both very possible
you're already quite Global right you
know but I think there'll be that one
moment right and then then you really
got wide Milestone that'll be the next
Milestone that will happen and then SNL
will spoof
me I actually think I might host SNL one
day I think I'd be great at it I'm I'm
really good at improv I could crush it
dck you've been impressed when I've
acted here and there you've been
surprised yeah you were surprised a
little
yeah you did it I always think for
people like us and I'll join us in this
yeah please that we're so true to who we
are and raw with who we are can we
actually act in that movie well it's
funny you know what I think we can do I
got one cuz I've thought about this too
you know what we'd be really good at
what Eminem was good at basically
playing yourself like I would be a great
I'd be a great character in a show being
exactly who I am you know what I mean
but that but there's people who do that
but you know what I going I couldn't do
the other add to what you said it's so
rare for people to be who they are
that's why we stand out 100% because
most people are trying to mimic what
they think is popular you know what else
you know what else is working for us and
I can feel it from
you when you when you start realizing
how much being yourself is working you
become more yourself yeah yeah that's a
Liberation one thing I I I told to ask I
don't know if you ask this one it's like
you say a lot to not give a [__] what
people say or think yes and then I'm I'm
like but you know you're born to always
think about what your parents you know
how yeah your friends your your teachers
your coaches your your boss at work so
how do you just wake up one day and and
hear Gary V say [__] you ready for this
well you don't CU it's not one day it's
you hear it you hear me say something
and it starts the process
yeah and then you practice it and then
you hear it and then you practice it and
you hear it and that's you know but it
was funny I thought you were going to
ask me like how' you do that and it was
funny where my head just went and I've
probably said this in the past but it
was very clear just now I think it's
empathy I think the reason I don't
struggle with judgment is I'm empathetic
that you don't know
everything did you at any point struggle
with it of course I'm sure I'm sure
build that it's it's what my mom said
she's like when somebody says [__] I got
one I got one out of all of the things I
probably struggled the most with uh
asking girls out that didn't come as
natural to me I was more scared of them
saying no that's why I've been married
for like 20
years first said yes said
yes that was Pro probably with girls was
probably of the categories not that it
was atrocious cuz I had something but
not to the level of every other part of
my life so um it was what was it yeah
when I got a bed I used to get some of
course you when people are real you get
a lot of [__] also so some my mother
used to tell me anest when somebody's
saying [__] to you just for one second
imagine which environment they're coming
from that they're spouting all
that like and my is there you got very
lucky that you had your mom do that and
that's what I'm trying to do for people
I'll do for whatever but what I actually
my mom did not do that my mom did
something different which was she
literally made me feel like I was the
best person like when I was being kind
to people it was so powerful but what
was interesting was I had another lucky
chemical in me which was when I started
losing I remember in my childhood I was
so much better at sports than all my
friends around me and then I was nice
and I was charismatic obviously and I
was good at business already like I was
killing I remember when I started losing
in things like fourth grade fifth grade
sixth it took me like a year to be like
I don't know if I I still am pretty
shocked when I loseing anything like
shocked yeah cuz it's not coming har
we're arriving well it was not at all
yes go ahead finish your I'll tell you
um this is the prime minister's office
where the government buildings are so uh
we're meeting right now thank you we're
good Gary V Chuck welcome to Dubai we
absolutely honored to be with you here
today we know you're a man under demand
so we're going to uh just enjoy our
moment here with you today thank you for
being here uh we're going to start off
just first off get straight in there
because we had a lot of questions
through from our listeners what is Gary
B's definition of
success uh the ability to do what I want
when I want at all times and waking up
and going to sleep happy mhm and what is
it you want when you say do what what
what I want when I for for me that is
building businesses producing content
playing the game yeah I don't want the
trophies that come along with
entrepreneurship I just want the game of
it for somebody else that might be
painting all day mhm and however they
can afford that that would be theirs so
it's Freedom you know it's Freedom now
when you become successful and sometimes
your company becomes your jail it
becomes your container but it's freedom
mhm you well let's talk about something
that we just spoke about which was sleep
now this is something that has been a
running theme in a lot of your content
in a lot of your speeches when when you
go around the world and talk about this
uh I'm going to hands up straight up I'm
the worst at sleep we do a morning
breakfast show where we wake crazy I'm
the best at sleep I get 8 hours I love
it really good for you he's the opposite
uh but I actually find I work better
with their sleep when I'm done a four
4our sleep I get on the show and I'm
better than I would be do you catch up
on weekend or I try to as much as
possible look I here's what I would say
in
this I'm such a big fan of work ethic
but I'm very concerned that people think
just working 20 hours a day means you're
successful it does not and so I think
it's important to have balance and yeah
I'm a very big proponent of sleep and I
think people should have more of it not
less I think people should be more
productive when they're awake MH if you
have huge Ambitions it's about your
production while you're aw awake not the
fact that you don't sleep M now I saw
you in charer last year and just you on
stage blows me away You're Incredible
you're inspiring and you're always on
the pools so the the thing that stuck
with me that you said and I went home
and I did it straight away was insta
stories is the thing promote your insta
stories get that sponsor post and you
said 99% of people aren't going to do it
proud to say I'm one of the one of the
1% that did that makes me happy what is
the next thing what's Tik Tok okay and
it's never the next thing it's always
the current thing I never know what the
next thing is I'm not
Nostradamus uh but I do know what the
current thing is and by far the current
thing especially in this region is Tik
Tok it is people laughed at us when we
got T we literally just opened one two
weeks ago people laughed at everybody
when they got a Facebook cuz that was
for college kids people laughed when
everybody got a Snapchat or an Instagram
or got on YouTube or started their own
podcast people always laugh until they
don't mhm until they're the ones doing
what you're doing as well until they're
sat all the celebrities all all the Real
Models laughed at the Instagram models
until they did it so true very true so I
listen I will continue to let them laugh
uh at first and then admire me later Tik
Tok is the underpriced platform and it
and it has already aged up it is
obviously littered with tons of 9 to 15
year- olds but it has already started to
penetrate the 20 to early 30-year-old
set and uh and unless a competitor can
create a feature and stop its momentum
the way Instagram stories did to
Snapchat unless unless it will go on to
become a massive massive Global platform
and oh by the way it already has 1.5
billion users is 1.5 billion users
unbelievable and we got 123,000 views on
one of ours yeah we let's let's talk
about that it's the one platform that
you could have no followers on any
platform put up your first video and get
a million views because there's so much
attention and there's not enough content
yet and that will change in four years
and then it's just going to be like
Instagram now where you post your first
thing and gets three views but right now
that's exactly right one Tik Tok I bet
you this is what happened to you one of
your Tik Tok posts got 197 views and the
next one got 247 literally exactly what
happened I saw one of your Tik toks and
you went around I guess your local area
where you're from yeah and you were
going was garage saying you was looking
at the lemonade stor you were over you
were giving them $20 the $1 what made
you want to do that so that was when I
was garage selling in America when you
garage sale you go to people's Lawns and
you buy stuff from them a lot of the
kids will set up a lemonade stand that
was my first business wow and so that
what what I'm doing when I'm buying
lemonade that's 25 cents and giving the
kid a $20 is I'm passing on one of the
Great Moments Of My Life I had a
lemonade stand in 1985 and a bike rider
drove by and he gave me his water bottle
you know like the water bottle he goes
he goes how much if I fill this this up
and I look at it and I think we were 10
this is 1985 I think we I think we were
10 cents a cup and I said a dollar and
he said okay and I fill it I'm so pumped
I mean he didn't finish saying okay and
I had it filled and then he gave me a 10
and he said keep the change wow I'm
sitting here 34 years later telling you
that story think about the impact that
made so I'm passing on the game I'm
hoping that when I give a 20 to that kid
in that Tik Tok video that that's
something that motivates him and
continues to have him get going and I
think about those moments see what
you're talking about right now is based
on something called gratitude and
kindness and uh and passing that on and
understanding that that is your success
and that is where you win uh in no
matter what industry you're in but I
used to be a professional tennis player
so being in that sporting uh kind of
Realm where it's Doggy Dog no one's nice
to each other it's listen it's you or me
and that's it but let me say this I'm
doggy eats dog when I do business mhm I
bet you there was gals and girls that
you played and you tried to destroy each
other's faces but when the match was
over you guys shook hands and then later
you might have even became friends with
some of them and went out for drinks to
your point people are very confused in
business there doesn't seem to be the
separation actually let's before I I I
don't want to finish this thought I
assume you played very hard and tried to
destroy the face of the other girl but
some of those girls became your friends
or you liked them yeah okay so guess
what that's how I think about business I
want to let there be for all the
kindness and caring and empathy and
gratitude that I'm putting out in the
world and words and actions let there be
no confusion I'm trying to destroy every
other business person on Earth so
there's no kindness in business no no
there's there's kindness in business but
it's a very interesting Nuance you can
be kind and still
compete like of course there's kindness
like I I'm putting out my best
information for free which mean do you
know how many social media agency entire
strategy is watch me regurgitate it and
sell it to clients those are my
competitors I bet they're they're
studying that pack you just released as
well 100% 100% but but it still doesn't
mean that when I go for a pitch against
that agency that I don't want to beat
them so notice yeah yeah yeah got it got
it got it so it's like dog e dog and
then a little bit later in the day dog
feed dog well there's a couple things in
a tennis tournament somebody ends up
winning in the micro
just like at a business pitch but in the
macro the world is abundant M I root for
everybody because they're not taking out
of me I'm going to get
mine I'm going to get mine regardless
regardless and so when I see other
people winning more than me I give
respect that they're executing I I laugh
when people are mad at other people
they're they're beating you like sorry
they you know just like in tennis like
you out you had natural Talent OR you
put in more work it's not super
confusing natural Talent work natural
Talent work that is the framework mhm I
know we got a wrap this one more
question last thing um Gary I I have one
fear my biggest fear snakes no okay no U
my biggest fear is getting a call that
um you know my parents are no longer
here because they have been brought up
in a generation let me quickly tell you
immigrants moved from Africa to the UK
from a young age uh they were in a
generation where survival was key they
have the privilege of us you know where
we talk about 18 to 30 years old
experiment if you fail get back up it's
fine they didn't have that privilege so
now they're edging towards 60 uh nowhere
near retirement they're still healthy
they're cool um but how do you as a
child you're a child you're also a
parent how do you then flip the script
cuz right now I'm worried for them I'm
like when are you going to slow down I'm
still going and I'm good to go how do
you look after yourself well first of
all you're a youngster because I can
promise you right now 58 and 57 and 59
is ridiculously young yeah that doesn't
feel like that for us now because it's
so far like when you get to 59 I hope
you remember this interview you'll like
man he was right like I promise you
every 59-year-old that's watching this
right now is like I I'm living so a
there's that and B all all you can do is
anything it's what I do every day all
you can do is educate all you can do is
say hey Mom stop eating bad food hey Dad
go to the gym hey do are you guys
checking in you know yeah in a but in a
generation that is so cult should that
work work work work work even though
they've done well for themselves and
achieved beyond their dreams but that
may be their happiness yeah you know
your ideology for them maybe is going on
beaches and relaxing but that's not what
they want in the same way that parents
often tell kids what they should be
engineers and doctors but they don't
want to be MH it's just the reverse you
just love them that's all got it just
support it yeah and communicate Your
Truth sweet Gary thank you so much it's
been an honor have a have a great rest
of your time here
thank you guys thank you do you mind if
we get some
sure how we
doing
good together and then solos one
[Music]
side grab me a solo shop
pleas
right
here guess who I'm
with it's
me Mr Gary be hey
[Music]
everybody Legend man thanks pleasure to
meet have a great day today yeah I'll
take one too so we have it ktie wants it
got it awesome cool man real pleasure
thanks really
pleasure to from Brit media such a
pleasure such a pleasure it's a quick
five minutes for uh success resarch okay
can ready thank you thank
you
Gary yes sir welcome back to Dubai man
thank you my friend nice seeing you
again great to see you again so tell me
Gary uh I want to ask you a couple of
questions sure first of all we're only a
month away from 2020 yes so it's really
close it's really close what do you say
what's going to happen in the marketing
and Entrepreneurship sector what's going
on what should we focus on for 2020 I
think it's about written audio and video
content on the 10 platforms that matter
I'm very consistent on this I I don't
need to talk about AI or machine
learning or VR or you know all that
stuff is coming what's going on now is
content at scale contextual to the
platforms of the LinkedIn and the
Snapchats and the Facebooks and the
twitters and the Tik toks and I and I
just don't I I sometimes am fascinated
by people's inability to understand that
producing creative at scale on these
platforms is how you achieve awareness
which then leads to you creating the
business the personal the
governmental Ambitions you want so what
you're saying is for 2020 we need to
even increase that scale of content I
believe that every uh business should
put out 150 piece of content a day that
every person should put out 20 to 50
that every you know and the bigger I
mean do I believe that Pepsi should put
out 4,000 pieces of content a day yes I
do a day yes I think the Delta between
what I see and what I'm seeing people do
is huge yeah you know huge so in terms
of brand awareness and everything is it
different in this region than other
regions is there something specific
people should focus on in terms of
marketing at a specific region 100% and
not only where for example Tik tok's
explosion in the Middle East is an
opportunity that is not necessarily
happening in other parts of the world uh
Twitter is huge in the US not big in
Germany so yes regionality always
matters but everybody watching right now
that lives within a region knows what
six platforms matter YouTube Instagram
Tik Tok very clear that it matters here
but then the content and the
context differs of cultures are
different Friday and Saturday are the
weekend Sunday not America you know like
slang term who's the popular you know
person okay Boomer is a great like term
right now has that come to your part of
the world yet has it not like the slang
the the culture the celebrities the
influencers the vibe the weather it
doesn't look like this in New York right
now so you know I you have to take all
those things into account there's you
know you got to take all those things
the context is the Warfare that is where
the magic is being made exactly and we
having a talk in a couple of minutes so
what do people expect from your talk
what are you going to teach them train
them about I'm not sure you know one of
the fun things about my talking style is
I probably have four to five hours worth
of things that I'm thinking about right
now which which 45 minutes to an hour
hits the stage right now is pretty
improv you know I'm you know if I really
challenge myself to answer a question
I'll probably get
into
entitlement and suppression of Happiness
I'll definitely get into Tik Tok and
LinkedIn because they're wildly
underpriced
distribution uh I'll get into context
I'll get into the volume of content I'll
get into self-awareness I think there's
a lot of people in the audience right
now who want to be entrepreneurs but
aren't and they're not willing to look
that truth in the mirror because right
now it's cool and everybody wants to do
it um those are some of the things I
think I'll talk about thank you so much
k for your time thank you so much take a
picture
yeah yeah hey guys how are
you awesome thank you so much thank you
so much pleasure me such a pleasure to
want this
one
thank you thank
you
yes awesome thank you so much thank
you thank you you're welcome thank okay
this is Thea from Dubai links Li in
Dubai hi hi me run operation here in
Dubai we had a meeting you happen to be
in town really happening so I've been
talking to pter in Paris in can lion
about hopefully connecting having you
come to speak at that one as well Zach
knows so got her ticket told her you
going to see what you're going
get I'm a great fan and a great
follow thank you and then it just saying
hello thanks very
much I hope so take care this is man she
did the Nike hij I'm aware and she was
on the phone with you during one of the
Ask Gary V's really the one who spoke
while you were interviewing no remember
yeah and Fallen intervention yeah I was
the one asking all the questions so
awesome and you well thank you for
following me the day like I tagged you
for the crushing thing book thing yeah
so you're amazing thank you and she's
amazing she's myom love it yeah okay
it's good like I'm just a photo just a
photo yeah but the lighting is not great
because of
the for take it from that angle I'm too
yellow though can you get a full length
one if possible no public display of
affection just
yeah yeah but I like I'll hug you later
but yeah all right 1 two
five perfect thank you Gary I'll be
there for your okay thank you so much so
such a
pleasure I love you this is the team
from Egypt that I was telling
abouted and mm run a Communications
company events company in Egypt talking
about bringing you next year to Egypt
this
is pleasure thank you for coming really
appreciate it we just dropped the Pepsi
ad for cardi B yesterday that was bner
media's work very good yes the one that
came out yesterday this the cardi claw
so we'll make sure Maha sends you a link
if you haven't seen it yet how are you
guys on you very good yes let's do it
we'll take group sure whatever yeah okay
it's
fine okay I got it thank you awesome
such a pleasure pleasure is
our looking forward to see you in I
can't wait I can't
wait I'll take
it one two five I got it okay thank you
thank you so much real pleasure you're
GNA go down you to
speak Steve
yeah I just dropped my podcast
everything legit and I got some awesome
people on it I was wondering if you
could just give me a bit of a sound Gary
vayar and you're listening to everything
legit with Nim meta nim nim meta I'm
going to go with Nim
hey guys it's Gary vuk and you're
listening to everything's legit with
nimi everything legit hey guys it's Gary
vuk and you hey guys it's Gary ve and
you're listening to everything what is
it everything legit hey guys it's Gary
ve and you're listening to everything is
legit everything's legit take a 100 L's
everything legit hey guys it's Gary vean
you're listening to everything legit
with nimi yeah yeah I killed
it
[Music]
all
that so the 8 weeks of Mentor calls I
don't even do I I haven't done train you
guys but I can't give you this and then
8 weeks I'll be there personally me and
my business partner Alex he just sold
his company last week uh last month
sorry August for 300 million bucks
[Music]
[Applause]
he know you're hiding in
your up later all right ready rolling
yep
[Music]
Roland ladies and gentlemen on the
behalf of Forbes Middle East and mental
unblock media we are joined here by the
amazing Gary ve really excited to have
you here in Dubai thank you my friend
it's not your first time not my first
time and definitely not my last what
brings you back got the speech we're you
know Vayner media is looking to figure
out its Global expansions we just opened
up Singapore so I'm always trying to
maximize my time in the region and
decide where and how because it's so
vibrant uh the biggest brands in the
world that obviously we work with on the
vayer media side um are looking at this
region and Dubai specifically all the
time and then obviously the
entrepreneurship that runs through the
blood of the region uh is uh is
something I'm very attracted to
absolutely well listen I know you're
going to go on stage right now we can't
take much of your time we'll do it again
in the future we sure hope guys you have
self awareness backstage self awareness
is the Breakthrough figure it out good
luck man take care see
[Music]
you when we get off on stage after we
inro you once your video has play ladies
and genten okay
so okay hurry are you going on
stage I'm just going to try to do as
much Q&A as possible to bring as much
value as possible and uh I'm really
excited to be here nothing else to
really say very excited very excited
what is you like about the Middle East
odience um I think there's a rawness to
the entrepreneurial spirit that I think
stands out and always has so I like
that man so going to
just okay let's do this come come okay
let's say
[Music]
[Applause]
you okay are you guys ready you think
you're
ready she says she doesn't think you're
ready are you guys
ready well here's the first thing we got
do we need to acknowledge somebody we
know there's someone very special that's
coming from far away to
do very very privileg to have with us
[Applause]
please
special he reu father business
phenomenon $50 million
Powerhouse new
[Music]
yorky
sports that part I want to add the
Dwayne Wade video to
and the cardi B Pepsi thing we just did
I think it'll play you
[Music]
know ladies and Gentlemen please stand
up Qui and welcome the stage one of the
most authentic speakers on the planet
[Applause]
is
hello what's
[Applause]
good thank you thank you thank you thank
you thank you thank you I will read that
sign shortly all right thank you so my
plan here actually is to do quite a bit
of Q&A um because the reality is the
more I do this the more I realize how
simplistic my point of view on uh
marketing and working out or health
you know the reality is is trillions of
and working out at the gym every day is
the actual
answer yet people are looking for celery
or apple vinegar or surgery to execute
that for them and the reality is is
that's basically how I see business the
reality is it's actually quite simple
and more importantly for everybody in
this room we are here during an ex
extremely special time because this
device is wildly underrated by all of
us Dubai this is an amazing moment in
our
lives this man does not own a
smartphone it is more likely that an
alien comes from space and joins me get
up here get up here uh-huh I I believe
it's more likely an alen what's your
name zad zad so nice to meet you let's
clap it up for this legend
legend no smartphone no smartphone you
did have one at some point I did and how
long ago did you get rid of it um 10
days ago 10 days ago I did why I I found
myself wasting too much time and I was
very distracted yes and I find myself
being a lot more productive good for you
I get a lot more done I have people
helping me Y and I am you're enjoy I
send an email I have have a laptop I
send an email and that's it yeah good
for you my friend thank you it's a real
pleasure thanks for being here let's
clap it
up now for the rest of
us communication history the reason
you're seeing things like America and
London and India and all sorts of things
happening in the world different things
that we didn't expect is because of
communication communication has always
been the Forefront of what happens in
the world almost everything you believe
right now was put into your
head by your parent by a piece of
content by something else my friends
please do not waste this conference the
fact that we have this time together to
not let this be the time that you
finally hear me you've been listening to
my my content but you don't hear me
you've been listening to my content but
you don't live what I'm telling you to
do why because there's a much bigger
thing that's going on than what platform
you should post on or how often it's
called
self-esteem the single most important
thing that I think about these days is
that I am blown away by the level of
insecurity there is in our society we
have so much insecurity that Instagram
had to take likes
away because you're not capable of
actually talking about what you actually
want to talk about you are so addicted
to other people's opinions that you
start posting only things that you think
will get likes not what you actually
want to talk
about this is very
important thank you it's very
important thank you it's very important
important I promise you the reason that
I stand on stage is because the
self-esteem and parenting that my mother
put into my body period
period the way she raised
me around putting
kindness and hard work but also no
entitlement not worrying about what
people said about
me is imperative let me tell you what
the biggest vulnerability for most
people here is about social media and
content you enjoy the cheering too
much the reason this is an interesting
game is you love it when you post
something and people say you look
pretty or that was a good
shot or you're funny or that was
brilliant you take compliments too high
so when people come in and and say you
look ugly or you're stupid or you're
wrong you take push back too
deep
I and all the people that I see who are
winning don't take the
compliments or the
insults every day on my content there's
comments that say you suck you're a
loser and the next one you're
God I don't get too high I don't get too
low my
friends you have to leave this
conference today and figure out for
yourself how you are going to post on
social platforms 25 to 60 times a
day let me say it one more
time that's right and by the way I want
you to do more but I didn't want to
scare you too much
Dubai
I'm not kidding 25 to 60 times a day
what does that mean that's arbitrary
numbers I could have said 20 to 100 I
could have said 80 to 150 as much as
humanly
possible I didn't say you have to come
up with 25 to 60 ideas a
day I said you have to make 25 to 60
pieces of content a
day when you make an Instagram story
maybe you save it and you go to Twitter
and you post and you write a couple of
extra lines and now you've made two
pieces of content from one video maybe
you take that video and post it on
YouTube and write three lines of
sentence now it's a third maybe you take
a still shot and then draw over it and
it's your snap and now you're on
fourat 25 across all platforms right I
want you to be on every platform all of
them all of them they go up they go down
they go up they go down but people don't
go on platforms cuz they don't have a
lot of followers on it and they feel
insecure so you stay on Instagram
because that's where you have 7,000
followers you don't want to go on
Twitter or Facebook or YouTube cuz you
only have 15 subscribers there and you
feel like you feel
sad the person in this room who decides
to stop listening to everybody else is
the person that's going to win this room
today
right you
understand so that's it you know I hate
when people call me a motivational
speaker if you look at my content from
2011 12 13 I tried to do nothing rah rah
or high up because I didn't want that
after I wrote crushit I'm a businessman
I'm a strategist I'm an Executor I'm an
executive but over the last three years
I had to look myself in the mirror and
say I'm doing what I tell people not to
do because I don't want to be a
motivational speaker and that's how
people see me sometimes I'm not giving
away the best information I can give I
was being selfish so over the last three
years I've gone into these subject
matters if you thought that I was ever
going to talk I never thought I was
going to talk about
parents or
self-esteem or entitlement if you
thought I thought 5 years ago that I
would ever make a video that goes like
this and here's this is for everybody if
you're 22 years old or older and your
parents give you money you're in bad
shape it's you know what's funny I'm not
I don't feel like you're a loser I feel
like you're in trouble mentally because
what is happening is you're getting more
insecure not
less you're getting resentful of your
parents and I promise you your parents
are resenting
you I never thought I was going to make
that
content but that's the content that I
watch for when I see people take photos
and by the way Dubai is a disaster in
this when I click on Dubai every photo
is private jets and Louis Vuitton and
Rolex watches I take a throw up on
Dubai all I see I don't see people that
genuinely enjoy the craftsmanship of a
Lou Vuitton bag or the fact that it's a
good shape for their day-to-day life I
see people that are so insecure that
they want to show other people that
they're doing well and they use the logo
to make themselves feel
good and for anybody who's in the crowd
who doesn't know me or is confused right
now I do not come to this amazing place
to Raz on people are hurt feelings I'm
here trying to
help this is the conversation that we
need across the world good news Dubai
the same things happening in New York
and la and London and Sydney and
everywhere else in the world that has a
little bit of money in the
system we as a society have to change
the
conversation no longer is it acceptable
in my opinion for Humanity to put money
on a
pedestal
now money's fine I don't want to
demonize money go wi but we have to put
happiness on a
pedestal we have to do you know how many
millionaires I know that are miserable
almost all of
them we have to change this conversation
let me tell you why it's not
sustainable people want to blame suicide
and all the gun violence and all the bad
stuff on social media let me tell you
guys something there is no social media
social media is empty we fill it we're
social media social media is not making
you bad you're bad social media is
exposing us it's not changing
us you're in control not the phone not
Instagram you and if you want to get rid
of the phone good and if you want to
limit your time on Instagram good and if
you want to stop looking at the likes
and post what you actually want ex or
instead of exposing your body for more
likes good you're in control not them
stop blaming the machine start blaming
yourself my friends I can see it in your
Collective faces you know I'm right I
know I'm right we all know it's right my
question is what are you going to do
about it do you have the courage to take
the way you're feeling right now and
leave and go make a post without the
perfect lighting with no makeup without
the right angle and actually talk the
truth do you have that courage because I
promise you you will be much happier as
a human being if you start doing it
much enough with filters and angles and
glow
lights enough with guys buying fake
watches and suits
you're tricking no one
dick tricking no
one you're tricking no
one this is a Warfare of Happiness
versus perceived
happiness my friends this is a Warfare
of Happiness versus perceived happiness
this is the greatest generation of
perceived happy people are going to go
on vacation this holiday season just for
the Instagram photo to send back for
everybody to see gonna go on a vacation
they can't
afford to make it look like they're
successful who else is tired of this
[__] we need to flip the world we
need to flip
this both work like again it's very
important you hear this I'm a bus
businessman I'm trying to build huge
businesses but I like the process of
building it not what it can buy me
almost every fake entrepreneur in here
wants to start a business to sell it to
buy
something that's why you're not going to
build it my friends if you're building a
business right now and thinking about
how quickly you can sell it I can
promise you you already
lost and this is all happening while the
economy is
phenomenal this has been over the last
10 years when everything's easy this is
the easiest time how many people here
are entrepreneurs or startup Founders
raise your
hands if you're one of those people and
your business is not crushing it during
this time you
suck and that's okay I suck at a lot of
things I as a friend if you just raised
your hand and you've been doing it for 3
years and it's not annihilating it right
now during the easiest time in the
history to build a
business you need to really go home and
look yourself in the
mirror because let me remind you being
the number two or the number four or the
number eight at Tesla or Facebook or
Instagram made a lot more money than the
number one of your [__]
startup this is about
self-awareness do you know
yourself this is about finally having
the conversation that you need to have
and you need to tell your mother or
father you're done living your life
based on what they
want it's time for you to tell your
spouse sister brother husband that
you're done living your life for them
hardest conversation I do not stand up
here and say that so easily I just know
it's true I don't think it's easy I
don't think I don't think anybody's
picking up the phone call and be like
hey Mom screw you it's hard I got it I
know it's hard but my friends this
starts at an early
age do you know how everything I just
talked about it's called high school and
you're still in
it we have to get out we have to get out
so that mindset is why you're not
posting I'm not I'm posting so much cuz
I'm not scared of what you're going to
say
I'm posting so much CU I'm not scared if
it's not going to hit the same metrics
as last
time I'm posting because I have
something to say I'm posting because I
want to talk I'm posting because I love
people and want to
interact but the majority is
not people who say things like but I
don't know what to post are already
stuck in the Judgment of the
post period end of story the entire
opportunity in your life is writing
words making pictures and making videos
for 10 websites on your phone at the
biggest scale that you can it's
happening right now this is the greatest
land grab of attention in the history of
mankind I have nothing else to say
that's there's no system I have no
products I have nothing else to say that
go do
it that's it dude you're going the wrong
way
you were first to move and now you're
like 11th in line it's over there and
over there you're dealing with is you've
got something you want to do practically
for your priority but you want something
for yourself and the way to do that is
to actually do that for yourself you're
just going to have to put in two hours a
day at first CU you don't have the
luxury to put in
15 but if you nail those two hours and
by the way my first book was just this
and I have thousands and tens of
thousands of stories of people for 4
years doing it for 1 hour after work and
then finally something clicked and they
were able to make the switch this just
requires one very difficult thing
patience that's it brother and that's
your weakness it's it kills me I know I
I respect that I've seen videos of you
you say it's not about what we do from 9
to 500 it's about what we do from 5 to 9
and I admire that and that little
sentence has has got me very far it's
developed amazing and things from that
but the patience thing is killing bro
but let me tell you why I'm tricky let
me tell you why I'm tricky I just
realized this very recently I'm like oh
right I'm saying a lot of things I
didn't realize you had to do all of them
it's like cooking a meal you might be
good at the at the hustle part you might
be good at understanding people you
might be good at giving you might be
good at taking care of people but if
you're bad at patience the whole thing
Falls if you're great at patience but
you don't have the work ethic it falls
if you're great at patience and the work
ethic but you treat people bad it falls
I'm like oh right this is why it's
challenging you need to get all 16
ingredients right to make this actually
work and the patience for the ambitious
is the hardest do you know how ambitious
I am if I didn't have patience I was in
a liquor store at 27 years old ringing
up my friends at the register I had a
patience my priority was my parents too
I wanted to build them a humongous
business for how they parented me I left
that business at 34 years old I didn't
have any money I started Vayner media in
a conference room in another company cuz
I didn't have enough money to pay for
rent I was patient and I'm 44 and I
haven't even started bro you got time
how old are you 27 I'm
done I'm out next I'm out I'm out
yes G yes first I just want to say thank
you um 3 years ago I quit my 95 job I
had 3,000 Jance in my bank account and
when I made that decision to quit my job
it was a lot of it because I was
consuming your content so I have a lot
to say um thank you because I quit my
job and now I have my own business it's
only been 3 years but it's financially
healthy I am so happy so the first thing
I just want to say is thank you you mean
the world to me more than
[Applause]
you by the way by the way I'm I'm sorry
to apologize there's a lot of people
thinking right now let me let me tell
you something that is very real it's not
for everybody but there is a very big
percentage of people in here that that
admiration is way more interesting than
making $100,000
today
and if you're lucky that your DNA is
similar to mine it's about providing
value with no
expectation none love you I love you too
people people say to me Gary you're
wrong I give all the time and I get
walked all over I go no you don't you're
not giving you're manipulating because
you're fith giving and you want
something in return giving is only when
you expect nothing in
return I don't want your 7day trial but
then you sell me I don't want your free
course and then it actually is trying to
sell me giving is giving
period
okay so yeah so I just want to First say
a huge thank you I love you so much you
are still playing such a huge part on
how I'm running my business all of your
advice content the Practical advice that
you give I I really my business would
not be where it's at and it's only 3
years but it's financially healthy I'm
so happy and I work my ass off in Dubai
is really hard I'm self-funded I'm
independent it's just me so what can I
answer for you okay uh it's been 3 years
I run my business here in Dubai yes and
it's getting to a point where I just
feel that Dubai doesn't really have the
infrastructure that for or an
entrepreneur like me um that's it's
expensive basically it's expensive what
kind of business is it social media
marketing keep going pretty much help
people build their own businesses ins
side hustles and it's just the expensive
of running the business here in Dubai
now that it's getting to 3 years I just
feel that it's just weighing me down and
it's not making me feel happy anymore so
move and and so my question then is I
know cuz I knew you would say that Alex
would just move but then what happened
happens when all of my businesses a lot
of like 80% of my businesses here save
money save money yeah move and do it
again you said the most important part
Alex you said you're not
happy yeah and I'm not I I don't you
were not happy in your job you quit it
you made yourself happy now you're 3
years in and you're not happy so move
the good news for you is unlike for a
lot of people here you've already taken
a jump
once do it
again and I'm happy here when I'm with
my clients doing what I love I don't
care that's a micro happy you're macro
unhappy Alex you need to move yeah see
you
duby thank you you're
welcome you look great I didn't know
after 30 what I do you always said 30 is
the a to start and this not working zero
that I I feel that this I haven't done
anything yet but on the on the other
side of the country that I've done a few
other a lot of businesses whenever I
reach a point that I know I can make it
okay I just leave that thing and I move
on to another challenge to myself that's
good right but uh the patience thing is
still there that's not a problem I do a
day job 9 5 is the age 30 freaking you
out uh I mean it's just it's just I want
to know how would it start off at 30 the
process that's the thing I've not bro 30
means nothing right so I think 30 is
bothering you yeah that's the thing I
think let me save you time 30 means
nothing all right and just another thing
on the uh just wanted to know like uh
I've been on many all of these uh
platforms talk about uh it's just that
I've read that Medium is the message
rather than the message you give out of
course right so I just want to know your
two sents on what do you feel about the
medium itself I believe in context for
the medium but the message is the
message right to medium is the message
or the message the
medium
both but look
look you you you consume my content
where all over different plac you've
answered your
question right got it yeah thank you you
got it thank you so
much in the living room we were trying
to make your parents were conservative
no I'm kidding I'm kidding go
ahead so that digital marketing saved my
life okay okay in 2017 I decided to give
back to the world so I created the
biggest movement of digital
entrepreneurs in Italy okay with
thousands of people and they even make
it stronger with a movement called all
inners with people that go all in and
want to make it a game okay so now I'm
like you I created content every day I
uh like eat every platform I have a team
editing the content making it for every
platform but I would like to have my
message go out there more organically
because even if I know the algorithm of
you do maybe like I know a little bit I
know how to write keywords you know
content I'm a marketer I feel I'm going
too slow I want to impact more people
and I started in Italy because I'm
Italian I got it then I speak other two
languages to impact the world okay so
how will you help like give me an ad
advice faster and two things the
quickest way to not grow faster is to
want to grow
faster let me tell you why what worked
for you was something that mattered and
it caught fire now that you want to grow
faster you're trying to hack strategies
to make you grow faster in numbers the
message is getting
diluted yeah because maybe I'm getting
tired on creating too many too much
content the reality is that I'm getting
tired on you know bombarding the social
it's not that it's that you're North
Star is to grow in
numbers not to be thoughtful to come up
with new things to
say so what's what's your advice for you
my advice is stop trying to grow
faster so take take my time and and say
things that matter yeah without filter
correct in your face that's right that's
what I we got it we got
it so uh I currently run two businesses
in the US and can Canada however here in
the UAE I don't think anyone really
collect knows yeah okay so I've been
trying to uh talk to my friends and send
some companies about it and educate them
about it however uh I'm not really
successful in building a community for
the niche how long have you tried to
build the community for the niche um
like two months
okay you know where I'm going
right I mean first of all you've got to
obviously look at proper football cards
for this Niche right there's a much
better chance like maybe basketball
definitely not football or baseball like
this is going to be a a football Market
a proper football Market it will happen
here if it continues to go the way it's
going because people are making a
fortune on it and a lot of people when
they get educated that they can make
more money in sports cards than they can
in cryptocurrency and cannabis will run
towards your game you just need to stay
patient you just told me that you're
struggling after trying to do something
for 8 weeks
you got it you're welcome you want to
win life you want to live a 1% life of
being a millionaire and doing anything
you want and being happy don't you think
that should be hard and should take a
long
time hey Gary how are you good how are
you super uh and uh all the I don't know
what you call like drilling ideas it's
just been crazy I've been working on it
for for
long and another thing I want to say the
180 Cent yes R it works so everybody go
for it I've been doing it for three four
weeks now uh I've noticed uh not only
growth
but that I can give some ideas I'm into
calisthenics so I went through
and sometimes I just say a great workout
or something like that but uh at another
time so I'm giving deep really good
advises not to do handstand or something
like that the 180 strategy if you Google
Gary V 180 strategy is the idea of leave
there's a saying leave your what's your
two cents on this idea 90 times a day on
Instagram you go to other people's
accounts in the things that you're
interested in look at their content and
leave a comment that's meaningful not
like like them with the hope they like
you back follow unfollow all the
[__] no no meaningful comments and
then you start building meaningful
relationships so uh before I get into my
question uh I'm into making funny videos
as well okay and I have this com
combination of uh calisthenic Sports and
funny videos and it goes to many topics
like even parenting okay uh I've done uh
funny videos about sports and stuff and
funny videos about
uh friends it goes to many uh topics and
I've done some uh videos for companies
I've been trying to yep uh I'm in U
negotiation with a company similar to
Best Buy in the
states and I made three videos for you I
wish that you can uh I already dm' you
in Instagram dck and team Gary ve uh I
showed you two videos I made them really
quick cuz I was coming here and shitty
so I can remake them okay fine and the
third scenario I haven't made it yet but
it's written and I just want to I can't
wait to see it send it want your advice
or I'll take a look I will so my
question is how uh can you go into the
state of not judging yourself Practice
still keep going CU I've had it one for
like a month and a half practice I've
been focusing in calisthenics and videos
I went silence in here practice but then
it's it was gone practice
you got to practice you got to read the
comment and play with it you suck you're
not funny read it read it read it now
here's where it gets good if you read
the comment from somebody saying you
suck or you know or if you're are you
judging yourself or you getting or you
struggling with the Judgment of others
somebody saying it's stupid idea that
you're doing this or a comment that's
bad I mean I didn't get anybody is uh
saying is stupid a lot of people liking
it but for me like continuing the work I
for this half month and a half uh month
that I've been talking about I went
through like uh putting my workouts
putting videos putting funny and you
burnt out huh are you burnt out you
don't want to do it anymore no it's just
I for some reason I slacked and I didn't
do anything I had this conversation with
somebody and just went out and
why I don't know what do you think I've
been thinking of uh maybe the
combination of two is not good sometimes
and it's slowing me down and I'm not
putting as much content as I want what
do you think of the combination like
putting Sports and good advices good
videos good everything is
good I think you might be impatient
because you went so hard for a month and
a half and the numbers didn't get too as
high as you want them by going too hard
for a month and a half
and an opinion is persective right
because the reason you're asking
yourself is this a good combo is you
didn't see the results that you expected
let me promise you one way that you can
consistently make yourself
unhappy having
expectations I'm going to move thank you
brother we got the microphone up I love
it let's do it we got up the top who has
the microphone up the top please stop
waving and ask your question thank you
love it go
ahead hold on one second it's not
working keep talking
though nope still
no there go thank you thank you Gary
than you appreciate this uh my name is n
I'm the founder of global woman and I
work a lot with women entrepreneurs and
most of them who come to the club they
never have done video live in their life
okay and the issue here is that they
really like their private life but they
still want to be successful in business
what would be your advice for all women
who are watching this video now how can
they get that confidence to break that
fear to take the the phone and make a
liveing social media there was something
you said that I didn't fully hear you
were you saying that there scared to do
it because they want privacy
yeah they go they go together very
easily I'm the most public private
person on
Earth you guys know nothing about my
family I post
z.0 about my family you look them in the
face and tell them you don't have to
post about your
family
and what would be your advice for them
right now to
post
awesome what if they have another work
to do what's that what if they have
another work to do and they they need
money so they're working for something
and they're getting money out of it okay
and they have a side side thing that
they love okay and which is
post it's just balance it's just time
management it's also what's the
alternative
people come to me all the time and they
say well Gary I'm Str I can't balance my
my care my job that I have to do and my
side coaching or whatever I'm like okay
then
don't but but they love both then do
both's living then do
both it's hard of course it's hard
everything's [__] hard love you man I
love you too go
ahead
hi all right I'm going to go over here
oh go ahead go ahead you're good hi my
name is Kai hi um uh first of all I just
want to say thank you for living your
truth and just speaking it to everyone
and inspiring us all thank you I'm a
musician from the UK and I kind of fell
into a business here in Dubai called the
bike club and we promote restaurants uh
since doing the bike club we do about
six events a week and so I'm meeting 100
something
to people daily weekly and I found that
I've got lots of good ideas and I'm
trying to catch up with the people that
I meet um and I've also realized that
I'm a connector love but in all the
platforms and all the people I meet all
the ideas and all the stories I don't
know if there's a platform that you can
possibly recommend uh to schedule or to
help curate ideas and content because
you know as an entrepreneur or a small
team um it's great to create the content
um but actually get edited and you know
cut down and everything like even today
I've taken load of videos but once it's
edited where do you start to turn out
the 25 that you recommend a day where do
you post it no like do you recommend
like plan or whole Suite or any
scheduling apps to help become a team
while you're build a team no I think you
should open Twitter and post the
photo let me tell you H where everybody
screws up people look for
efficiencies where what's needed is
context my friends let me promise you
how not to do social media if you post
the same exact photo with the same exact
word to all 10 of the prominent
platforms they won't act the same way
you have to write the copy and you have
to edit the content for the
psychological nature and the utilitarian
nature of the platform for the for the
31 minutes you save by hitting one
button and blast in it out you're
wasting actual
growth so you would recommend cuz I'm
learning to be still also and just take
time to balance so let's say it was 1
hour a day sit and post sure okay yep
Whatever Gets you to post you I post my
content do you know how busy I am I post
it I write it I reply to you every reply
you ever got ever from Gary ve is me not
an
intern
me that that's why I have a team Gary ve
account and other accounts in case we
want to engage where I'm not but if it's
me it's me if I have time you have time
Kai thank you you're
welcome I've gotten old thank you so
much honestly that means a lot right
like think about it 10 years talk about
like you know but go ahead thank you
yeah more than to years yeah so I think
you very special and I love you and I
think if you more people listen to you
the world will be better place that's
the
plan and you're like a motivational
speaker but very very cool one okay
thank you okay so this is about my love
to you and you always say about giving
so I want I want to give you my present
okay H present to you it's my business
and if you even like look at it after
whenever you time come bring
it yes
okay she's
[Applause]
running can I you can thank you yeah
give me hug wow this is
like you you're welcome another
question so
basically uh this product is offline
right
offline I mean you not cuz you started
with wine but anyways the is it's
difficult you know to get investment cuz
everyone loves to talk about online now
no it's not millions of people are
getting investment
offline okay cuz it's a vision boards
and whenever I go investor so basically
how many investors have you gone to tell
me the truth or I'll get mad about 12
and they all saying oh if you do online
version that's 12 but everyone wants on
my vision but no no you're saying
everyone you're talking about 12
people
okay they took about hundreds and I have
to go to hundreds maybe thousands maybe
thousands and maybe you should go to
people maybe you should do a little
research on Google for people that
invest in things that aren't online
businesses but can I have your exact
opinion sorry this is Vision Bo I love
it but do you really love it do you just
say to I really love
it vision board
self but it doesn't exist I created it
nobody sells vision boards people sell
vision boards nobody sells Vision Bo go
to Pinterest people sell vision boards
no it's vision board kits right people
sell vision board kits it's not like
that have yours might be your might be
better they sell
all I'm sure I love it you're
welcome hi Gary hi my name is Mara and
I'm a first time business owner awesome
um actually I worked for about 10 years
in the corporate world I work a lot of
glass ceilings around the world good for
you um especially as a mom I love it
let's clap it up for
[Applause]
[Music]
her I wanted more and um so I started my
own business and now I feel that I'm
stuck I love the process the money is
fine because uh I worked really hard um
and the business is fine it's not making
a ton of money but it's making enough
for me to continue with the process and
I want to continue but I feel that the
growth is slowing down are you
micromanaging what's that are you
micromanaging um I try to do that less
and less but I feel that where I'm stuck
is in my training in my learning you
yourself yes that's awesome yeah well
that's good that's the most solvable
part of it all how well there's
something called the internet and on the
internet there's a website called Google
and YouTube and you can literally type
in anything that you think you're stuck
with and then somebody will give you
content for free I got yes it's I
definitely I'm always there but I find
it so overwhelming I feel that you know
I know I identify that I don't have
mentors okay okay um so that's one thing
but I am at loss and overwhelmed at the
amount of information and my business is
running and it's going I'm involved so
you what are you most unhappy
about um that it's not growing more no
not the business I feel that I I can
still give more and I can still learn
more I'm so hungry to learn more but I
feel like sometimes people are patient
like 8 weeks 15-year-old who I love you
know and some sometimes they're
impatient for everybody in Dubai to
collect football cards sometimes people
are impatient for their side hustle to
get big enough so they leave sometimes
people are impatient for quenching their
thirst for
learning but when you were stuck have
you ever felt stuck nope really really
you know why cuz I don't judge
myself situation where you just don't
know what to do every day right so what
do you do when that happens I make it up
and pick
one I love losing I love going through
the process I learn that way every day I
have a situation the reason I'm good at
business now is I've done so much I have
such pattern recognition I can do this
but other things happen to me all the
time right like every day I pick
something and if it goes well I'm like I
knew it I pick something it goes poorly
it was drock's fault I'm kidding I'm
kidding I take that loss and I keep
evolving you might also not be stuck you
might have decided you're
stuck thank you so much you're
[Applause]
welcome see I was
wrong still it's still not working
okay yeah this just wants to shout out
his Instagram tag CU he forgot to
earlier no problem uh yeah Gary I forgot
to tell you the name can you go fast
you're long-winded grownup child that's
my grownup child got
you just a quick question on Tik Tok I
know you've been shouting out about it
recently where do you see it going in
the next three to 5 years confused cuz
at the moment obviously it's like
dancing videos and yeah like in
started as filters and obviously I'm
just wondering
like I have no I'm not Nostradamus okay
yeah what I know is 1.5 billion people
are on it right now okay so you're just
saying go with it keep going with it and
see what happens what what's what's the
alternative what's the
downside people value their time when
it's not
valuable of course go with
it
brilliant thank you very
much I am pro calistenics athlete as
well cheers to the from the other side
uh actually I used to work as a camping
crew almost for 40 years but actually I
liked it only for few month and then I
decided to start yeah after 4 years I
left because I loveed ganics I loved the
uh the way how training is going with me
every think and then almost like uh 10
month ago uh I started uh just like uh
searching how do I start on social media
okay yeah and then for now I'm just like
posting normally on Instagram uh and
that's it but how many times a
day story you can say like not story not
story you can say two three times per
week yeah
but I just so basically I started I just
like bought my domain and I'm starting
my website soon and uh I literally like
two to three days ago I I made all the
accounts on almost all the platforms
good uh now I want to ask you something
actually I have a I have a problem which
is like if I don't have a plan let's say
if I want to go to Everest if I don't
have a map I cannot go to to the top
that's bad yeah that's why I take too
much time to plan my thing
with that's the game why because I feel
like if I don't know the way how how I
would reach to the top yeah listen this
is why a lot of people are not
entrepreneurs your framework is an
incredible number four
executive I need you to work for me it's
unlikely that you'll build anything
successful with that much fear of the
unknown
so one of two things yes start
practicing mhm on doing things without a
map okay or put the map down and go
follow somebody
else you understand that's your only two
options got it and there is listen to me
listen to me there is nothing wrong with
following somebody else there's nothing
wrong with being a number two three four
this whole generation that everybody has
to be a founder and CEO and entrepreneur
is
ludicrous it's ludicrous in the same way
that everybody should have been good and
went to college 20 years ago it's
ludicrous so if you want it so bad
ideologically you got to start going
into the forest without a map you got to
try if you're incapable you're going to
have to take a step back and say I'm
going to follow somebody else thank you
thank you very much G all right they're
pulling me off I'm so sorry I love you
du byai please oh my God please Gary
I've been cling you for 5 years please
iiz this I can't believe you're in front
of me my vision board I beg you you'll
never believe this they just told me had
you been following me for 6 years I
could have asked you now go ahead go
ahead go
ahead go you were very loud
before
it's still not on there you go go okay
firstly I just want to say I have
visualized this moment for so long for
the last four or five years I think
you're unbelievable because of you I
have got so much more gratitude in my
life and I can't thank you enough for
that honestly so this is a really big
moment for me and I'm fighting for it
and I really appreciate you and I want
to say that I want to hug you after I
talk to you just one hug two seconds
please done thank you okay I love you I
mooved when I was okay here we go don't
worry don't wor I'm staying you're not
going to lose me now don't worry I'm
waiting you got me there we go I moved
to ababi when I was 20 I'm now 28 I'm a
teacher here okay I have a side business
that I'm building before you judge me
yes I'm a life coach I don't have
everything figured out I know I don't
I'm using my experience of being an
expat to hopefully help people in expat
in their life so you're not you're not a
life coach you're an expat coach which I
love keep going you know why cuz you're
actually an expat yes I am an expert and
I have found a niche where I really want
to help you I like that going where I
didn't have I'm looking inside for my
Niche right who do you think who do you
think Gary ve is I'm the person the
12-year-old me was looking for
yeah I understand I that from you
ins your
own y I'm kind of Tor in between right
now I am a teacher full-time I'm trying
to build Nova coach y that's my business
from XA teachers but also my energy has
now been taken away a little because I'm
obviously still teaching but I've been
now implementing a coaching program into
my school okay in Abu Dhabi around
building a culture of innovation and
Trust which is actually turning out to
be pretty unbelievable amazing and I'm
kind of toring between what do I do like
I know I need to leave teaching I'm
incredibly passionate person and I know
I meant to be doing something with
coaching or building culture ination and
Trust in schools great I I'm stuck I
don't know where to put my energy though
because like right now my content is a
bit stale online because I've been
pumping my energy into teaching and also
building this culture of innovation and
Trust in my school your actions are
speaking sorry my your no no your
actions my actions I your answer is what
you're
doing right now you're more passionate
about this culture thing because you've
now innovated and said wait a minute
maybe this is what I need to be doing
but I mean I'm extremely passionate
about the expat experience no [__] you
know
yeah you can tell if you heard my heart
beating now would be crazy sorry I'm
just so nervous I love that you're
passionate about that but your actions
are speeding about this yeah so see this
through yeah and see where it takes you
and produce content as much as I want on
my
platforms my dear my dear I'm so glad we
got your question in this is what
everybody does you're judging um myself
correct yeah do 6 months of of this
thing and if it doesn't feel good
anymore start doing more expat because
I'm getting a good response from the
school and from the teachers around
creating Innovation a culture of
innovation and Trust because the buzz
word right now is innovation but people
are afraid to take risks so we need to
create trust in schools
yep I don't know I don't know why you're
judging yourself for not finishing the
xack thing when this thing came see that
through okay I know you like it I so
should I change my content online yes to
culture of innovation and Trust yep I
don't know if you heard this okay but
for 7 years I only put out content about
wine do you remember that part but do I
I feel disloyal followers yeah do you
remember that part of my story yeah yeah
so that's the answer okay so it's okay
to change it's okay I got good news for
you evolve everything's okay okay okay
thank you come on all right goodbye
thank you so
much thank
you
Hest get get
off
all right all right fast fast fast fast
fast I'll get to India I'm getting there
it's almost done I will I'm looking at
you Tony Tony I got you
[Applause]
Tony bro I'm not going to be I'm not
going to be able to pull it off I'm
sorry I'm just
not thank you I'm willing to work for
free for you man I'm willing to work for
free for you thank you bro email me
email me email me that
picture that's [__] amazing bro I'm
taking that that I'm
taking thank you Dubai thank you a see
guys thank you okay let's keep
going if you
are ISO sir how are you I love you so
much you're my biggest inspiration thank
you brother thank you so much great we
have a couple we're walking to the meet
and
GRE yeah I'm looking forward to it can I
get a photo yeah yeah
yeah thank you real looking forward to
to know you better yeah yeah absolutely
I need these three boys with the with
the books how are you these are your
Arabic Gary ve fans I love it and they
won tickets soy and they competed in a
competition to be here I'm so glad you
won he came from aan which is one of the
Emirates and he came from R how are you
such a pleasure and so they each get a
picture with you let's do yeah let's do
a picture let's do one BM yeah
ready
bo
bo okay this is
tala came last year she's been following
you for years she actually came to New
York and I went to your offices but you
weren't in such a pleasure and last year
she waited a long time to see you but sh
was crazy
yeah this is amazing in the front row I
saw her I saw
her ready oh this this
side how
um can I take one
more tell them what you're doing with
music man it's fine I don't want to take
up your time thank you for coming tell
me tell me thank you no I just I I
should I should come I was I met Justin
in New York I think the next time I'll
come I'll try to arrange it hit up
Justin right now show him the picture
and tell him I said so he'll come to me
and he'll say is this true I'll say yes
and we'll get some time than
you inspirational thank
you Gary yes sir uh real quick with CNBC
so what goes through your mind after you
what goes through your mind after you
get off stage um like right now what's
going through your mind I usually
critique you know subjectively it's
always good you know and what I mean by
that is it isn't always good some days
are just sharper than others I try to
think about I think I listen I try to
think about what really just hit put it
in my head one more time I felt it up
there but then I think one more time and
then honestly then I get off stage and
this usually happens that I'm just like
super focused on actually focusing on
the people that are here because you
know yeah be present yeah like what what
you know what I have I have great
visualization the fact that I can
visualize us sitting in that booth in
asah like that's my strength that's my
strength yeah and um so but you can't do
that unless you actually pay attention
yeah absolutely so recap and then pay
attention to the 4C interactions with
people you know I'm so grateful and so
in tune with the 4C interaction I had
with a Jets football player or at a
baseball card show the fact that I'm on
the other side now you know it's intense
amazing awesome great let me just get
the uh photo out of the
way and then can you just last one that
we're going to walk can I have a you can
I'll be right
there
[Music]
awesome thanks man you're welome it's
great to see you thank you so
much thank you you're
welcome Gary you tell him who you are so
uh what are we doing we're building the
next home run mobile app we're currently
one of the global immersive apps that
teleports people in time so we have a a
Outsource teleporters reporters that
report in 360 top events behind the
scenes we already went to Hollywood Will
Smith was on our app many top
celebrities we went 6X growth in
revenues in one year we reached 14
million screen views this year versus 1
million last year congratulations
valuation from 3 million to 20 million
one year uh a premium subscription model
I'm just putting them down so I don't
forget anything and then uh 1,000 new
paid subscribers per day that are paying
$8 per day this this is our growth uh we
have we're aiming now at 30X growth I
want to grow globally from here we have
investors like CS saris if you know them
two VCS from the US BCS from here the
Kim founder is in they all invested in
us and we want to build the business
globally and I believe together and I
told M before we the right Partners to
take this globally because we're into
sports behind the scenes interviews and
I want to part of you you part of advis
let's have a meaningful meeting I want
to look at it all right she'll set it up
okay let's walk we
pleasure how are you thank you can you
please can you
please thank you so much just do
I'll get it Gary and then I have a
question we we're going to have to walk
though yep let's walk so Gary I want to
know I'm a very conservative person I
never put any video picture of myself
public but on my personal account I'm
very active daily I put so many things
on everything and I'm meter and ANP
coach so how I get this of me okay you
know
what area is that okay all right I'm so
sorry I never do that yeah it's like
kissing a boy it's like swimming it's
like having sex when from a conserv
totally understand but that's the game
did you do you swim do you swim yeah
yeah yeah you were scared of swimming
before you swam yeah that's actually the
answer so I just do it jump in the
water that's the that's it you're
welcome thank
you thank you very much okay can
everyone
just okay
here I'm very about digital marketing I
work in a very big company Commerce
company company I really like the
marketing but I felt that I lost the
energy I I was always like learning a
lot every day but now I feel I lost the
energy to learn or even to do stuff good
I didn't lose the passion but I lost the
energy how to take it up how to work
myself again well maybe maybe it's not
as interesting to you anymore it's
interesed I love it but what's the real
answer why aren't you doing it so I feel
after work I need to like just uh sit
down and watch movies so maybe the job
you're having is draining you too much
maybe you don't like it as much as you
think it was one of my dreams really I
worked very hard to my friend a lot of
people have dreams and then get there
and realize what they had a dream for
isn't what they want
mhm but I L like the dist marting so is
there anything that I can do it to get
up my energy learn again work hard no
because that's a mental thing mhm if you
need the rest after work you need the
rest so what is your advice to move one
to keep grinding to keep grinding see if
it comes back and then after a couple
years of this you may want to change
careers
completely okay thank you so much you're
welcome G just Meg and then we're going
to go to no thank
you such a pleasure yeah thank you so
much
than check your I will
Ora thank you sir real
pleasure
oh from so nice to meet you thank
you thank you thank you very much for
all the advice thank you for saying that
thank
you how are you great pleasure thank you
my friend
awesome very much take
care how are you to meet you nice to
meet you big fan I hope you
enjoyed thank you thank you I love it
good
[__] Bro man pleasure buight the Jets
get let them win the Super Bowl I'm a
fast fan though you won too many
yeah how are you real pleasure
yeah thank you take care of
yourself what's up Gary how are you how
are you pleasure to see you pleasure
me thank you so much man thank you for
coming sorry s how are you my God I love
you man I love you back
bro thank you for coming to bro I will
I'm working on it how are you good to
see
you thank you for coming thank you
yeah how are you such a pleasure he came
especially for you he's the youngest one
in the audience 17 years old he loves
you thank you brother thank
you thank you for coming thank you all
the best thank all the best to
you hey man hey I know you get this a
lot but thanks thanks a lot man happy to
doia man so nice to meet you nice to
meet you as well take care yourself take
care stay take care
bye-bye thank you bro thank you Nice
Kicks
yeah thank you thanks for coming see you
Neil I can't wait hi Gary how are you
I'm pantea I'm the success resources
partner from Iran I brought 100 people
from to your
event you were so great in the audience
you were shaking your heads at the right
stuff I saw you thank you for that
information continue this what you doing
I had a doubt I had a doubt because it's
not a money making in Iran bringing
people because of our currency but I
realized that I have to do it for hi Hi
how are you project manager of her how
are you nice to meet you
thank you nice to meet you thank you so
much hope everything goes well at home
thank you thank you yeah hi how are you
so nice to meet you thank
you thank you so much thank you thank
you can you wear wear it yeah of course
happy to do
it oh
man thank you come through will I will
thank you so much
how are you such a pleasure you much
thank you my
friend thank you for coming take
care Hi how are you I love you man I
love you back but in life in life you're
much better than the social media man
thank you for saying that I don't mean
any but in life you so thank you brother
how are you good to see
you thank you my friend take care thank
you how are you nice to meet you hold of
course oh yeah all
right thank you my friend take care
thank you thank you how are you thank
you thank you s on happiness thank you
yes somebody has to yeah you know yeah
thanks so thank
you how are you thank
you hey har how are you good
morning thank you so much morning
motivation thank you
thank
you real pleasure pleasure thank you my
friend you have had
a tall fan yes I'm had tall fan thank
you brother how are you such a big fan
thank you brother thank you so than
you thank you so much apprciate
it hi Hi how are you I'm good good I
have been reciting this for [__] 2
weeks
thank I'm from Wisconsin my parents are
first generation from the [__]
jungles I've had my for 3 years and this
year the state of Wisconsin awarded me I
love and I found you on the website that
um the state that that awarded me this
and I found you there your confirmation
that everything I'm [__] doing is
[__] right I love it I love
it I'm so glad we met you're welcome
was great real pleasure thank you thanks
for enjoying
it awesome take care of
yourself thank brother are you changing
my life thank you for saying
that no you did not just saying it thank
you I appreciate it bro looking good so
nice to meet you nice to meet you bro
real pleasure
awesome thanks for coming through
awesome hope you enjoyed today loved it
thank you I thank my sister for
introducing me to you my wife for buying
me the ticket to come and see you the
ladies are coming through awesome yeah I
love your voice for changing the
educational system thank you brother
that means a lot to me thank you
brother and I know we're not supposed to
do this but can I take a selfie yeah
real fast come come over here and I'll
sneak it in okay app you got
it how are you such a pleasure you so
much thank you
brother thank
you
hello how are you such a pleasure thank
you thank you for coming thank you I am
from
Kurdistan that's very
nice I want to meet you again thank you
I hope so bye-bye Gary you are the most
authentic person that I've ever met
thank you my friend I never knew
somebody could be such a famous person
like you be so authentic thank you for
saying that thank
you my thank you I have one one one very
quick question you know all this
pressure and everybody's asking question
and everybody's asking you questions and
everything you know when you go home yes
wait what do you do like like you have
think down bad I feel bad for them for
for us because because we don't know
what to do that's right thanks hi G such
a pleasure nice to meet you so glad
how's everything very good my friend I
hope you enjoyed it so nice I love you
thank you brother so
take brother
that's sure you man I really love you
you changed my life thank you changed my
life
yep I love it Chang my life see you in
birmingam next year I can't wait I can't
wait how are you how are you so nice to
meet
you thank you see you Hi how are you so
nice to meet you pleasure thank you um
may I ask a question or yes go ahead
okay um my social media is very active
I'm not getting enough clients what's
wrong are you how many are you asking a
lot of clients um I'm creating lots of
valuable are you reaching out to people
to pay to get clients no you're waiting
for it to come to you yes start reaching
out okay thank you so much you got it
you got to ask and and getting a lot of
nose is okay yes thank actually I'm up
again but the reason is cuz I wanted to
say what you do for social media adds a
lot of value to uh teenagers means a lot
thank you forit old old than that but it
adds a lot of value I appreciate it
thank you
hi awesome thank you hi hi Hi how are
you I'm thank you you're
welcome thank you for
coming thank you brother I want to ask
you something but I know you don't have
time but thanks a lot thanks a lot for
everything and I really thank thank you
so thank you so much Hi how are
you thank you take care Hi how are you
good thank you for coming thank
you Hi how are you to meet you such a
pleasure such a pleasure I already met
you one more time one more time one more
time okay oh she's in you in got
[Music]
it
all
right awesome thank you so
much so thank you brother appreciate
that you you're welcome so much hi is
interview
[Music]
him okay we got it thank thank
you sorry you're not supposed to do
that hey you're the best thank you
brother Hi how are you love your thank
you thank
you aw
than hello how are you so nice to meet
you
[Music]
thank you for coming take
care hi good to see you again thank you
sorry I'm also a sponsor for it I love
it awesome great to see you again good
keep going I'm only person who tce I
love
it pleas to meet you such a pleasure all
right look here please do that give it
to
there you go thank you brother real
pleasure okay look here
please right now thank you such a
pleasure thank you thank you me okay
you're going to do a quickview with her
we done um I'm running a 10 was that
your question so nice to meet you I love
your shirt so Gary next year Mela and I
are doing a 10, th000 women Summit in
Singapore I love it so uh first time
ever good for you so we want to ask you
if what is one message that you can give
it to help me to Rally 10,000 women come
to Singapore on one day uh on the 10
October 2020 what's the one thing so I
think you guys asked separate questions
what's the one thing I would say and
you're asking how do we make get it to
happen yeah a message for them and how
can you help us with a tip a $1 million
tip how can we convince 10,000 women
that is their day on the 10th of October
I think the number one thing I think
about is never convincing anybody of
anything so in a world where there's
probably 3.8 billion women I'm sure we
can find 10,000 that know it's their day
it's our job to communicate to Millions
so that 10,000 come not try to convince
40,000 as far as the message look I am
the byproduct of the greatest woman who
ever lived so when I tell you that I'm
convinced that even if they are not
proven by science to be women Tendencies
and like empathy and gratitude and
nurturing all those things are now the
superpowers of business not the other
stuff and I think that would be my
message which is what is naturally
inside of you is your strength you don't
have to cover it up in a boy's World
make it a girl's
World wow than you so I love your
keyword conversation conversation so
what is the key message conversation
that we can use as your your your key
tip that
communication that lacks friction will
always
win whether that friction is the
platforms whether that friction is is
the format written audio but the number
one friction is the communication that's
the truest always
wins wow thank you now I'm going to I'm
going to be very to help us to turn this
Vision come true would you be willing to
share just one post women of all over
the world please join this appr
appreciate this I have to see it send it
to me okay I never make a commitment cuz
I see no commit but I'm happy to very
much consider it send me the information
I appreciate thank you
welcome thank
you oh there is
okay no it's okay I'm here I'm
here important man he's a good
guy thank you thank you okay thank you I
got you you're welcome they trying to
throw me out just one
selfie oh that's cute thank you so
much I got you I got it it's
okay next time don't do that please all
right sorry I love Youk
you that's a great
message that friction always yes sir
pretty cool
right go remember the request I asked
you for
yeah one second one second one second
one second hi can I ask you for very Qui
request I'm doing content all about
kindness and and right now my video is
about uh the importance and the power of
using someone else's name because it
shows the appreciation respect and
recognition of someone so I'm trying to
get people just to say hi my name is
okay can I get your sure perfect and you
want me to say hi my name is Gary yeah
okay perfect
okay thank you so much okay you're
welcome can you get back
yeah 1 two three go hi my name is Gary B
neru you're
welcome question if I have investment
[__] I would like to share it with you
what's the Gary at Vayner media my email
okay thank you
sorry good luck Spen man I'm good
friends with r last one we got five
minutes of spener and then we're done
five
come on
D got waiting for him sorry I understand
B I really appreciate yeah I don't know
what an ambassador is so that could be
like I could be could be real trouble
for me you know you know don't don't
hurt me all right let's do
it ready to go ready to go should be
recording there we recording sound okay
test 1275
yeah ready okay Tik Tok L I've got to
Tik Tok about about 3 months ago my
daughter said to me dad that's my place
get off yeah and I'm on it now okay and
it's mad and it's crazy as you like and
I watched what you do and I'm like okay
I'll just do more of that kind of stuff
but then I get so sucked into the stuff
that hours it's very entertaining yeah
and and I'm just you know why cuz it's
happy yeah the world is putting out so
much content that is not happy Tik tok's
happy it's youth doing creative things
yeah that's why we're getting sucked in
it's happy they said to entainment too
isn't it that's right it sure is
entertaining yes it is sucked into it so
I I complet I've been following you for
the Last 5 Years got me the shoes man so
I'm have for that okay like so Raj's
like Mega with it okay so Mega with it
that you're going to have to sign my
shoe done okay I don't know where you
want to sign it I'll figure it out while
you're talking go ahead and uh and so
what I wanted to make sure that I did
was ah get
in um I I built a company it's just been
valued at $109
million and I'm I'm thinking about
selling it okay but I'm fearing of
purpose okay because I've done this
before I sold a company before a lot of
sold and I literally really killed
myself I understand because I was
miserable deeply miserable I understand
and so now I'm in this place where this
company is great and it should be sold
now it's the right time to sell it but
I'm scared about what my life's going to
be like and so do you have maybe at the
time you sold your first one you were
still insecure and you needed the money
to do bad behavior you might not do that
same bad behavior now you might I don't
know you
but it the money is not the
problem it's just not no it's not the
problem it's just it all that money does
is exposes the truth mhm so you have to
ask yourself who are you right now cuz I
promise you it's different than that guy
yeah and if you feel great about where
you're at and you can take those dollars
and do something purposeful with them
and I don't mean give it away I mean
build something else mhm but it's so
hard I think for me to to be creative I
I mean I suppose I just need to sell it
and then start again don't I to find
just try that's right yeah but it took
me a year at become very I went to a
very dark place for a year I so equ I
had all this money and it was like but
what should I do I'm going to do this
this this it'd be great and after a
month you didn't want to do those things
I don't want to do those things I don't
want to go skiing I don't want to lay on
a beach I don't want to buy a mesera I
want to build
businesses I may want to build other
businesses I'll build other businesses
besides vayer you can sell this but you
just need to go build you're a builder
yeah I guess I am you're a builder funny
that you said that you've done so
extremely well at trying to influence
people but I I heard Ty Lopez say
something recently that he said the most
influence he has is people under the age
of 25 because when you get over 25 or a
little bit past that it's harder to
learn do you agree with that or not I
don't I do think people at a younger age
are impressionable I just think it takes
a great communicator to break through
somebody that's older just got to find
your angles you broke through to me and
I'm 49 years old so that that is that
doesn't it yeah absolutely and um the
last thing I want to ask you about is
you come to this place you go all over
the world work with success resources do
you enjoy being on the road all the time
I do yeah I love people there's no
chance of me meeting these people and so
it's fulfilling to me I love the process
and uh and of course you you miss your
family of course there's sometimes you
just miss the same routine locally um
but I get enormous joy out of
interacting with people of all shapes
sizes Creeds religions cultures
and you know I can't replicate this in
New York and so I get enormous amounts
of Joy from it and when we lastly think
about how social media is impacting
people all over the world and what
you're doing about getting that message
out there I I look at that and it
resonates with me it took me 3 years of
listening to you but then the mess
thinking and I went no stop arguing with
yourself stop fighting this just start
doing something about it and in 2017
January is when I started my journey I
love it and it was like and I produce
videos every single day now just like
you said to do I'm on Tik Tok like you
said to do I'm on LinkedIn like you you
said to do and I can't understand why
people won't take the action the same
reason you
didn't but I did and and they will too
you sure I think so I appreciate your
time okay take care take
care thank
you thank you brother okay we got to
watch to the kitchen this way this way
Gary thank you so much thank you so much
good to see
you i'
respect I love you bro love you I love
you too man have a wonderful New Year in
10 years this week was our best
interview it's crazy ping me on the
exact date I want to do like a 10e
throwback be here though yeah yeah me
too me
yes this is one of your um guys you you
guys already taking a all
right nice to meet
you it's a real pleasure how are you
good that's good goodly stag
early you okay how have you been good
man good so get some volunteering here
now can I get a picture sure St radi
you're taking your picture come on
please all right can we get a picture
ofed
100% my phone is ringing right now who
got a camera take his photo sorry my
phone just rang oh there it
goes thank you so much for
coming it's always
good it's always
[Music]
good
today's felt today's speech felt good
it's a good one yeah definitely oh the
crow loved it but you've spoken here
before right
yes where are you often next then New
York thank god oh it's been busy yeah
that's why you like it right you like to
be busy just cost savings cost savings
next time you tell me you'll stay here
hope you enjoyed it thank you brother
thank you hope you enjoyed it take care
cheers we have to tell you how are you
I'm doing great how are you such a
pleasure yeah it's
awesome um I Believe In
Unicorns um worry about your own zit you
didn't quite say that you said like when
you're going to high school and you're
worried everybody's worried about their
own zit right like everybody was so
scared about their zit meanwhile when
you walked into school they were all
worried about their own zit but I
thought it was like worry about your own
zit [__] I've got mine yes that
was much more yeah so someone's
consuming content that was drill are
saying that to
you I want you to know I have my own
slogan I have my own
Mantra if you can see it you can be it
uhhuh I'm aan of that all my life so
good that's what I was talking about
today if you see one person that did it
that comes from what you come from then
it's I believe in that and it's not even
see one person if you can see your self
doing it I get it and that's what I told
k no that's yes life it's yes life yes I
totally get it I'm a big
fan yeah and then I had a lot of stories
to tell I didn't tell them so we'll have
to get together again oh darn yeah I'm
like a PO I know uh and so and so tell
me about your time you're so you'll be
in Abu Dhabi how many for 3 years Y what
percentage of your time will you be
there uh 100% you won't tra you I
understand you won't you won't have to
be in Canada 30 days a year I don't know
how it works uh no I'll be in Canada
from time to time I'm going in December
for uh it's going to be so happy Matthew
hey it's Gary ve I'm hanging out with
Mom you know how that is but I'm super
frustrated cuz I was hoping you'd be
here we're going to have to make that
happen big news I'm going to be in
Edington next year in March so hopefully
that will be the date but hey thank you
so much for consuming the content it
means so much to me that it's brought
you some value and I just genuinely
can't wait to DAP it up and hug it up
and I'll talk to you soon and your mom's
rad see you a Gary that was so nice
oh my God my heart just melt my heart
just
melted um do you know how Matthew's
going to like I don't even know Matthew
but like out yeah it's so sweet he said
just tell him he helped me when I was
down I was like yeah he totally did kids
live in the dream now let's take a
picture I want to get a picture of both
of you so you have that yeah and I'm
going to send it to an too and say look
it happened an's going to die I told her
we're doing this so she's
excited and uh um yeah so I'll
definitely of course that's on video
mode photo mode yeah get the bersel out
of uh this is my good side though I know
you said no glow lights I was the one
who like don't [__] ENT the glow
lights don't kill the glow for
yourself you got the F bombs down fly
you did fly where did you grow up
Montreal Montreal City I'll try take my
phone I can get it
to yeah yeah stick with me this is like
this is historic it's funny I failed all
my classes but one history and I never
understood why until very recently
history will give you the answer to this
question if you really want to nerd out
about this no matter how powerful AI is
or machine learning or augmented cars
farming was what everybody did and then
tractors came along like technology has
always upended you know how many people
were in the the horse business when
there was no
cars this is this is historic yeah but
with the invention of AI yes we' decided
to demonize
it it's the
reverse I would argue I'm not saying but
it's
prediction sure based on you putting
in you don't put in you don't get
predicted you're in the framework it I I
would argue that nobody cares about
privacy I know that to be true I can see
the yes
sir thank you much um my question is I'm
I'm trying to place what you said into
what we are currently please yeah by the
way if anybody wants to go very very
specific I'm here to bring value I'm
happy to answer something very please
don't mind so we're in the middle of a
cold mine acquisition in South Africa
okay so it's a distress asset 35,000
miners lost their job and we've just
started a social media campaign
internally to Target the actual Miners
and tell them with hearts and Minds that
we are going to be that we want their
votes in a process to vote for us
because we believe that we because we
will be paying them 100 cents of their
un salary we go in there and do what we
did you're trying to convince them that
you're the right guys for it to go to
okay what has now happened is because of
the likes of the great ha
Facebook all the comments that are
flying about about using social media to
actually influence decisions we've been
told by our by the you know government
to slow down our social media okay
because they're saying that we should
not be using it very we should not be
using it in an aggressive manner to
influence outcome but I need the votes I
understand how well how would you see
that I see two things in that statement
a I'd like to listen carefully to what
was just said what was just said wildly
confirms so much of what I've been
saying for a
decade we are now at a point where
there's enough Consciousness and data
that governments them this is why
blockchain is the most interesting
conversation in the world if bless you
if blockchain hits
scale it has taken out all the leverage
of governments themselves except for
bombs think about think about So my
answer to you what do you do in that
scenario when you have to fight City
Hall and they control the rules you have
to be very careful I don't know the game
of chicken and Bluff that you have to
play with the government is not
something I'll have enough context on
right I just wouldn't know what to you
know I just don't have the Dynamics but
but because tonight you know anytime I
do anything I want to bring value
imagine we are now in a place where
governments are having conversations
with institutions to limit their ability
to use a free
product there's never any listen there's
never been anything like it just so you
know and to your point I would argue for
the people that are the shrewdest here
much like real
estate it'll be interesting to see how
much this could go
away Iran has unrest they shut down the
whole internet there's nothing else you
need to
know you
know not super complicated this is the
great
power the ones that know how to use it
will benefit the ones who don't will be
at detriment I'm fascinated by
organizations's ability to spend money
to try to communicate on things that are
dead or at best
wildly
overpriced watching every one of these
Brands put up Billboards out here on
these beautiful streets and knowing that
for a penny on the dollar they can do
four times the impact on Instagram makes
me smile I find it
fascinating so you mentioned privacy yes
see and and you you hinted to your but
between the gdpr and other acts of
privacy and all the way to where where
Facebook announced Libra their currency
y what's your point of view in that
space I don't think humans
care and I think governments do and that
will be the game it's a tax it's a
political play it's a control play
control play it's a control play
whatever that may be Europe thinks of
control One Way Russia things controll
right just it depends on where you live
worrying what's that don't is that
worrying I would argue that if you
actually have a thoughtful two-month
conversation with yourself about privacy
that if everybody knew everything about
everybody we would be the happiest
people on
earth I really do it's a very
interesting conversation if you play it
out I believe that everybody's
unhappiness in this room has to do with
shadows Shadows Shadows the secrets that
you have inside of
you I really believe that and I'm
watching it very
carefully I saw you a clip on education
yes and you were very specific about
being outdated the the way that
education is packaged in 2020 and sold
is wildly outdated our kids are being
taught to memorize things that they have
the information on on their phone
education in the world today is strictly
a brand play almost every parent in this
room only believes in education because
of the brand leverage deployed against
where the kid goes nothing else so what
should
we uh what would you suggest
I think I think it's very dangerous I
like talking in macro because I don't I
hate tell the thought of telling
somebody what to do with their children
is out of bounds for me everybody knows
their own situation in the
macro I think that education is a
foregone conclusion of losing its
leverage I don't think we do anything I
think it's inevitably going to happen I
would argue that our kids generation
will be the last will be either the last
or the first generation to not value the
brand of college that we that
close I I think PE you know what people
are very bad at
history I mean college is a very modern
Roi it's no different than Mentor
capital or hedge funds these things are
not that
old lots of things have 30-year runs 70E
runs 100 Year runs I think we have a
very bad relationship with time and and
we think our world is the
world and uh I think it's EX extremely I
mean it's it's it's it's it's becoming
laughable you're starting to as somebody
who's a bad student and grew up in the
80s and 90s and was somebody who always
shared ideas you know a lot of people
first thought my views on education were
predicate on me being a bad student sure
in some ways I could it's very sad that
I got no value from 6 to 18 being who I
am it's sad I could be much further
along in thoughts and hypothesis and
productivity an
impact you know so I think they're very
vulnerable
so but real quick I apologize but
they're not vulnerable in societies
where brand is everything they're really
not vulnerable in Dubai everything's
logo here because it's important for the
people the
brand people want to say that their kids
going to Harvard yeah to look good in
front of other people this is one big
game of
insecurity that's thing right that's a
world thing that's a absolutely that's
everywhere but to and I think you'll
agree with this there are clearly
certain pockets of the world that it's
more intense than others it is more
intense in Dubai than it is in Peru you
know so like you know but yes no
question that's based on fin that's
based on 100% 100% you know or and as
you know like I think everyone's kind of
bright here there's also certain
cultures where even if it's not
Financial there is that variable or or
occupation engineer do you know 100%
it it's it's actually interesting to me
that I'm like oh no I might be at the
tail end of my business talk career I
might spend the next 20 years of my life
talking about parenting I'm very
concerned about I I don't think people
especially of wealth understand what
they're actually doing if a child is 22
years old and taking money from their
parents they are deeply
depressed but that is not a belief of
the parents that are paying for their
kids apartments in New York City that is
not the
belief don't forget don't don't forget
real quick I apologize for interrupting
don't forget this the majority of this
room comes from the generation where
they themselves and definitely their
parents borrowed money from parents and
paid back but the thought of just giving
and see
you I mean in 20 to 50 years we've gone
completely from an amazing thing for
parents to do was to lend money that you
would pay back to children feeling as
though it's just owed that you're on the
payroll until forever that's the parents
fault that's not the kids we I watch 40
to 80 year olds make fun of Millennials
when they created
them we created
them we've created incredible
entitlement and entitlement is the
quickest
path to a really sad place and we're
going to blame social
media we're going to technology cuz we
are not good at being held accountable
for our
actions so what are the
drawbacks uh a lot of things I mean when
you have an open platform you have the
ability for bad voices to scale
agenda yeah because I feel with
communication your subing or become
reality sometimes I would argue that
letting 12 men around the world for 70
years dictate what reality is it was a
really bad problem you have cuz life's
about right life's about
Alternatives no yeah yeah it is I agree
but depends on how you see it well I
agree with you 100% depends what yeah I
agree what I'm saying I couldn't agree
with you more I agree that it's what
perspective I would rather have an open
market because I'm a buyer that humans
in the macro are good and that an open
market Market of communication is better
than Rupert Murdoch and 17 other people
completely dictating the thoughts of
society through print and television
that's what I would argue I have a funny
feeling that the people that benefited
from that system would disagree with me
because they don't have the empathy to
look at it from a
ho that's what I but I'm not saying I'm
right to your point I think this is a
perspective game I just intuitively
believe in humans and open
markets what's really funny is all my
friends who are quite wealthy and I have
many of them love open
markets but want to keep this market
closed because they're making money I
understand hypocrisy is very easy to
detect sorry going back to the subject
par yes so within specialization what do
you think are the subject or the the
professions that might
actually it's I don't I think I think
that's a tough game for example one
thing that I was arguing for the last 5
years which the math is starting to show
in my favor was 5 years ago everybody
decided to make their children
coders and I kept saying guys the reason
coders are valuable today is nobody
wanted to do it 10 years ago and all the
Nerds were doing it and that's it's just
called supply and demand if every body's
a coder then coding in 20 years is going
to be $11 an hour job somebody once said
that your kids don't Cod they're not
going to make it in the future I don't
think that person's right I could be
wrong but again I use history this has
happened a lot something gets hot
everybody does it the value this is life
is supply and demand it really is it's
why intention is the big one it's why
I'm doing everything that I'm doing with
myself you know what's fun about what I
talk about is again I'm not teaching
this I'm living it every day this is my
dog food I'm eating
it you know so I don't know but I will
say this one thing that has emerged to
me as a hypothesis because I don't like
guessing I like everything you know it's
fun for me to talk here because I'm
talking about things that I know versus
things that I Perce you know it's these
are perceptions and things of that
nature but the Tactical stuff the
LinkedIn Tik Tock or the media's under
PR that's just tactical I know some of
the perspectives are perspectives but I
will say this I do believe emotional
intelligence is an incredibly Rising
asset I believe things are getting
commoditized with
technology and that EQ is starting to
outpace every other skill and so I'm
very excited that empathy and gratitude
and kindness and compassion and sympathy
are becoming business Advantage skill
sets so people talk talk about keeping
Millennials in the workforce and we
judge Millennials for moving around
they're they're not entitled they have
options everyone's like these kids want
to be vice president in a year right all
that they have options the ability if
you have a half a brain to make $200,000
a year on the internet at 22 doing 37
things I can rattle law for you is very
high the [__] are they going to get paid
$86,000 to do [__] work that we did
as
kids 90% of this room looking around
would have done it too you would have
left
to you wouldn't be in this room if you
wouldn't have left to it's timing we're
imposing a prior World on their reality
now do I think they're entitled yes I
think because of the stuff I was talking
about earlier which is we paid for
everything paid for
everything yes sir um lot of talk about
you know Steve Jobs didn't let his kids
use the iPad right media consumption uh
with with young adults and children
what's your view generally on media
consumption of young adults and children
and if your view is positive what kind
of media do you think
ISO I want my kids to consume technology
and information 24 hours a
day
2re 24 hours a day they won't and I
understand I I think people really
demonize the realities because they
didn't grow up with it like what world
do you think our children are going to
live
in and I'm listen to your point earlier
which I think was the right Point
everything in life is
balance and so what I can tell you is it
that doesn't scare me I know they won't
I'll I I'll give you one what people
don't realize is the digital world is
forcing people to be more active not the
other way
around people are living a PR version of
their life and they're doing more
physical activities and different
activities for the photo on the digital
platform I'm serious I'm serious people
are really bad at looking at data people
are bad at looking at people are very
good at having an
opinion people are very bad at looking
at macro
data G question please um you spoke
about dist passion and you spoke about
content yes what are your ABCs of
compelling content uh that's thank you
uh I'm very big on the truth it's really
important like it seems basic but almost
nobody wants to put out the truth in
their content almost
nobody
so uh
context content that respects the [__]
at of the distribution Channel but more
importantly of the psychology of the
person while they're on that platform
like you know I could see you being
intuitive about this you and me on
Instagram are totally different than you
and me on LinkedIn different just like
we're different here now than if we were
at a party then if great that is
something people struggle with
tremendously um I'm extremely passionate
on uh cultural
currency you cannot imagine how much you
can do when you actually understand the
slang of the moment
being cool or just knowing what that
audience wants right like knowing what
memes what slang what colors what like
all that stuff has in it's unbelievable
current currency is incredibly valuable
um and probably the single reason that I
broke out from everybody else I think
the single most important thing about
content is consuming the qualitative
feedback after you put it out qualita
qualita have not quantitated correct the
Quant the commodity everybody else has
it too the qual and the ability to
synthesize the qual so the insights that
come out of the water AKA read every
single comment and have the natural
ability to glean the Insight that lets
you inform the next piece of
content and that's why it's such a fun
game because everyone's going to lean
into the
math everybody leans into the the black
and white because it's black and white
all the upside is in the
gray yes ma'am so teens developing their
brains that time I'm sorry teens teens
develing their brains and you say the
most important thing is EQ but they're
all tce 24 hours a different kind of
empathy no one know I would argue they
get so much more empathy out of that
they have so much more context and
content
consumption right I I think that you
know it's very interesting to me that we
would put a piece of paper and a pencil
on a pedestal but we would demonize a
phone right like why is writing a letter
a more noble act than sending a
text we
glamorize the
distribution but not the
communication it's what we do it's what
old people
do it's always been like that go read
the article go read actually I'm not
kidding I I think this you know I'm
trying to think about like wow this is a
really crowd what can I say that like
forever brings them value go read old
old stuff go read all the newspaper
articles about the
kaleidoscope and how it was going to
destroy the children of the
world real real go read it you think
you're reading about the
iPhone the number one un underrated
brand in the world is the human
being guys our brain capacity hasn't we
have us are not even touching
it you don't think they can handle the
screen it's
laughable I know and it's very it's an
unpopular take I'm just hoping that I
can stay healthy enough to be heralded
for seeing it but the kids are not here
what's
that that want that would change
how shaping their personality since on
the other side of course it's not
reality of course it's of course it's
real
but of course I think it's shaping their
minds but of course it's reality you
mean people pring themselves yeah very
ex we've always done that yeah I mean
why do you think people buy cars and
homes okay I'm I'm talking about social
media so for example today when you're
talking about specific social media
where you no longer know the truth
behind that product of you don't know
the truth behind anything this is what
humans do beings do you have a much
better chance of finding truth on the
internet than you do in your
neighborhood and College
in what sense you're you're limited to
the information you see in front of him
and everybody's been faking the whole
time people always
fake you went on a great trip to St
Barts with your family this year did
you I mean it guys and you know this you
know it it's always been like this we're
just seeing it now social media exposes
us it doesn't change us it's the mirror
yeah it's the
mirror it's the mirror I'm telling you
it's the mirror which is why the
insights are so powerful it's the
[__]
mirror and if you get really good at
reading the mirror you know exactly
where things are
going um I agree with a lot of what
you're saying but I do think uh when
you're interacting with someone face to
face that intuition and that reading of
the body language and those couldn't
agree more that are are more valuable
than this is my opinion and I'm happy to
hear your I I would argue that it's more
valuable than you know seeing a
heartfelt post on whatever uh well first
of all there are so many people in this
room who have the inability to read the
subtleties in a human interaction my
father's ability to read any body
language is zero yeah we're all wi peers
so we're very
realiz so I would argue that they're
just different uh they're different
skills as somebody who's incredibly good
at it in real life I've been incredibly
good at it in digital life which is why
I've been able to glean the insights I
don't know CU I just haven't thought
about it so I'm glad this is why I love
this now I'm going to is that skill map
or can one be good in one place or the
other probably one good place in the
other other you just think cuz there's
so many chemical variables but yeah I I
I agree they're different I don't
necessarily agree On's better than the
other I would also argue that just
because you're on your device all day
doesn't mean you can't do the other
thing I know many of my daughter's
10-year-old friends who I analyze crazy
who only live in their phone who have
ridiculous body language understanding I
would argue that it's a natural skill
and sure there's practice but let's
remember we're still not in era where
these kids live in a bubble all day as
much as they're on their phone my
friends we were on things too we were
reading magazines but for PE girls in my
high school looked at Vogue and Cosmo
for 4 hours while being on a three-way
call with their girlfriends for 4 hours
after school the hell's the
difference you know I'm telling you once
you this is this is what it is it's when
you take a step back look at it from a
different perspective contextualize the
past you start getting into some very
interesting things which is humans are
consistent and will always always and
have
always wrapped themselves around the
modern technology and communication
things this notion that this is now the
time where this is all going to fall
apart is
audacious let me you said something
about Big Data can you say a little more
of that yeah it's an extremely fun
buzzword in government and big business
and everybody's got it and nobody's
doing anything with
it so but you can do a lot with it
unbelievable amounts but everybody
thinks just having it is the
win that's like having a
basketball you know I'm not LeBron James
what you do with the big data that
actually takes human beings there are so
many emerging jobs that we're not
talking about I'm I'm hiring hundreds of
people to just analyze data based on my
belief on my subjective belief on their
ability to be intuitive with
it but a sorry AI can analyze
quantitative
data
not that's why the math is the commodity
while everybody's going all in on the
math so what always
happens right look what happened in
Hollywood everybody made tons of money
for 50 years on the distribution now all
the money is in the
IP the internet is the middle just so
you know if you're in the business of
being in the middle it's just a matter
of time it could be 40 years and you're
retired and you don't give a [__] but it
is the middle the internet is the middle
bookstores got hit first then limousines
and taxes you will be hit it's just a
matter of time you spoke about the
middle right now and you do in
blockchain 20 minutes ago blockchain CU
I think that's that's something that
most of us are bringing up about but
how's it going to it's a framework like
the internet's a framework except the
Internet has people in the middle it's
called Apple Facebook Amazon there's
Gatekeepers that's why they become the
biggest companies in the world
blockchain
doesn't and if it scales and becomes
where we play you're talking about a
very interesting world is it scill or B
I think it's if because I don't think
governments will let it scale as
naturally as we let the internet
scale
America China and
Russia have zero Collective vested
interest in letting blockchain
scale so that's going to be interesting
I don't I that's you know listen you can
see I speak with a lot of conviction you
can see that when I hear another Insight
I get excited about the thought this one
I've spent a lot of time on I just can't
put the pieces in my head together just
it just seems you know I just can't go I
don't you know but but I can add the
context of if because if you play what
I'm pretty good at Naturally is playing
chess if this happens and this Happ
right um I don't overvalue the past
which is a lot of what the questions
here are about um and I play that one
when I play you know that one was fun
because that's where I got into like
some pretty headyy people I know in
government and I just can't can't get to
my answer on that one I just don't know
how that one that it's just it's intense
it it becomes almost
a war of of the humans on Earth versus
the governments at Earth at
scale it's really intense it's pretty
interesting you
know um so bit more specific I'm into
manufacturing okay okay so we
manufacture what just fing systems so
we're trying to get into the African
market for example y makes sense and the
way to do it is basically we have to go
there and go into exhibition and do you
think yes the internet would solve my
problem if I had $100,000 $50,000
$10,000 you would sell a lot more pipes
than a [__]
exhibition I mean by you telling me who
buys the
pipes and then me going and figuring out
where that decision maker consumes
information and then me creating
information that builds brand equity for
your business which then leads to top of
the funnel sales opportunities so if I
get this right it's to
identify the final decision maker
always and then go back I'll give I'll
give you one that's going to blow
everybody's mind I Market to 14-year-old
girls on Tik Tok because I have the data
that proves to me that the 14-year-old
girl in America now is influencing the
mother because mother's no longer mother
they want to be friends and the
14-year-old girl is influencing the
mother and the mother is the one that
buys the product for the father when I
try to sell deodorant this is real when
I try to sell deodorant to 50-year-old
men I Target 14-year-old teenage
girls
that's it's interesting
right
question the whole like advertising and
was kind of based on like brand grow
through reach right it's wrong right so
what is your new pces now Brands grow
through relevance at scale to as to as
many cohorts as possible until until
there's diminishing returns on the
creative and the media that you need
50,000
content that's it you got it that book
how Brands built is destroying every cpg
in the
world and I'm pumped by the way just so
you know what I'm up to because I want
to buy the New York Jets in America uh
I'm building this machine waiting for
the economy to collapse Going Global so
I have multiple arbitrages and then I'm
going to buy historic Brands and
refurbish them either in new Geographic
places or in contemporary
communication we have a couple of
minutes so any pressing questions and
then probably we have some time for for
pictures so please go
ahead yes sir um looking back your
crystal wall you know forward 20 years
what um startups do you think you know
would be
tomorrow's the these are always hard for
me because what I'm much better at is
this moment versus the future but I will
say this I haven't invested in a long
time once in a blue moon but I'm saving
a lot of money to invest in a specific
thing when the iPhone came along I knew
I knew it was the next medium and that's
why I invested in in Facebook Twitter
Tumblr I did extremely
well whatever whenever I think that the
voice devices are at scale I will invest
in all the apps that are being built on
top of
it that's what I'm waiting for I'll give
you an example there's a startup I know
right now that uses Alexa that when you
start reading your child in the room
there cool is it Dr Ro so I this is what
I do I get in early and I watch and I'm
patient and I look for timing the reason
I don't lose a lot of money as all my
friends invest in VR and AR it's too
early the consumer is not ready the
technolog is ready we're not
ready uh when you start reading the book
to your child Alexa recognizes it and
then starts doing sounds if you're like
and the boy was running through the rain
Alexa is like sh it's amazing and it was
awesome and it works already and it was
a year and a half ago and it was a year
and a half ago so um
voice voice is the toll booth what I'm
very good at is investing in toll booth
employees I'm not good at building the
toll booth I'm a very good toll booth
collector I know that voice is the next
toll booth and then I'm going to be
looking for the collectors got it you
understand the analogy
I I'm I'm not going to build the iPhone
but I knew to invest in apps I'm not
going to build Facebook but I know how
to leverage it for me I know how to use
it more than it uses me I would argue
that we can all use these platforms but
we've all bought into the headlines that
they're using us let me remind everybody
that these companies are so bad they're
free they're [__]
free you're also more than welcome to
not use
it when you watch television they run
ads too they're using
you when you read newspapers there's an
ad when you turn the page they're using
you mainstream media is demonizing these
platforms because they're about to kill
mainstream
media people are not thoughtful that is
something I've learned so you agree that
U and this is an extreme Case by
Cambridge analytica
Insidious influences you agree that
that's incorrect no I do not
I believe that if I put in front of you
something that it's your job to decide
if that's true or not I believe that
those people wanted to believe what was
put in front of them based on the
behavior that they put into the machine
no I do
not that's like blaming somebody who
buys something on a commercial while
they watch Fox News that demonizes
immigrants no I do
not I believe that people are very very
onedimensional
in this conversation and I came here
tonight to add a dimension to the
conversation I wasn't I wasn't lying
when I told he was going to be very
provocative so you can you saw that uh
guys real quick I got D's and Fs my
entire childhood I'm serious because I
know a lot of people probably have like
we need to have this conversation of
self-awareness we all have people we
care about in our lives we need to
reverse engineer people one by one we
have the options you know like I feel
really weird right this minute that like
was a very good talk and I'm like
sitting and analyzing myself and I'm
like [__] how did this kid [__] get
D's and Fs that's the
punchline that's the punchline we need
to figure this
out so not only better better business
people but better parents uh thank you
Gary thank you
guys
[Applause]
remember to thank you my friend thank
you so much charity Bo I'm on the board
of both of them the reason we're raising
more money than most people is because
of
this also I'll give you a huge
Insight never convert
cont thank you
s I hope you enjoy it I did
more
more people always were that way I would
argue that now that we're putting
Spotlight on it yeah before we didn't
have enough information so to use your
barley example whatever it's like I only
met three people two said barley was
great one was [__] y I haven't gone out
and been able to seek my kind of I want
to find as many people as I can as [__]
yes whereas now we have that wider
information but we we then just use that
filter to then extreme polarize I've Us
in everything that's right and I guess I
don't know where I'm going with that but
it's no longer a freedom of it's not
almost from a human
there not
Freedom it was always more focused no
it's always been that it really has like
that's what people did why did have the
ability to find you didn't have the
ability to go that laser you know what I
mean I think it's depends on how much
how you define laser right you know
right this conversations hinges on what
you mean by
that
laser Marx was able to get communism out
Hitler was able to do his thing us was
like these things were were were
happening yeah they've always happened
the question becomes do we believe in
the human spirit that over time at an
open scale we more good than bad I do
and and I think that that's what we have
to talk
about you know because because you know
we make it very basic about good guys
versus bad guys but it's much deeper
than that like like when you look at
look if you look at Europe Europe is a
nonfunctioning player in the world but
it was good or was it and was if it was
open would have it gotten that entitled
you see where I'm going and so what
happened is Europe gets entitled then
America gets entitled then China will
get entitled then Africa will get
entitled like it's the same old game
this is why Empires my my debate is the
reason that Empires happen is that but
if you open it up you'll eat a lot of
[__] which is what we're doing now but
over the long
term the light is better than the
dark in the
yeah we're in we're in the eating [__]
stage
analytic but it all depends and he said
it best it all depends the perspective I
don't think we're in eating [__] face I
think I'm in the creating enormous
Legacy for myself stage cuz I'm going to
use the tool instead of cry about the
tool people are crying about the tool
and getting off the tool ask one one
more specific question so our company
sells medicines to the poorest in Africa
basic it's low cost
medicine you therefore argue actually my
a dollars should go not so much in
conventional media but almost buying my
pharmacist and smartphon so they can
then receive the digital stuff that I
yes I do yes I would argue that and
what's fun about these conversations is
and why these are great evenings is now
you can at least have that as a even
correct you even have it as a day do I
mean get a smartphone $30 this is why I
win a lot I have all your data points
and then I'm hypothesizing other data
points and then I'm AB testing the data
points and then I'm making decisions if
you don't even create the other data
point you have no
context thank you very much thank you so
much it was really nice thank you for
your questions and statements thank you
for having me have a good
evening thank you for coming I love your
pants
wel did you ever come out the Africa
side Africa yeah you know what's funny
it's the next kind of place for me right
like Focus please it's very much on my
mind it's very much I've spent some time
in Ghana cuz I buil schools there with
pencils of Promise so we're doing water
kios in Ghana love it I mean I mean this
is great can you thank you we'll connect
some phenomenal data just last week has
presented to me so we we go to small
villages to try and Trace where the
where the populations are thousand
people or L love and I was presented
with Facebook
data we met we met on on top of Ghana
where the populations are of thousand
people because that's where that's where
Facebook is being used phenomenal it's
really phenomenal there Facebook
everyone's going to talk about the kid
that saw somebody bad on the internet
and shot up his school nobody will talk
about the 47,000 wonderful things that
happened that day this is what humans
do this is what humans do focus on the
focus rubber
necking right headline reading do you
know any opinion including myself do you
know any opinions we have here off of
two
headlines we have deep opinions about
stuff off of reading two headlines not
the
article yeah but the article is based on
an opinion and a report I love you for
that you're right it become but forget
about the truth you'll appreciate this
couldn't agree with you more I'm just
saying do you know how many opinions we
all have this smart room including
myself on things completely based on one
newspaper headline and one bottom line
BBC line that's it that's completely
formed
it's
fascinating my big argument in the room
is we can get very heady and we did a
little bit here tonight on a business
front please please pay attention to
what's happening because it is real
estate I mean when I tell you everything
I believe in is not as easy as it was 3
years ago it's not and it'll be less
easy 3 years from
now and you
know and people have their people are
not investing in these channels because
of the headlines of I hate Cambridge
analytica or they tried it once and it
didn't work because really they're a
sales organization not a brand
organization or a million other things
or the reports
internally or their CMO is old school
and they don't even understand it so
they say it's [__] and you have to
believe them or a million [__] other
things I can tell
you okay got to
go thank you
thank you so much thank you so
much oh it's such a good picture thank
you I love two things one we take a
picture yes hi Hi how are you and then
you're going to make a video for his
daughter Journey she lost like 100 lbs
she documented the whole thing on social
media turned her life around she's
amazing she's a big fan you have to say
something I know what to do I know what
to do Lulu so I got to Lulu it's me Gary
B I'm here with your Dad we're super
proud I'm super pissed we're not meeting
but let's fix that in 2020 see you
thanks so
much was
aming
just so good to see
you take care thank you for having I
hope enjoy it was amazing amazing hi I
hope you enjoyed it I did thank you so
much thank you so much take care
yeah